So, Hallöchen, herzlich willkommen. Wir sind's, die Freakshow.
Und ich liebe das, wenn immer Dinge dann auf den letzten Moment nicht funktionieren.
Wieso geht diese Scheiß-Tasse hier nicht?
Mit Dingen meint Tim Technik.
Ja, aber deine gehen, ja? Deine geht auch?
Meine geht.
Ich kann mal drücken.
Auch. Tim, es geht nur bei dir nicht.
Ja, dann ist wahrscheinlich der Abo alle. Ich check das mal kurz.
Okay, wie auch immer, ist die Freakshow Nummer 288.
Und wir haben den 9. Januar 2025 und das heißt neues Jahr.
Genau.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß am Jahresende, wo auch immer ihr wart.
Ja.
Du hattest es für sich gleich angesprochen, ne, Roddy? Dass du Spaß hattest, das wusste ich.
Wieso?
Na, ich hab dich aus dem Augenwinkel beobachten können. Wirktest jetzt nicht gelangweilt.
Achso, du meinst jetzt genau zum Jahreswechsel. Ich meine halt diese ganze Zeit,
so Weihnachten, wenn alles einschläft und dann so familiär und was dann nicht wird.
Und die ganze Zeit fangen die aus dem Augenblick.
Dann fangen die bunten Lichter an in Hamburg.
Für uns ist ja Kongress sozusagen die Zeit und danach muss man ja eh ausschlafen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ja doch.
Das stimmt, genau. Na dann fangen wir dann vielleicht auch gleich mal mit dem,
38C3 an, würde ich sagen. Auch
wenn ich jetzt hier meine Kapitelmarke von Hand setzen muss. So ist das.
Genau. Guten Abend.
Like an animal.
Ja. Ah, es war wirklich nur der Akku war alle.
Kaum macht man es richtig, funktioniert es auch gleich. Grüße an Clemens.
Ja, wir waren auf dem 38C3 und ich weiß, einige von euch waren nicht auf dem
38C3 und ihr findet das Thema vielleicht total langweilig.
Kapitelmarke.
Kapitelmarke. Aber wir müssen trotzdem darüber reden, weil wir waren ja da und
irgendwie ist so ein Kongress immer,
nah so ein potenziell transformatives Erlebnis für manche in manchen Momenten.
Also auf jeden Fall gab es Kongresse, die,
für mich waren. Ob dieser jetzt dazu gehört, das lasse ich jetzt mal offen,
aber ich hatte auf jeden Fall Spaß, auch wenn ich noch nie so sehr an einem
Kongress teilgenommen habe,
wie dieses Mal in puncto, dass ich an diesem Kongress so teilgenommen habe,
wie man vielleicht an so einem Kongress teilnehmen sollte, indem man mal was macht.
Also so vor Ort an seinem Projekt rumwerkeln und nicht so nur Talks gucken oder
nur rumrennen oder nur feiern oder was weiß ich, sondern so hacken.
Oder sich hinter einem überdimensionierten Bildschirm verkriecht,
wie auch berichtet wurde.
Ja, wie sich das gehört.
Welchen Screen hattest du eigentlich dabei?
Ich hatte meinen alten iMac dabei, den ich kurz vorher dann doch nochmal reaktiviert
bekommen habe mit Open Core. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da jemals drüber geredet haben.
Das ist so ein Hackintosh-Zeug, ne?
Ja, das ist so ein Hackintosh-Zeug, aber es ist minimalinvasiv und ich muss
sagen auch wirklich geil. Also, kurze Erklärung.
Also, ich habe ein iMac von 2009.
Also, das Ding ist 15 Jahre alt.
Und ich habe den ja eigentlich ausgemistet, als ich hier letztes Jahr das Studio
überholt habe. Da habe ich dieses Mac-Studio gekauft. Bla, bla,
bla. Brauchte ich nicht mehr.
Und dann stand da erstmal rum. Und ich habe ja nahezu alles,
was ich hier nicht mehr gebraucht habe, habe ich ja auf E-Mail verkloppt. Und...
Nur diesen iMac und den alten Mac Pro, das habe ich nicht über das Herz gebracht, die zu verkaufen.
Also stand da hier die ganze Zeit unterm Tisch und ich dachte mir so,
auf dem Kongress großer Bildschirm wäre schon ganz geil.
Das ist noch der alte iMac 2009, den kann man noch als externen Bildschirm benutzen.
Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, hol es mal raus, probier es mal aus und so nochmal
vielleicht frisches Betriebssystem aufspielen. Und dann dachte ich mir so,
das mit diesem Open Core wäre eigentlich auch ganz geil, wenn ich den so als
modernes System benutzen könnte.
Weil ich wusste immer, es gibt einen
Hack, mit dem man auch ein aktuelles Betriebssystem drauf machen kann.
Weil das letzte offiziell unterstützte Betriebssystem war High Sierra und dann ist halt Schluss.
Und ja, es gibt dieses Open Core Projekt und das Open Core Projekt macht was ganz Pfiffiges.
Wenn du diesen Open-Core-Installer nimmst oder wie heißt der Open-Core-Legacy-Installer
und den dann auf dem Rechner startest, dann sagt er, okay, prima,
ich würde mich hier gerne mal auf diese Festplatte installieren.
Übrigens Open-Core-Legacy-Patcher.
Patcher, Entschuldigung, Patcher, genau, korrekt. Nicht Installer,
das kam mir eben schon so falsch vor.
Genau, also der normale Weg ist eigentlich der, man startet das Ding,
wählt einen Installer aus von einem alten Betriebssystem und schreibt den auf eine SSD,
Entschuldigung, auf eine SD-Karte oder auf eine SSD, also auf irgendeinem Device, ein externes.
Und der Open-Core-Legacy-Patcher installiert dann noch was dazu.
Also der schreibt nicht nur den normalen Installer von einem aktuellen OS drauf,
sondern er installiert noch was dazu. Und was installiert er dazu?
Er installiert im Prinzip noch eine zweite Bootable Partition,
die nichts anderes enthält als diesen Open-Core-Legacy-Patcher-Code.
Und wenn man dann quasi den Rechner bootet, bootet man davon.
Und alles, was das Ding macht, ist, dass es so eine Art Replacement-EFI ist.
Alte Leute sagen BIOS.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Ja, also BIOS als allgemeiner Begriff und das EFI ist sozusagen das,
was in den moderneren Max dann irgendwann drin war.
Aber der installiert sich halt nicht als neue Firmware, also der brennt nicht
eine neue Firmware, sondern der lädt sich sozusagen nur ins RAM und ersetzt
das normale EFI oder extendet das auf irgendeine Art und Weise.
Also sie haben einen Weg gefunden, wie sie sich sozusagen ins System hängen
können, nur ins RAM und dann bootet er nach und der Code, der dann normal gebootet
wird, denkt so, ah, moderner Rechner, fehlen ein paar Features,
aber ich bin hier gestattet.
Und dann installiert sich das tatsächlich alles ganz easy.
Du hast nicht zufällig den Pimp My Mac Jingle da?
Stimmt, Pimp My Jack. Warte mal.
Gab es mal was. Das gab es mal. Oh Gott, muss ich mal schauen.
Ich bestimmt. Ah ja, hier.
Aber kriegst du den jetzt auch reingeroutet?
Aber was denkst du denn hier? Ich habe ja hier schon den Kanal für die Notfälle
sozusagen vorbereitet.
Und da muss ich nur noch ganz kurz ablenken und bin gleich soweit.
Sag noch mal irgendwas Kluges.
Die Kommentarspalte wird im Nachhinein überlaufen. Mein Gott,
wir haben Dennis' Stimme gehört.
Wir und was Kluges sagen.
So, und wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, müsste das jetzt passen.
Und, wie Sie hören, hören Sie dies, weil ich nicht die richtige Tasse gedrückt habe.
Ach ja, vielen Dank für den Hinweis.
Kam aus dem Slack.
Das kann ich mir jetzt eigentlich hier nochmal auf die Tasse legen.
Da habt ihr echt recht, die alten
Dinger sind doch eigentlich immer noch Goldies. So eine Grüße an Dennis.
Ja genau, also ich habe meinen Mac gepimpt und danach lief das.
Nicht schnell, aber lief. Also
ich konnte sozusagen alles, wo es auch die Hardware für gab, installieren.
Tatsächlich installiert dieser Open-Core-Legacy-Patcher dann,
nachdem man dann quasi final installiert hat, installiert er dann noch allerlei Treiber noch dazu.
Also die haben dann quasi auch noch Backport für die alte Hardware in das neue OS,
um halt Grafikkarte und so weiter noch ein bisschen effizienter anzusprechen
und dann rödelt er noch eine Weile drauf rum und dann ist er irgendwie auch
bedient und das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Naja, und so hatte ich den iMac, den ich erst eigentlich so ein bisschen als
externen Bildschirm gedacht hatte und auch teilweise als solchen benutzt habe.
Die Funktion allerdings geht dann nicht mehr, wenn man ein moderneres OS geboostet
hat. Das wäre jetzt sozusagen Best of Both Worlds gewesen.
Also da brauchte ich dann nochmal ein separates High Sierra, was ich booten muss.
Dann habe ich diese Funktion, weil einfach dieses Tastenmapping dann sozusagen nicht mehr existiert.
Aber es gibt auch keine Hardware-Taste für oder so?
Nee, das ist so Command F2. Warum auch immer.
Also wenn sie das mal wieder einbauen würden in die iMacs, dann würde ich mir
eventuell auch ein iMac kaufen.
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht, aber es hat auch was damit zu tun,
dass die Moderneren halt so eine hohe Auflösung hatten und dann war das gar
nicht möglich über das alte Thunderbolt irgendwie so.
Und jetzt haben sie es auch wieder nie eingebaut, weil Bodennebel,
es gibt wahrscheinlich niemand, der bei Apple arbeitet, der sich noch daran
erinnert, dass es das mal gab oder dass Leute sowas haben wollen würden. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, das Fußvolk soll mehr Hardware kaufen.
Genau, Abdelkader fragt gerade, ob ich auch auf 15.2 gehen konnte und die Antwort ist, konnte ich.
Und ist es wirklich langsam?
Also sagen wir mal so, es war okay zu benutzen.
Es war jetzt nicht schnell und es gibt Dinge, die sind langsam.
Also insbesondere war es interessant mal zu sehen, wie so ein aktueller Mac
Studio bei mir zu Hause im Vergleich, ich habe meinen Code compiled im Vergleich
zu so einem 15 Jahre alten Rechner.
Da ist schon ein bisschen was passiert in der Zwischenzeit.
Ja, es hat eine etwas andere Wupptizität.
Absolut. Gut, aber das war mir ja egal.
Alles, was ich machen wollte mit dem Teil, war mein Flip-Dot-Display zu steuern
und dafür hat es allemal gereicht.
Ja, genau. Jetzt habe ich weit ausgeholt. Das war jetzt quasi nur so meine persönliche Perspektive.
Mit anderen Worten, ich habe gar nicht so viele Talks geguckt,
ich habe ein bisschen was nachgeschaut, bin ein bisschen rumgerannt,
habe ein paar Leuten geredet, aber ich war eigentlich die ganze Zeit am Coden,
weil ich so im Coding-Wahn war.
Ja, und dann habe ich so meinen Kongress verbracht. unter anderem.
Ja, mein Kongress war auch sehr speziell. Aus zwei Gründen.
Zum ersten Mal war es, glaube ich, mein Ersttag, also ich war seit fünf Jahren
nicht mehr auf dem Kongress, sechs Jahre, also viel zu lange her und es war
wieder traumhaft und es ist einfach der Ort, wo man sein will zwischen den Jahren,
egal was man sich vorher für Sorgen macht.
So, ausschlafen wäre doch auch toll und sowas. Nein.
Das geht ja beides. Da will man hin. Wenn man keine Kinder hat,
geht auch beides und das ist jetzt genau Die Überleitung war jetzt mein erster Kongress mit Kindern.
Sprich, ich habe, wie auch schon hier angekündigt, meinen fünfeinhalbjährigen
und meinen gerade acht Jahre alt gewordenen mitgenommen.
Und das war dann ein sehr anderer Kongress, kann man sich vorstellen,
als alle, die vorher waren. weil also die Spiegelregel ganz klar war,
tagsüber nichts als Kinderbespaßung machen und dann abends halt irgendwie noch
ein bisschen frei haben.
Das habe ich mir mit Claudia ein bisschen aufgeteilt, so sie einen Abend,
ich zwei Abende und andere ist dann halt mit Kindern ins Hotel.
Aber das war natürlich auch so ein Fragezeichen, so wie klappt das auch mit
dem unterschiedlichen Alter und das war total awesome.
Also beide Kinder dann hinterher am letzten Tag, oh Papa, da müssen wir jetzt
jedes Jahr hin. Ja, genau, das war der Plan.
Und hier nochmal wirklich maximales Lob in Richtung Kidspace-Orga.
Also wir waren dann wirklich auch tagsüber hauptsächlich im Kidspace unterwegs
und nebenan ist dann ja auch clevererweise gleich der Youth Space,
so dass man also auch altersabhängig so ein bisschen immer zwischen den Seelen
hin und her chargieren konnte.
Und das Programm war toll, die Atmosphäre da war toll, die anderen Eltern waren
entspannt, die meisten Kinder waren cool.
Das hat viel Freude gemacht.
Und meine beiden Racker, da war ich dann doch ein bisschen überrascht,
haben den Kongress dann sehr unterschiedlich bespielt.
Also der Große war vor allen Dingen faszinierend vor diesem großen Legostein,
mit dem man dann da ja wirklich beeindruckend hohe 2 Meter Konstruktionen irgendwie
bauen konnte und sich ganze Burgen und eigentlich hätte er sich gewünscht,
dass er die ganzen Tage einfach von morgens bis abends spät da einfach nur mit den Legosteinen baut.
Wo ich dann denke, dafür musst du aber eigentlich nicht unbedingt auf dem Kongress
fahren. Das kannst du auch woanders haben.
Und der Kleine ist dann den ganzen Tag mit mir und Claudia rumgezogen und hat
wirklich alles mitgemacht.
Der hat gelötet und Elektroschaltung ausprobiert und den ganzen Licht-Klimbim
und wir haben Linoleumschnitt gemacht und gedruckt und gemacht und getan.
Der war da also voll drauf und fand das also total prima, wie er sich da ausprobieren
kann. Das fand ich mit fünfeinhalb Jahren schon echt cool.
Also keine Angst vor etwas kleineren Kindern auf dem Kongress.
Auch das finde ich hat echt richtig gut funktioniert.
Und sie haben beide ihre erste Podcast-Folge aufgenommen. Wie könnte es anders sein?
Stimmt. Ich kann das mal in...
Mit Herrn Snyder.
Genau, der Max Snyder hat,
am letzten Tag einen Podcast gemacht, so mein erster Kongress und da durften
die natürlich nicht fehlen und da gibt es auch wirklich süße Bilder von,
wie jetzt also mein kleiner da mit Bayern Dynamics Headset sitzt.
Wenn ihr in die Aufnahme hier, ich habe es jetzt findet hier den Shownotes,
wenn man sich das anhört, da wird man auch merken, wie unterschiedlich die beiden,
gerade die Situation cool oder nicht cool fanden, weil der Große hatte echt
keinen Bock da drauf. War, glaube ich, noch etwas wortfaul.
Aber der Kleine, der Paul, Tim, du sagst ja immer, Headsets sind einfach wichtig,
weil die Leute dann einfach sofort in so eine Habachtstellung kommen.
Das hat bei dem so funktioniert. Wenn du also merkst, wie hibbelig der ansonsten
ist und was der alles wo noch irgendwie für Eichhörnchen entdeckt.
Der hatte dieses Headset auf und Rücken gerade, volle Konzentration.
Auch wie er gesprochen hat, also der ist in der Logopädie, gerade wegen so dem
einen oder anderen Isho noch, wollten wir noch vor der Schule jetzt noch ausgehen.
Eine Verständlichkeit und eine Sauberkeit der Aussprache. Ich dachte so,
Holla die Wald fehl, Podcasting, es funktioniert.
Einfach dem Kind eine Headset aufsetzen in der Schule.
Er öffnet noch komplett neue pädagogische Möglichkeiten. Nein,
das war also wirklich großer Spaß und von daher war das dann auch für mich ein
toller Kongress zu erleben.
Die nächste Generation, die hat es kapiert und das machen wir doch gerne wieder. Gerne mehr davon.
Ja, ich bin es dieses Jahr noch ruhiger angegangen als sonst so.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe in der Hardware-Tauschkiste, die mehr so ein größerer
Tisch war als eine Kiste von den Regensburgern,
da hatte jemand eine ältere Registrierkasse angeschleppt.
Und da gab es also nicht nur die Einheit mit dem Keypad, sondern da gab es irgendwie
auch eine Schublade zum Auf- und Zumachen.
Und was es auch gab, war so ein, das kennt man auch von Supermarktkassen,
so ein extra Display auf so einem Ständer.
So ein zwei Zeilen, 20 Zeichen, so ein Ding.
Was so raussteht.
Genau, was so raussteht, wo man dann als Kunde auch gut erkennen kann,
was man jetzt bezahlen muss.
Und so ein Ding stand da auch und da war ganz offensichtlich ein serielles Kabel dran und da dachte ich,
das nimmst du mal mit und versuchst du mal, kannst du ja, gibst mal einen Tag
Zeit und kannst es ja abends wieder hinräumen, wenn du irgendwie nichts erreicht
hast und dann ist mir tatsächlich gelungen dieses Teil anzusteuern,
nicht besonders kompetent vor allen Dingen habe ich herausgefunden dass,
USB zu Serielladapter, da gibt es verschiedene Chips,
die da drin sein können und die sind verschieden gut oder gar nicht supported
von macOS und ich habe bei MediaMarkt den einen gekauft,
der keine brauchbaren Treiber für das aktuelle macOS hat.
Also kein Prolific-Chip.
Gleichzeitig habe ich dann aber auch aus einer ganz anderen Ecke noch den Tipp bekommen.
Es gibt ein Serial-Programm, Serial-Terminal-Programm, wie auch immer man es
nennen will, für den Serial-Port,
das für sämtliche von diesen Chips quasi Treiber eingebaut hat.
Serial-Tools?
Das heißt passenderweise Serial-Tools.
Serial.
Das heißt einfach nur Serial.
App-Store oder separat?
Separat, separat. Im App-Store auch, weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall mit
dem Ding habe ich es dann geschafft, da tatsächlich Daten hin zu übertragen
mit dem einen Adapter, den ich hatte.
Ich habe jetzt, als ich wieder da war.
Noch… Das kostet hier 45 Euro, das war es wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Doch, das ist es, ja.
Ah ja, okay.
Also genau, das Decisive Tactics Product Serial, genau das ist das.
Damit habe ich das also hingekriegt, allerdings habe ich nur die 7-Tage-Probe-Version verwendet.
Ich habe nicht die 45 Euro eingeworfen.
Naja gut, ich habe es ja jetzt wieder gelöscht.
Diensterschleichung.
Ich habe dann, wieso? Testversion ist Testversion. Ich habe ganz offiziell getestet,
es für gut befunden, aber ich werde es nicht kaufen.
Das ist sehr kratzt.
Das haben wir heute nochmal. Für gut befunden, aber ich werde es nicht kaufen. Teaser.
Ich habe aber in der Zwischenzeit einen anderen Adapter gekauft.
Also wenn ihr mal einen USB-Serielladapter für einen Mac kaufen wollt,
dann kauft einen mit FTDI-Chip drin. das sind die, die haben die ordentlichen
Treiber, die kann man dann auch einfach verwenden.
FTDI.
FTDI heißt die Firma, die macht ordentliche Treiber.
Future Technology Devices International.
Whatever. Also die, mit dem hat es auf Anhieb funktioniert, einfach.
Okay.
Ich habe da jetzt aber noch nicht weiter gebastelt.
Mir ist noch gar kein FTDI untergekommen. Ich habe bisher immer Prolific Chips
gehabt, dafür gibt es dann tatsächlich einen Treiber im App Store,
den installiert man sich darüber.
Prolific. Das war, glaube ich, genau der, der nicht funktioniert hat.
Den du nicht hattest oder den du...
Den ich nicht zum Laufen gekriegt habe.
Hast du den Treiber dafür installiert aus dem App Store?
Ja.
Okay, hatte ich bisher noch keine Probleme mehr.
Whatever, also FTDI kann ich empfehlen, wie auch immer.
Du hast eine Limited aus Schottland in Familienbesitz.
Ich hätte ja jetzt gedacht, wieder Jet in a China Town, aber offensichtlich, okay.
Oder gibt es noch einen? Keine Ahnung. Die sind nicht alle gleich gut und ich
kann nur empfehlen, wenn ihr einen USB auf Serialadapter kauft,
informiert euch, was für ein Chip da drin ist und ob dafür auch eine ordentliche
Treiber existiert, sonst könnt ihr den direkt in den Elektroschrott tun und einen neuen kaufen.
Genau, das war so das.
FTDI baut auch unter dem Markennamen EVE Embedded Video Engine Grafikchips zur
Ansteuerung kleiner Touch-Displays.
Oh, okay.
Also wenn das so eine positive Erfahrung war, dann kann man sich das ja vielleicht mal anschauen.
So kleine Touch-Displays, das würde ich sowieso gerne mal häufiger zum Einsatz bringen wollen.
Also genau, ich habe das Ding noch zu Hause und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen,
wie man zweimal 20 Zeichentext irgendwas Sinnvolles damit macht.
Da haben wir uns ja im Prinzip mit ähnlichen Kram rumgeschlagen,
weil ich war ja eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit mit der USB-seriellen Schlittstelle
zugange und da viel gelernt.
Um mal so ein robustes Device-Handling einzubauen.
Ja.
Muss man auch mal gemacht haben. Weil irgendwas ansteuern ist immer gut,
aber so rein rausstecken, rein rausstecken im laufenden Betrieb und dann geht's
immer noch smooth weiter, das ist die eigentliche Herausforderung.
Naja, der FTDI-Treiber, der exponiert ja in Slash-Dev ein TTY-Device und eigentlich
exponiert er zwei und einer davon hat so eine ID-Nummer hintendran, die sich nicht ändert.
Das heißt, wenn man immer genau den Chip anstecken will oder den ansprechen
will, dann kann man über dieses Device, ist das vorhanden, ist er eingesteckt,
kannst du ihn ansprechen, ist er nicht vorhanden.
Also ist es wie Serial Number?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, manche machen das mit Serial Number, manche nummerieren beliebig durch.
Das hatte ich jetzt irgendwie bei verschiedenen, also alles mit Prolific,
aber trotzdem haben sich alle irgendwie so komisch verhalten.
Mal mit Serial, mal wenn wo keine Serial da war, dann nimmt er wohl irgendeine
Random Number oder sowas.
Wie gesagt, alle...
Alle empfehlen FTDI. Ich tue das hiermit auch. Fertig.
Ja, okay, gut. Super. Und da haben die ihren Treiber im App Store?
Das fand ich jetzt eigentlich ganz charmant.
Ja. Oder haben sie den im, nee, aber man kann einen runterladen.
Das Lustige ist, dass ab Sequoia sind die Treiber, müssen an einer App dranhängen.
Das heißt, du lädst eine App runter, dann startest du die App und dann gibt
es in der App nur den einen Button. jetzt mal den Treiber installieren.
Ach, du musst den noch installieren?
Naja, es gibt da halt den einen Button oder aktivieren oder weiß ich nicht.
Der Treiber bleibt, glaube ich, im Bundle der App drin.
Ja, aber bei den ProLypik reicht es sogar, wenn du die nur installiert hast.
Also du musst die App nach Slash Applications verschieben.
Gut, das hast du beim App Store ja eh.
Das hast du eh. Ja, und dann irgendwie, du drückst einmal auf den Button und
dann macht der grün und dann ist gut.
Okay. Okay, im Chat gibt es Zuspruch für deine Einschätzung.
FTDI-Bäste, super.
Da sind wir uns ja einig.
Ja, genau, sind wir uns einig.
Gut, ja, ich war auf dem Kongress auch noch in einer anderen Funktion unterwegs
und zwar habe ich es das erste Mal geschafft, mich als Chaos-Pate zu melden.
Das dachte ich schon länger mal an, für Leute, die nicht wissen, was es ist.
Das gibt es seit dem 30C3 und das ist eine so dieser tollen Initiativen auf dem Kongress,
wo jemand sich denkt, hier fehlt auch was, das müsste man mal machen und dann
kriegt das so eine Eigendynamik und mittlerweile, das sind dann immer die,
die hier mit diesen bunten Basecaps mit, wie nennt man die noch gleich,
Propellerhead oben rumlaufen.
Ein Beanie.
Oder hat es den nicht Beanie? Naja, das ist halt so ein Propellerhead,
also dieses generische Nerd-
Nerd-Kleidungsstück, was immer so unterstellt wird, also wo oben so ein Propeller oben auf dem...
Ja, das ist mehr Meme als Realität, ne?
Ja, aber bei den Chaos-Parten ist es dann sozusagen kleidsam.
Muss ich immer sofort an die Abschlussszene von Blue Velvet denken, David Lynch.
Wo der Junge dann auch mit so einem Propellerhead rumläuft.
Oh Gott, den habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, aber den schreibe ich
mir gleich nochmal auf die Liste, den wollte ich schon immer mal...
Ja, mach mal, der altert gut.
Ja, ja, das sowieso, David Lynch altert sowieso gut.
Auch er selber, muss man sagen.
Er als auch, genau. Das kommt hier gleich in meine Letterboxd.
Habe ich wahrscheinlich sowieso schon drin. Mal gucken.
Ja, genau. Und dann war ich, also was ist das?
Chaos Partner ist das Projekt, wo man Leute unterstützt,
die auf dem Kongress das erste Mal sind oder aus anderen Gründen so ein bisschen
Schwierigkeiten oder meinen Schwierigkeiten zu haben oder Hilfe gebrauchen könnten,
in irgendeiner Form mit der Veranstaltung oder den Leuten oder verschiedenen
Gruppen oder Themen in Touch zu kommen.
Und dann melden sich da sozusagen Leute, die denken, dass sie da helfen könnten.
Da muss man jetzt kein altgedienter, ich war schon auf 30 Kongressen Mensch sein.
Sondern… Das könnte eher hinderlich sein.
Wieso?
Naja, weil man da vielleicht ein bisschen eingefahren ist in dem,
was man so zeigen möchte.
Meinst du? Also ich war ja auf 30 Kongressen.
Ich sag nur könnte.
Ja, ja. Habe ich schon verstanden.
Naja, nee, ich meine, das Ding ist, du meldest dich dann halt vorher an und
sagst, hier, ich könnte mir das vorstellen, Chaospart zu sein und dann sagst du halt,
wo so deine Stärken, Interessen oder was weiß ich so liegen,
was du sozusagen meinst, wie man dich am besten sehen sollte oder bewerten sollte
und die bekommen dann eben genauso Gesuche von Leuten, die sich da halt gemeldet
haben und sagen, hier so ich bin.
Wird gern mal jemand an die Seite gestellt bekommen. Und dann gibt es ganz am
Anfang so ein Treffen, wo die meisten auch auftauchen, nicht alle.
Und dann geht man gemeinsam in die Eröffnungsveranstaltung schon mal so als
Kick-Off und quatscht dann so ein bisschen miteinander.
Und dann ist es sehr unterschiedlich. Also mir sind dann drei Personen zugeteilt
worden, von denen ich eine tatsächlich, glaube ich, nur einmal ein paar Sekunden
gesehen habe und die dann irgendwie verdampft ist.
Wohl haben sie die Probleme dann vielleicht nicht so gestellt,
weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Eine andere, mit der ich relativ viel dann noch kommuniziert habe über die Veranstaltung
hinweg, eine andere, wo ich am ersten Tag irgendwie Austausch hatte.
Also sehr unterschiedlich, was dann sozusagen von einem verlangt wird bei Neueinsteigungen.
Das waren jetzt alles, welche, die schon mal da waren.
Also man muss jetzt nicht beim Urschleim anfangen. Genau, so 101.
Das hätte ich dann halt gemacht, also zumindest angeboten, einmal über alles
rüberlatschen, mal so Räume zeigen.
Aber dann gibt es natürlich dann schon so die Orte, wo man normalerweise nicht hinkommt.
Und Dinge erklären, Zusammenhänge, Geschichte ein bisschen erklären etc.
Also wenn ihr Erfahrung schon habt mit dem Kongress, meldet ihr euch doch auch
als Chaos-Pate, Patin an und ja, dann könnt ihr da,
interessante Leute zugeteilt bekommen und das war auf jeden Fall sehr cool.
Ansonsten eine Sache kann ich vielleicht noch nachreichen. Wir haben auch ein
bisschen Ultraschall gemacht auf dem Kongress.
Zum einen habe ich mich mal mit Mio so anderthalb Stunden hingesetzt und sie
hat mir mal ihre neue GUI-Engine gezeigt und das ist echt so irre,
was sie da einfach Monat um Monat runterhackt.
So, wo ihr denkt, okay.
Das hat mal Hand und Fuß. Also da bin ich jetzt sehr optimistisch,
dass wir da zur sechster Version wirklich coole Sachen mitgewuppt bekommen.
Dann, das werfe ich mal in die Shownotes rein, haben wir einen kleinen Workshop
gemacht auf unserer Sendezentrumsbühne und den hatten wir so exakt gar nicht vorbereitet.
Normalerweise mag ich das nicht.
Die haben wir die Besten.
Wenn ich auf irgendwelche Bühnen setzen, ohne irgendwie Vorbereitung,
ist normalerweise nicht so mein Ding.
Aber das hat verstörend gut funktioniert. Da war es nicht besonders überlaufen,
aber es saßen die richtigen Leute da im Publikum.
Und wir hatten eine anderthalb Stunden total gute Debatte, was so verschiedene
strategische Optionen werden, was irgendwie Lücken sind, die geschlossen gehören.
Also allen, denen irgendwie das Projekt am Herzen liegt und die so ein bisschen
wissen wollen, was so unsere aktuellen Überlegungen jetzt gerade für die 6er-Version
sind, hört da mal rein, ich glaube, das ist ganz,
Ganz cool geworden, dieser Deviser-Workshop. Ich war hinterher,
dachte so, hui, das hat ja mal gut funktioniert.
Und was ihr jetzt verpasst habt, aber zumindest als Bild wollen wir das auch
in den Schaunotes drin haben, ist, dass Udo, auch ein Urgestein bei mir aus dem Ultraschall-Team,
ja eine der, ich würde mal sagen, Sensationen des Kongresses mit dabei hatte,
nämlich ein echtes Ultraschallgerät.
Naja, ein Gehäuse.
Ein Ultraschall-PC-Gehäuse.
Naja, aber hier Trackpad und sowas lief ja dann schon alles.
Ein Ultraschallgeräte-Gehauze.
Und also wirklich halt so ein medizinisches Ultraschall, wie man es halt so kennt.
Und dort lief dann in der Tat Ultraschall drauf, inklusive auch mit Mikro und
in echt und man konnte Spuren aufnehmen.
Ich glaube, das kennen nur Leute, die gerade irgendwie schon in dem Prozess
Kinder zu bekommen sind.
Also ja, Udo hat mich dann aufgeklärt, das ist kein Gerät, was normalerweise
jetzt irgendwie beim Gynäkologen steht, sondern für Ultraschall von Herzinfarkten und sowas irgendwie.
Also schon das rechts unten Modell auch. Das bessere Modell.
Genau, also richtig rechts unten war das.
Und das hat er halt irgendwie über eBay-Kleinanzeigen geschossen.
Und fruckelt da also wirklich seit Monaten dran rum und schreibt in unserem
Ultraschall-Chat immer irgendwelche obskuren Sachen dazu, irgendwelche Bilder.
Und du denkst immer nur so, okay, ja, damit kann man seine Zeit jetzt auch so
verbringen. Und dann hat er das halt einfach stehen gehabt und sofort macht alles Sinn.
Das ist so ein Klassiker von so manchen Dingen muss man wirklich in echt und 3D.
Irgendwie vor sich haben, damit sich die ganze Grandezza irgendwie erschließt.
Ja, das war sehr, sehr großartig. Vor allen Dingen die Menge an Leuten,
die da stehen geblieben sind und Dinge gesagt haben und mitunter auch wirklich
fortgeschrittene Mediziner,
die dann nochmal genau gesagt haben, ja, das Gerät hätte er auch gerne gehabt,
aber sie haben nur die kleinere Variante und solche Sachen. Also das war...
Ja, im Nachhinein habe ich mich da ein bisschen geärgert, weil also es gab wirklich
viel Aufmerksamkeit da.
Man hätte da eigentlich dann wirklich nochmal einen Roll-Up-Banner daneben haben
müssen. So, ach übrigens, das ist das ernsthafte Projekt irgendwie da zu dieser Spaß-Bastel-Aktion.
Da hätte man also sicherlich jetzt noch ein bisschen Publicity auch mit reinfahren
können. Aber naja, nächstes Jahr ist ja der nächste Kongress.
Ich bin mir einigermaßen sicher, dass Udo sich nicht nehmen wird,
da seine 2.0-Version hinzurollen.
Er hatte ja dann zum Schluss auch noch ein Ultraschallgerät angeschlossen und
zwar so ein Ultraschallabstandsensor.
So ein Distanzmesser.
So ein Distanzmesser, den hatte er hinten rangeklemmt und dann konnte man das
Ding rumschieben und sehen, wie weit man noch von einem Hindernis weg ist.
Wohlbemerkt im Ultraschall-Dashboard, das heißt also er hat dann auch eine kleine
Erweiterung für unseren Dashboard-Bereich.
Ja, Ultraschallabstandssensor to MIDI ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Softwaremodul,
was niemand anderes hat.
Ja, das war sehr fein. Für sowas ist der Kongress dann ja doch der exakt richtige Ort.
Einen Vortrag habe ich auch gehalten oder einen Workshop vielmehr,
auch auf der Sendezentrumsbühne.
Das war ja sozusagen unser Podcast-spezifischer Ort.
Also wir teilen uns traditionell diese Räume immer mit dem Deutschlandfunk,
die da tagsüber ihre Sendungen produzieren.
Das haben sie diesmal in den ersten beiden Tagen gemacht und den Rest nutzen
wir dann eben für Live-Podcasting oder eben auch mal für einen Workshop und ich habe meinen,
Workshop, den ich schon auf der Subscribe gemacht habe, nochmal quasi neu ausgerollt
und nochmal neu erzählt. Das ist auch aufgezeichnet worden.
Der ultimative Rodecaster Pro 2 Workshop.
Der, ich habe ihn mir sogar nochmal angeschaut und ich kann ihn empfehlen.
Also, ich habe wenig vergessen.
Er hat dein eigenes Nachhören überstanden.
Ja, also ich bin schon kritisch. Also ich schaue mir meine eigenen Talks dann
an und will irgendwie wissen, ob das jetzt auch okay war. Und es war okay.
Ja, genau. Also wenn ihr schon mal immer mit dem Rodecaster 2 geliebäugelt habt
oder wenn ihr der Meinung seid, ihr könnt da nicht alles rausholen,
dann ist da vielleicht für euch noch ein bisschen was dabei.
In dem Zusammenhang kann ich auch verkünden, dass ich jetzt meinen Dritten gekauft habe.
Der Trend geht zum Drittmixer.
Ja, weil also ich habe hier einen im Studio stehen, ich habe einen,
zweiten großen Rodecaster 2, den habe ich immer in meinem To-Go Koffer sozusagen,
also ich will halt hier ein Studio nicht abbauen, wenn ich irgendwie unterwegs
bin und habe quasi immer so ein Vierer-Recording-Setup so Feuerwehr-mäßig muss
dann hier nur noch irgendwie die Stange runterrutschen und dann direkt zum Einsatzort
und weiß, ich habe alles dabei.
Da sind alle Adapter dabei, alle Fernbedienungen dabei, Strom,
Verlängerungskabel, Speicher, genug Headsets und so weiter.
Also da kann mir dann auch irgendwas kaputt gehen. Ich bin irgendwie vorbereitet,
weil die Gelegenheit kommt ja unter Umständen nicht nochmal.
Aber da ich jetzt auf eine längere Reise gehe und ich auch Podcast-Equipment dabei haben will,
dachte ich mir, hole ich mir nochmal die kleine Variante davon, den Duo,
den kleinen süßen, der im Prinzip genauso ist wie der große,
der aber kürzere Mixerwege hat und nur sechs statt der acht Abspielbuttons an
der Seite hat, was aber immer noch vollkommen ausreichend ist.
Die größte Limitierung ist, dass er nur zwei statt vier Kombo-Mikrofon-Line-Eingänge hat.
Dafür hat er aber vorne noch so
ein Headset-Klinke, wo man so ein Plug-in-Power-Headset reinmachen kann.
Also zum Beispiel diese iPhone-Kabeldinger oder irgendwie sowas.
Das gute Boom Pro, hier schon mal besprochen. Das klingt richtig gut.
Genau, also könnte man theoretisch sogar ein Dreikanaler draus machen,
wenn man die unter Umständen dann abweichende Soundqualität hat.
Entweder nicht feststellt oder es egal ist. Genau.
Und da werde ich dann später mal von meinen Erfahrungen berichten.
Aber das war jetzt, sagen wir mal, aus Kompaktheitsgründen angemessen.
Genau. Aber der Rodocaster ist nach wie vor ein interessantes Gerät,
auch wenn im letzten Software-Update für mich nichts dabei war.
Was bleibt zum Kongress noch zu sagen? Also ich fand die Veranstaltung insgesamt extrem smooth.
Also es gab relativ wenig Reibung, so wie ich das mitbekommen habe beim Aufbau.
Es ging alles gut, als ich da ankam und mein Kram reintragen wollte,
wurde ich von einer Herrscher von Freiwilligen nahezu überrannt,
die mir helfen wollten, das hochzutragen und es auch getan haben.
Ich mir dachte so, okay, also zwei Tage vorher und es gibt nichts zu tun,
das kann nur ein gutes Zeichen sein.
Und das war auch so das Feedback, was ich gehört hatte, dass eigentlich alles relativ easy ging.
Es ist halt der zweite Mal jetzt in diesem neuen CCH, man kennt sich aus.
Und es gab ja auch ein paar Änderungen.
Der Musikclub ist umgezogen.
Also ich war da ja, also die offizielle Lounge war jetzt ja unten im Keller
vom Reddison und das war die ganze.
Lounge ist ja eigentlich.
Oben.
Aber ich weiß.
Aber der Club, der ist da auch immer. Das ist jetzt einfach die normale Club-Location,
die im Reddison ohnehin da unten im Keller drin ist.
Also für die Leute, die nicht wissen, wovon wir reden. Also es gibt,
das TCH und in demselben Gebäudekomplex, aber schon räumlich getrennt,
ist dann noch dieses Reddison Hotel, was ja direkt da ranklebt.
So ein bisschen teuer, aber wer sich das leistet, der hat auf jeden Fall kurze
Wege und das ist ein sehr hohes Gebäude und im Keller gibt es tatsächlich auch
noch einen Club, so einen Musikclub, der von irgendeinem anderen Clubbetreiber,
normalerweise gefahren wird und das hatte sich halt der CCC jetzt in diesem
Jahr als Location auch mitgemietet.
Das heißt, der eigentliche Club hatte dann zu, Ich weiß nicht,
ob er sonst da auch zu hat, wahrscheinlich nicht. Also man ist sich dafür irgendwie einig geworden.
Das Musikprogramm, was letztes Jahr noch in einem der CCH-Säle lief, war dann halt dort.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass es halt keinerlei Theming halt gab.
Also es war halt einfach so der völlig normale Club, so wie er da halt das ganze Jahr steht.
Nee, das stimmt nicht ganz. Der sah schon anders aus. Ich habe ihn auch vorher
gesehen. Der sah vorher wirklich anders.
Nicht schön aus und war besser dann.
Es war halt trotzdem noch so, sagen wir mal, im klassischen Musik, er hatte kein,
38C3 Flavor im Design.
Wir Älteren hier unter uns werden sich hintern, wir kommen noch aus der Generation,
wo wir noch auf Wasserwerfern getanzt haben.
Die legendäre Endlich mal normale Leute Party da mit dem Wasserwerfer.
Also sowas fehlt natürlich irgendwie komplett. Ja, also dass du wirklich irgendwie
so eine Art von sichtbarer Gestaltung hast, dass das jetzt noch zum Kongress überhaupt gehört.
Das ist richtig. Ich glaube, das haben auch alle geteilt, die da dran engagiert
waren, wie das immer so ist.
Also das war, ich weiß, wie das gelaufen ist und es war sehr kurzfristig.
Also die Einigung, die dort erzielt wurde, das war dann wirklich so oft in den
letzten zwei, drei Wochen und dann war da nicht mehr viel Zeit, viel zu wuppen.
Also die eigentliche Leistung war, das überhaupt an den Start zu bekommen und
dadurch wurde halt dieser Saal vier frei und das hat dem eigentlichen Kongress
dann wiederum eine Menge zusätzlichen guten Huckspace gegeben und das sah auch sehr nett aus.
Ja, Weihnachten hat auch bitter, bitter nötig, ja.
Und dann gab es ja auch noch die Kloparty und das Hutzelhäuschen.
Ja, aber erste Regel, wir reden nicht über den Fight Club.
Aber die Natur bahnt sich ihren Weg. Und wie war die Formulierung,
die mir freigegeben wurde, zu sagen,
der offizielle Lautsprecher und Lichtanlagentest war ein voller Erfolg.
Wie lange haben wir gesucht, Roddy? Du warst doch da auch mit dabei.
Also bestimmt irgendwie eine Dreiviertelstunde oder so.
Nee, ich bin da relativ straight runtergelaufen, weil die Beschreibung,
die ich hatte, die war relativ gut.
Ich war nur nicht drin, weil ich bin da um die Ecke und dann war innerhalb von...
Ein bis zwei Metern von kalte Tiefgarage zu finnische Sauna.
Und dann dachte ich, das musst du dir jetzt nicht antun.
Ja, also Nelo und ich waren da irgendwie eine Dreiviertelstunde am Suchen und
wurden immer hin und her geschickt und keiner wusste irgendwas.
Aber es hatte vor allen Dingen ja so Inception-Qualitäten.
Also wenn du auf der Ebene der ersten illegalen Party warst,
dann musstest du von dort dann noch auf die nächste Ebene irgendwie dich vorarbeiten.
Das war also schon ganz cool. Naja.
Nichtsdestotrotz gab es also auch unten in dem Club ein delikates Musikprogramm.
Das Line-Up, das konnte sich sehen lassen.
Es gab auch irgendwie einen Jodel-Workshop von Esels Albtraum.
Also es war mir wieder mal viel zu holen auf dem Kongress, weil man im richtigen
Moment am richtigen Ort ist.
Und ich finde es immer wieder schön festzustellen, dass diese Veranstaltung
auch immer noch Optimierungspotenzial hat. Also es ist irre.
Es bleibt einfach kein Quadratmeter ungenutzt.
Und wenn sich in irgendeiner Form irgendwas anbietet, was man irgendwie noch
mit reinkriegen kann, findet es auch statt.
Und ja, insgesamt war das einfach eine runde Veranstaltung und man kann nur
sagen, alle, die da organisiert haben, das war super. Ja.
Vielleicht noch ein kurzer Nachtrag, weil ich da auch mehrfach schon darauf angesprochen wurde.
Ich war auch nicht der Einzige, der darauf hingewiesen hat, aber ich hatte so
ein bisschen Kritik geäußert an der Heraldik auf dem Kongress.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also
Herald's, das sind ja sozusagen die Arbeitsgruppe, die sich um diese ganze.
Publikums- die Adressierung zwischen den Talks auf den Bühnen kümmert.
Also die Haralds, das ist so ein Team, die sind dann eben zugeteilt für die
einzelnen Räume und die einzelnen Talks und machen dann eben alles,
was quasi nachdem der letzte Talk beendet ist, bis der nächste Talk anfängt,
kümmern die sich sozusagen um die Begründung.
Spielung der Teilnehmer. Das Defragmentieren.
Zum Beispiel, also aller möglichen Ankündigungen, die in dem Moment gemacht
werden müssen, eine Ankündigung des nächsten Talks,
aber eben auch die Betreuung der QA-Session danach, also welches Mikrofon spricht,
bla bla bla, vielleicht Leute auch ein bisschen...
Die halten auch noch so und so viele Minutenschilder hoch.
All sowas. Also das ganze Stage-Management, ich weiß nicht,
ob da noch weitere Personen also ob das dann mehrere sind pro Talk weiß ich
jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht ich hatte mich dann auf Mastodon und da war ich
jetzt auch nicht die einzige Person,
das kamen von mindestens zwei anderen separat unabgesprochenerweise auch, dass halt,
ich es ein bisschen unpassend finde, dass die,
dass die Ankündigungen immer noch mit in den Aufzeichnungen landen,
weil ich finde ich unpassend.
Die sind nämlich dann im Stil und Dimensionen sehr unterschiedlich und mal mehr
und mal weniger gelungen und mir ist das besonders unangenehm aufgefallen,
weil alle so die Videolinks geteilt haben und dann waren so die ganzen,
Leute so, ja hier ist mein Talk vom Kongress und der Thumbnail war dann immer so.
Die Person, die das im Saal angekündigt hat und da habe ich mir so,
äh das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig das Ding.
Manche haben mich dann so ein bisschen missverstanden, dass ich da jetzt sozusagen
groß Kritik geäußert habe.
Also klar, manche Sachen sind schiefgegangen, sind was weiß ich,
Sachen falsch angekündigt worden, Namen falsch ausgesprochen worden oder gerade
bei internationalen Ansagen,
dass dann auch das Englisch nicht so sitzt, das finde ich, sowas muss dann halt
auch irgendwie schon passen und man muss es dann auch nicht unbedingt auch nochmal
aufzeichnen und veröffentlichen.
Aber grundsätzlich, ich zum Beispiel verzichte gerne auf sowas,
weil ich mir eigentlich diese ganze Eröffnung eines Talks gar nicht aus der
Hand nehmen lassen möchte.
Und dann kommen dann irgendwelche, vielleicht auch abgesprochenen Ankündigungen,
aber im Wesentlichen sind das Dinge, die kann man irgendwie auch von sich selber sagen.
Maybe it's just me, aber ich finde selten, dass da irgendein Mehrwert geboren wird dadurch.
Ich finde es vollkommen okay, dass man im Saal in irgendeiner Form eine unmittelbare
Überleitung macht zu jetzt geht es auch los.
Das ist okay, dass man so einen Übergabemoment hat,
aber in der Aufzeichnung finde ich, ist das halt genau der Zeitpunkt,
wo dann der Cut gemacht werden sollte und dann hast du quasi als Konserve dann
eben wirklich nur den Talk und die Präsentatoren haben dann auch das Limelight für sich.
Wenn sie schon den Aufwand dort treiben.
Ihr nickt?
Ja. Okay, sehe ich auch so.
Gut. Sehr schön. Ja, sonst noch irgendwelche Anmerkungen zum Kongress?
Mir fällt jetzt erstmal nichts ein, vielleicht fallen es dann auch später ein.
Es gab noch das Whisky Tasting bei Milliways.
Das ist allerdings wirklich nur für Leute, die ihr Glimit kennen.
Hat aber sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich habe da irgendwie Leute kennengelernt.
Grüße an dieser Stelle. Wir sind dann zu dritt irgendwie noch in die Schanze
gefahren und haben dort bei einem edeltürkischen Restaurant irgendwie Zeug gegessen.
Das war einfach sehr spaßig.
Right.
Gut. Dann können wir ja mal,
auf andere Sachen eingehen. Vielleicht nochmal kurz ein bisschen Feedback zur letzten Sendung.
Nicht viel, aber ich hatte ja erzählt oder ich hatte beklagt,
dass Geldautomaten in meiner Welt sich zumindest bei den Sparkassen nicht mit
einer NFC-Autorisierung zufriedengeben,
sondern dass man hier, like an animal, immer noch seine Karte in so einen Slot reinstecken muss.
Stellt sich raus, das ist halt mal wieder so ein Infrastrukturloch im Norden.
Im Süden gibt es das wohl. Also mir wurde von München und anderen eher südlicheren
Standorten berichtet, wo das wohl bei einigen Sparkassen so sei,
dass man tatsächlich sich darüber autorisieren kann.
Meine These ist, dass das dann quasi so eine Rückwärtsautorisierung ist,
dass man dadurch eigentlich nur nachweist, gucke mal, ich habe hier eine Kreditkarte
oder eine Girocard, da wird es ja auch Sinn machen,
die ausgegeben ist von dieser Sparkasse und die damit verbunden ist mit einem
Konto und damit fungiert das Ding quasi wie eine Kundenkarte,
die man ja sonst da reinschiebt.
Beziehungsweise eine EC-Karte ist es dann direkt, also vielleicht mit Girokarte geht es auch so.
Ja, so heißt es ja nicht mehr.
Sondern Girokarte heißt es.
Girokarte heißt es, ja. Aber die normale Bankkarte.
Naja, Bank, also EC-Karte, wie der Volksmund so schön sagt, ist eine Girokarte
und das ist das, womit du bezahlst und das ist halt ein deutsches Bezahlungssystem
der deutschen Banken und Sparkassen.
Ja. Das aber auch im Ausland irgendwie, es ist ein bisschen mehr.
Nur in so einem Ausland wie so ein Mallorca-Ausland.
Nö, auch Italien oder so. Also dieses V-Pay oder wie das heißt.
Ja, das ist ja was anderes.
Ja, aber es ist auf der gleichen Karte drauf.
Ja, das ist was anderes. Da ist halt noch was anderes drauf,
damit das funktioniert.
Aber die Girocard als solche funktioniert in der Regel nur in Deutschland.
Das mag sein.
Ausgenommen Orte in Europa, wo so viele Deutsche, die nicht wissen,
was eine Kreditkarte ist, aber eine Girocard haben, von der sie nicht wissen, wie sie heißt.
Nämlich Girocard. Und die sie EC-Karte nennen.
Rumlaufen und Geld ausgeben wollen und dann hat man da irgendwie Automaten hingestellt,
die irgendwie einen Standard nach Deutschland haben und die noch in der Lage
sind, sich sozusagen wie so ein normaler deutscher Geldautomat zu verhalten.
Aber eigentlich ist das so quasi non-international.
Und die internationale Version ist natürlich wie immer, dass man eins der beiden,
international akzeptierten Bezahlsysteme gibt.
Da haben wir dieses schöne Duopol zwischen Visa und Mastercard.
Das heißt dann also Maestro.
Oder eben dieses V-Pay. Und das ist dann sozusagen so diese Debitkarten Geschichte
und dann hast du eben noch die richtigen Kreditkarten, also Mastercard und Visa,
die du eben auch auf so einer Karte haben kannst.
Manche haben jetzt in Feedback auch gesagt, ja, man kann ja auch damit abheben.
Ja, klar, das kann man auch, aber da hat man halt andere Gebühren.
Und ich sprach ja von gebührenfreie Bargeldauszahlung.
Ich habe im Apple Pay tatsächlich zwei Karten.
Ich habe ganz viele Karten.
Und die Visa-Karte, aber vom gleichen ausgebenden Institut.
Was war die erste Karte?
Na diese Giro, Gira, wie heißt sie?
Girocard.
Girocard, genau.
Ja, genau, bei Sparkarten kannst du das machen.
Genau, und eine Visa-Card.
Aber auch die Girocard wirst du auch mit NFC, Apple Pay nur in Deutschland benutzen können.
Das mag sein.
Ja, das mag sein, das ist auch so. Und Visa-Karte kann man auch haben und dann
kann man aber auch eine Debit-Karte haben etc. Bei manchen ist es halt auch
ein eigenes Kreditkartenkonto, bei manchen Banken ist es direkt mit dem Konto verbunden.
Also entweder hast du deine Abbuchung unmittelbar oder du hast die Abbuchung
nach einem Jahr und so, naja egal, nach dem Ende des Monats.
Jira-Karte, ja okay, nein.
Ja genau, also vielen Dank für die Kommentare und jetzt haben wir das auch nochmal klargestellt.
So, und du hast CES geguckt, Roddy?
Was heißt, ich habe es geguckt? Nein, ich habe kein CES geguckt,
aber mir sind zwei, drei Sachen, zwei Sachen sind an mir vorüber geflogen.
Das erste ist, Roborock hat einen neuen Staubsauger-Roboter vorgestellt mit
einem jetzt wird es langsam wirklich scary Feature und zwar der hat einen Greifarm.
Greift er da mit die Haustiere und räumt sie aus dem Weg.
Wenn die Kinder mal wieder die Socken liegen lassen, dann kann der tatsächlich
der Greifarm die Socken rausnehmen und dann in eine vorher definierte Kiste reinlegen.
Das heißt, der fährt dann nochmal quer durch die Wohnung zu dieser Kiste hin und dann wieder zurück?
Und genau, Roborox, Saros, keine Ahnung, welcher von denen das ist.
Auf jeden Fall, der hat halt einen Greifarm.
Hier, Saros Z70. Erobere die Zukunft mit Intelligenz.
Ja, also das Wettrüsten der Staubsaugerhersteller nimmt kein Ende.
Ich weiß nicht, wann in Amerika die ersten mit Schusswaffen umgehen.
Aber naja, auf jeden Fall fand ich das mal bemerkenswert.
Sofort kriegt der Welt ein Vibes, wenn die dreibeinigen Herrscher die armen
Menschen aufsammeln und hinten gehen.
Aber was kann denn jetzt hier der Saros an sich? Also hier scheinen ja nicht alle Modelle ein.
Naja, das Übliche, also ich meine Saugenwischen hast du nicht gesehen und der
hat halt diesen Arm noch dran.
Soweit ich weiß, wurde er nur vorgestellt. Den kann man glaube ich noch nicht kaufen.
Aber ich fand es halt einfach drollig und wollte das mal erwähnt haben.
Von Spiel und Zeug gibt es auch ein Video dazu.
Keine verhedderten Haare, keine Probleme. Dieses System ist der Garant für 0%,
Haarverhedderungsrate.
Der Duo die White-Aubbürste und Anti-Tangle-Seitenbürste.
Die Verhedderungsrate, das ist schon irgendwie...
Ja, Werbetexte müsste man haben. Genau, das ist das eine. Und das zweite ist...
Es wurden neue Grafikkarten angekündigt, sowohl Nvidia als auch AMD haben ihre
neue Generation vorgestellt.
Nvidia hat da einige Behauptungen aufgestellt, die komplett jenseits der Realität sind.
Weißt du, welche denn? Welche denn?
Die 50 sonst was Serie, also 5070, 5080 und 5090.
Ja.
Ja,
da ist es so, dass die 5070 soll also so schnell sein wie das Topmodell von der Generation davor.
Das ist aber Quatsch, die ist wahrscheinlich nur so um die 20 Prozent schneller.
Aber lustigerweise hat AMD auch eine Keynote auf der CES gehabt und die hatten wohl Gerüchte gehört,
was Nvidia da so vorstellt und haben im Prinzip dann in ihrer Keynote zum Thema
Grafikkarten nur gesagt,
ja, es wird eine neue geben, die heißt so und so und die hat 16 Gigabyte und fertig.
Die haben also weder gesagt, wie schnell ist das Ding, noch wie viel wird es kosten,
weil sie wohl so ziemlich erstmal abwarten wollen,
was so die ersten Benchmarks bei Nvidia so behaupten und ob das,
was Nvidia da so erzählt hat, tatsächlich irgendwie dann auch Realität wird.
Grundsätzlich gilt, das klingt alles irgendwie wundersam,
aber den Vorbestellen und Kaufen-Button würde ich jetzt noch nicht klicken,
bevor nicht irgendwie unabhängige Reviewer das Zeug gründlich durchgetestet
haben, sonst wird es nämlich ein bisschen teuer.
Also die, das Flaggschiff von Nvidia soll jetzt 2000 Euro kosten für eine 32
GB Karte, die eins drunter dann immerhin nur noch 1000.
Die ist dann aber wahrscheinlich auch nur halb so schnell.
Ja, mal gucken. Also ich denke, die haben jetzt viel Staub aufgewirbelt,
das sollte sich erst mal legen.
Genau, mehr wollte ich dazu auch gar nicht sagen.
Naja, neben dieser Grafikkarte haben sie ja irgendwie noch so ein Physik-KI-Modell,
glaube ich, angekündigt und diesen komischen KI-Desktop-PC, der an viel Power ist.
Ja, da ist überall KI, KI, KI.
Naja, klar, ich meine, das ist ja ein großes Ding. Also sie wollen ja so ein
3000-Dollar-Arm-PC mit ihrem
Grafikkarten-Wumms, der halt speziell für Trading und KI gedacht ist.
Dass Nvidia in das ganze ARM-Game einsteigen will, das war schon länger klar.
Vor allen Dingen, weil die Switch 2 auch einen ARM-Prozessor haben wird und
eine Nvidia-Grafik-Lösung.
Die Nintendo Switch 2.
Die Nintendo Switch, was habe ich gesagt?
Switch. Ich wollte nur klarstellen, dass du von Nintendo redest.
Nintendo Switch 2, genau.
Nicht, dass du auch zu diesen Leuten gehörst, die Ethernet-Switch meinen und
die Switch sagen. Kennst du das?
Nein.
Was würdest du zu einem Internet-Switch sagen? Der Switch. Genau.
Wir sind im selben Boot, aber ich habe auch schon mal die Nintendo Switch Konsole.
So richtig Konsole ist es nicht, egal, soll eben auch,
Nvidia Grafikpower haben und aber einen ARM Prozessor und es sieht ganz so danach
aus, als würde Nvidia beides in einer Package dann abliefern.
Mal gucken, wie das was da so genau passiert.
Was sagen die neuesten Gerüchte? Im März wäre es soweit, im April?
Im April wohl am ehesten, also hinter verschlossenen Türen wurde wohl die Switch 2 präsentiert.
Wer ist schuld?
Was?
Ich, weil ich habe mir jetzt gerade eine noch gekauft.
Du hast das beschleunigt.
Naja, ich dachte ja auch immer so, vielleicht wenn mal eine neue kommt und so,
dann dachte ich mir so, jetzt will ich aber mal eine haben. Ja, jetzt habe ich eine.
Naja, solange sie nichts offiziell angekündigt haben, sind das nur Gerüchte.
Ja, Gerüchte gibt es schon lange.
Gibt es schon lange und die Leistungsdaten, die gerüchtet werden,
die haben sich nicht erhöht und sehen jetzt inzwischen auch ein bisschen alt aus.
Aber gut, Nintendo war nie dafür bekannt, dass sie die Latest und Greatest Hardware ausliefern.
Ganz im Gegenteil, die Geräte waren immer ein bisschen schwächlich,
dafür waren die Spiele ein bisschen genialer.
Die Geräte ein bisschen billiger.
Die Geräte billiger?
Für Nintendo vor allen Dingen.
Also klar im Verkauf dann auch, aber die haben da glaube ich ganz ordentlich
Marge auf ihre Hardware, während andere Konsolen gerne mal unter Herstellungspreis
verkauft werden am Anfang.
Also spannend wird, was sie dann so als Konsolen-Startspiel mit rausgeben.
Also jede neue Nintendo-Konsole hat dann so ein Flaggschiff-Spiel. Mario Kart 9!
Wäre eine Option, also Damals war es ja Breath of the Wild.
Die Frage ist, wenn sie Switch 2 heißt, ist es dann eigentlich nicht,
also dann können sie es sich ja nicht erlauben, dass Software rauskommt,
die nur für die Switch 2 ist.
Also noch ist ja auch nicht klar, ob sie Switch 2 heißen wird.
Ach so, ich dachte.
Das wäre geil. Also klar sagen alle Switch 2, weil es ist ein ähnliches Handheld.
Rechts- und links-Controller in der Mitte-Bildschirm.
Weiß man ja auch nicht, ob das so ist.
Ja, doch, da ist sich die Gerüchteküche wohl relativ einig.
Gut, das werden wir dann sehen. Aber um noch mal ganz kurz den Nvidia-Spin zu Ende zu bringen.
Es ist natürlich interessant. Ich meine, Nvidia hat einfach eine Menge Kohle.
Nvidia hat bewiesen, dass sie ihr Silizium ordentlich auf den Tisch bringen können.
Also die sind in der Lage, ordentlich zu fäppen. Und die haben irgendwie auch
Ahnung. Und die wissen gerade auch im Bereich Grafikkarten, KI,
also in so einem Wachstumsmarkt genau, was angesagt ist, wenn sie jetzt eben
sich auch noch eine ARM-Lizenz holen, was sie wahrscheinlich schon getan haben.
Schon lange her.
Ja, die Frage ist, ob sie sich eine richtige ARM-Lizenz holen.
Also es gibt ja da quasi zwei Abstufungen.
Es gibt die, wir nehmen ein Design von ARM und bauen das oder es gibt den,
wir holen uns eine Architektur-Lizenz und bauen alles selber,
so wie Apple das macht und Qualcomm.
Und das würde ich natürlich auch Nvidia zutrauen und wenn sie dann jetzt mit
ihrer aktuellen Marktpower in der Lage sind,
quasi für ARM-PCs da so überzeugende Grafikperformance abzuliefern und quasi
noch die Desktop-CPU dazu,
was sie ja jetzt hier im Prinzip mit diesem 3000-Dollar-PC schon mal so angedeutet
haben, aber das ist halt jetzt fokussiert auf die eigentlichen KI-Funktionen.
Wenn sie das quasi dann auch noch für den theoretisch wachsenden Windows-Arm-Markt
auch noch machen, dann könnte es vielleicht interessant sein oder halt natürlich auch den Linux-Markt.
Also als Microsoft wäre ich jetzt nervös, weil Microsoft hat das mit dem ARM
Windows, haben sie es so oft verkackt.
Ja gut, aber wir haben ja keine andere Wahl. Also ich meine,
mit Intel geht es jetzt nicht weiter.
Nee, Intel braucht nicht mehr nervös zu werden.
Die zittern schon.
Intel zuckt kaum noch.
Aber AMD ist ja auch noch da.
AMD ist auch noch da, ja.
Denen geht es ja relativ gut, aber letztlich ist es halt die Frage,
hat denn überhaupt der Intel x86 die Architektur überhaupt noch eine Zukunft?
Ich meine, das ist wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Mal totgesagt worden,
aber es sah schon mal besser aus.
Ganz ehrlich, am Ende zählt, was kann die CPU und nicht welchen Zeichensatz fährt sie.
Also gerade der 64-Bit-Zeichensatz, den übrigens Arm damals in den Markt...
Du meinst wahrscheinlich den Instruction-Set, nicht den Character-Set.
Den Instruction-Set, ja, den damals AMD in den Markt gepusht hat,
ist ja schon so weit modernisiert, dass die Fallhöhe zu Arm gar nicht so riesig ist.
Und deswegen, also AMD zeigt ja, dass man mit diesem Instruction Set auch gute
Prozessoren bauen kann.
Intel hat halt gezeigt, dass wenn man der Meinung ist, man hat das erfunden
und macht das jetzt 40 Jahre, was kann schon schief gehen, dass halt Dinge schief gehen.
Ja, aber der Instructions-Set ist ja nicht entscheidend, sondern entscheidend
ist ja Performance per Watt.
Wenn du halt im mobilen Bereich irgendwie mithalten willst, dann musst du halt… Ja.
Aber schau dir die AMD-Mobilprozessoren an, die sind, was Performance per Watt
angeht, sind sie vielleicht nicht ganz so gut wie das, was Apple baut,
aber sie können wirklich auch in der Klasse mitspielen.
Aber nicht in Apples Klasse. Also mit dem M4 können die nicht mithalten,
aber nicht mal im Ansatz.
Wie gesagt, die mobilen Kerne schon.
Ja, aber die können performance-mäßig nicht mithalten.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Also da habe ich noch nichts gesehen, was auch nur ansatzweise,
also Performance und Stromverbrauch zusammen gibt es nichts derzeit,
was Apple auch nur ansatzweise das Wasser reichen kann.
Also ich meine, da gab es ja jetzt von Microsoft große Ankündigungen,
jetzt hier machen wir jetzt auch ARM.
CPUs, Qualcomm hat dann irgendwie Sachen rausgebracht, Snapdragon, bla bla bla für ARM.
Und die performten halt so auf dem M1-Level.
Ja, die Qualcomm-Katastrophe, über die brauchen wir nicht reden.
Ja gut, aber das ist das, was auf dem Markt ist und natürlich kann es vielleicht
sein, dass Nvidia unter Umständen vielleicht in der Lage ist,
einen Prozessor rauszubringen und vielleicht kann auch AMD irgendwie so ein
bisschen Schritt halten, aber halt derzeit sind sie alle noch zwei Jahre hinterher, mindestens.
Also wenn Nvidia sich dieser Aufgabe ordentlich annimmt, dann würde ich als
Qualcomm, würde mir der Arsch wahrscheinlich auf Grundeis gehen.
Jetzt Apple Angst haben muss, weiß man nicht. Auf der anderen Seite,
Nvidia verdient jetzt Geld, vor allen Dingen mit AI.
Also diese ganze KI-Beschleunigung, das ist das, wo sie groß abräumen,
alles andere ist für sie eher Kosten.
Weil sie damit wahrscheinlich nicht genug Geld machen. Und wenn sie jetzt da
sagen, sie haben da so ein PC, da ist halt irgendein arm Ding drin, wahrscheinlich,
jetzt nicht das schlechteste, aber der Fokus liegt, glaube ob ich auf dem eigentlichen KI-Lernen lerne.
Da liegt ja derzeit der Fokus drauf. Aber ein Markt, den sie sich jetzt noch zusätzlich,
weil diesen Markt haben sie eh schon in der Tasche, aber den Markt,
der jetzt quasi noch up for grabs ist, ist halt Laptop-Prozessoren der nächsten
Generation für Windows.
Weil Windows wird ja noch eine Weile benutzt werden.
Ja, aber so richtig for grabs ist der Markt nicht. Also sie müssen da erst an AMD vorbei.
Und was PC-Prozessoren anbelangt, ist AMD momentan nicht das Wasser zu reichen.
Auch von den Kosten her, weil die relativ günstig produzieren können.
Ja, aber halt nicht, was Leistung pro Watt betrifft. Und wenn Nvidia auch noch
die Grafikkarten-Performance dazu ballert, die es so in der Kombination mit
anderen Prozessoren nicht gibt, dann könnte was draus werden. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich Wumpe, aber das ist so das,
was ich jetzt hier gerade sehe. Müssen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen.
Wir spekulieren ja nur. So.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass Nvidia da Interesse dran hat. Aber gut, mag sein.
So, haben wir noch Kleinkram?
Ja, die Doom Gallery Experience.
Ja, was ist das?
Moment, ich muss kurz den Link kopieren und hier.
Und zwar hat da ein, ich glaube, Es ist ein Künstler,
hat etwas gebaut und zwar hat er die Doom Engine benutzt und den ersten Level von Doom,
um damit eine virtuelle Galerie zu bauen.
Man kann also dann da durch diese Ausstellung gehen mit einem Glas Wein in der
Hand und immer wenn man den Feuerbutton drückt,
dann trinkt er einen Schluck von dem Wein, aber es liegt eben auch Geld rum
und es stehen noch Weinflaschen rum und man kann sich dann die ganzen Objekte
angucken und zum Schluss bekommt man dann ausgerechnet,
wie viel Geld man noch hat, wie viel Wein man noch hat.
Es gibt auch ein Secret in dem Level, dann findet man Bier.
Das gute Papst Blue Ribbon, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt,
das ist so quasi das Oettinger oder das Sternburger in Portland.
Unter Studenten hat das so einen leichten Kultstatus, das Zeug,
obwohl es nicht besonders gut ist, halt einfach, weil es billig ist.
Ich fand das einfach so ja, irgendwie war das witzig der Doomguy hat auch eine
Brille und guckt ganz wichtig künstlerisch,
also was mit dem Käse auf sich hat, weiß ich nicht genau irgendwo findet man
wohl auch noch Käse Cheese.
30% habe ich gerade schon mir hier.
Oh, dann hast du irgendwo Cheese gefunden.
Man vergisst ja immer, dass das erste Doom noch nicht nach oben und unten gucken
konnte Das ist gerade wieder, mein Gott, das ist echt lange her.
Ja, ja, das ist sehr, sehr witzig.
1993, ja.
Achso, das sind die Dinge, G ist 30 Prozent, ja.
Ja, das fand ich irgendwie so als kleinen, was kann man alles so machen?
Leider läuft es nicht auf Mobilgeräten, aber man kann tatsächlich auch das Ganze
als Windows-Ding kann man es auch runterladen, wenn man denn möchte.
So, das war die eine Kleinigkeit.
Ach ja, wir hatten das letzte Mal über alte Macs geredet und dann kam auf den
Kongress jemand auf mich zu.
Und meinte so, kennst du denn schon Infinite Mac?
Auch das nochmal den Link hier rein. Infinite Mac, oh jetzt habe ich hier, egal.
Infinite Mac ist, da hat jemand irgendwelche Mac Emulatoren auch fürs Web gemacht
und dann kann man da tatsächlich...
Kann man da alte Mac-Systeme, so richtig alte Mac-Systeme starten und kann sich
da im Ding drin rumklicken.
Lustigerweise gibt es tatsächlich auch relativ viele CDs, die man in den etwas
neueren Systemen starten kann.
Unter anderem ein Myst und ein Riven und sogar ein Marathon.
Also man kann da quasi auf dem Emulator Marathon spielen.
Die muss man aber extern heranführen, die sind natürlich nicht auf der Webseite.
Doch, die sind mit auf der Webseite.
Ach echt?
Mehr, ja. Also wenn man so ein macOS, was ist denn das hier,
8.1 laufen lässt, dann kann man, da gibt es da unten so ein CD-ROM-Ding und
da ist jede Menge Krempel drin.
Tatsächlich.
Loadrunner sehe ich hier. Doom 2.
Sogar Quake.
Ja, es sind nicht nur die Macs, die hier emuliert werden, sondern es sind auch
die Next-Step-Systeme.
Also im Prinzip sind es 68K-Emulatoren, die hier als WebAssembly tatsächlich im Browser laufen.
Das kann man natürlich ganz gut machen mit WebAssembly.
Und ja, dann kann man hier mal nachfühlen, wie es ist, mit so alten Systemen
zu arbeiten und ja, dauert allerdings auch ganz schön lange,
also ich boote hier gerade mal so einen OpenStep, das hat schon ganz gut zu tun.
Lustig ist bei den älteren Mac-Systemen und das hatte ich auch schon komplett vergessen,
Die Menüs bleiben nicht offen, wenn man von der Maustaste runter geht.
Zumindest nicht bei den ganz Alten, ja.
Also...
Das war schon ein bisschen anders alles.
Das war schon alles anders, ja.
Und auch so auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise unstable. Da muss man sich erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Aber es war nicht alles schlecht da drauf.
Ja, so ein Trip down Memory Lane, wenn man die Dinger kannte.
Kannte, beziehungsweise einfach mal anschauen, wenn man es nicht kennt,
wie ja, wir hatten ja nichts.
Genau, wir hatten ja nichts und das insofern glaube ich so für die jüngere Generation
mal ganz gut rauszufinden, wie sich das auch so entwickelt hat.
Also gerade macOS, von dem ganz alten, wie wenig da eigentlich auch am Anfang
da war und wie sehr man auch von sehr wenigen Programmen,
dann profitiert hat und wie auch einzelne Programme, die es dann irgendwann
mal gab, so einen totalen Craze und den nächsten Schritt ausgelöst haben.
Also die Ankunft von PageMaker und später von QuarkXpress, was das einfach,
das hat ja so komplette Industrien begründet und eingerissen auch gleichzeitig.
Diese ganze Desktop-Publishing-Welt war ja das, was überhaupt den Macs erst
so richtig auf die Agenda gesetzt hat.
Bis dahin war es eher so ein Experiment und ja, kann man machen,
Maus, interessant, Fenster, wozu braucht man das?
Und dann kam halt irgendwie Desktop-Publishing und dann alle so, yeah.
Ja, vor allem die ganz alten Systeme waren ja noch nicht mal Multitasking-Systeme.
System 7.0, Multifinder, ja okay,
aber ich glaube genau bis System 6 war es ja auch komplett, also nicht mal präemptives
Multitasten, war wirklich nur ein Programm starten und wenn man was anderes
machen wollte, Programm beenden, anderes Programm starten.
So ist auch interessant mal zu sehen.
Und präemptiv war es auch bis zum Schluss nicht, also auch Mac OS 9 ist nicht
präemptiv gewesen, es war immer kooperatives Multitasking.
Nein, sie haben dann was ganz Böses gebaut.
Und zwar das Hauptsystem lief mit kooperativem Multitasking.
Man konnte aber präemptive Threads im System starten.
Für all die Programme, die parallel noch Dinge tun wollten.
Und Multiprozessor Max und so weiter. Ja, du guckst sehr verwirrt.
Achso, aber dann nur bei Multicore-Systemen mit so einem speziellen API,
um da drauf was laufen zu lassen. Dafür gab es ein spezielles Framework.
Aber nicht die normalen.
Das war kein spezielles Framework, ich glaube ab System 8.1 oder 8.2 oder so.
Das darfst du gerne mal nachschlagen.
War das standardmäßig drin? Ja, ich weiß, wenn ich das damals nicht mir ganz
genau angeguckt habe, weil ich dachte, scheiß die Wand an, was haben die denn da gebaut?
Naja, auf jeden Fall war das alles Zeit, durch die Tür zu gehen und es ging
ja dann Gott sei Dank auch durch die Tür, auch wenn es dann nochmal bis 2001
gedauert hat, bis wir dann wirklich Abhilfe bekommen haben in Form von macOS 10.
Ja, die letzten macOS, also gerade macOS 9 war ja nun wirklich nur noch Live-Support.
Und ich glaube auch so ein bisschen die Vorbereitung darauf,
dass man jetzt endlich mal auf macOS 10, wie es dann hieß, umsteigt.
Also da waren dann auch so Kompatibilitätslayer eingezogen, dass die Programme,
die vorbereitet waren unter macOS 10 zu laufen, auch in macOS 9 laufen konnten und und und und und.
Beziehungsweise sie haben das ganze macOS 9 gebundelt, dass man es in macOS
10 laufen lassen konnte und so. Das war alles ein großes Scheiße.
Und man konnte vor allem den Niedergang von Apple an der Versionsnummer ablesen.
Je mehr Punkte sie hat.
Ja, mit Punkten fing es an. Es gab System 7.
Das war so der Aufbruch. Jetzt alles ein bisschen bunter, Multifinder,
mehrere Programme gleichzeitig, wenn auch kooperativ.
Dann kam so 7.1. Da wurde es irgendwie ein bisschen gebackfixbar.
Da werden ein paar Sachen rausgeschmissen.
Dann kam 7.5. Totales Feature-Upgrade. Richtig viele interessante Sachen drin.
Und viel bunt auch. Oder mehr bunt.
Mehr bunt, genau. 7.6, das waren alles noch so die Zeiten, wo es irgendwie noch ganz gut aussah.
7.6 war die Version, die sie gebaut hatten, damit die Clone-Hersteller das mit
ihren Systemen bundeln konnten. Die Mac-Clones, erinnerst du dich?
Ja.
Genau, die haben die 7.6 bekommen. Richtig. Und die Acht wurde den Clon-Hersteller nicht mehr lizenziert.
Das war so ein bisschen so ein Trick, den Steve, der damals dann schon zurück
war, aus dem Hut gezogen hat, um die Clon-Hersteller wieder loszuwerden.
Ja gut, er hat dann auch einfach gekündigt und hat gesagt, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Und hat den erfolgreichsten von denen auch direkt, glaube ich,
gekauft oder alle eingestellt oder so.
Genau, aber das war ja dann schon so der Bugfix ich hab jetzt gerade so,
fluppiglich hier angefangen und gesagt man kann es in der Visionsnummer ablesen
und ich überlege jetzt gerade, was war es denn genau ich glaube mit 7,
7.5 7.5 ging es dann los dann gab es 7.5.1 7.5.2 7.5.3 und dann gab es,
753 Revision 2?
Gab es nicht gleich 755? Irgendwann hatten sie in der letzten Point-Version
mal eine übersprungen, weil sie da fast eine Version rausgebracht hätten und
damit es keine Verwirrung gibt, haben sie die Nummer einfach ausgelassen.
Äh, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich weiß nur das, was ich gerade angesprochen hatte,
dass man sozusagen die Krise an der Versionsnummer ablesen konnte.
Also eine Firma, die normalerweise noch nicht mal in die dritte Stelle gegangen
ist, hatte dann ein 751, 752, 753, 753 Revision 2 und dann 753 Revision 2.1.
Also es gab wirklich eine 753 V2.1 und die dann auch nicht irgendwie auf allen
Rechnern lief und so also es war, sie haben einfach ihre ganze Stabilität nicht
mehr hinbekommen, sie war nicht mehr in der Lage,
ein OS zu releasen, was sowohl stabil als auch auf allen Rechnern lief und das
haben sie dann alles erst irgendwie so mit,
755 so halbwegs eingefangen bekommen und 76 war dann so der Anfang mit,
okay jetzt versuchen wir mal das Schiff irgendwie zu retten.
Es gab noch, Version 2.2 gab es auch noch.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ist Anfang,
97 dann Next gekauft worden, ne?
Ähm 95, 96 muss das gewesen sein.
Oder war es Ende 96, Anfang 97, so in der Gegend.
Next wurde von Apple, wann gekauft? Ende 96.
Ende 96, genau. Und wenn man das hier, also wenn die Daten hier stimmen auf
der Seite, dann kam ja quasi 7.6 raus, als Next schon eingekauft wurde.
Klar, da war erstmal Chaos, nehme ich mal an.
Und das macOS 8, was sie dann rausgebracht haben, war ja eigentlich nicht das,
was sie jahrelang angekündigt hatten.
Sie hatten ja dieses PINK, Codename PINK angekündigt, was ja der neue Kernel zusammen mit IBM.
Ja, also das war der, das war, pass auf,
Pink war ein Forschungsprojekt zusammen mit IBM auf Basis von AIX oder irgendwie so was zu machen,
mit irgendwie Intelligent noch irgendwie als Firma mit drin und das war alles
auch so ein objektorientiertes Geschwurbel und das ging nowhere.
Dann haben sie Copland angekündigt. Das war das, was sie eigentlich als Codename
für ihr sagenumwobenes macOS 8 mit, das hat dann auch richtiges Multitasking.
Ja, genau, Copland.
Das kam auch nie raus, sondern stattdessen haben sie dann Next gekauft in ihrer
Panik und das war, sagen wir mal, das Beste, was sie damals tun konnten.
Dadurch kam Steve Jobs wieder in die Firma, der ein halbes Jahr lang nur so Berater war.
Dann haben sie den Jill Amelio gefeuert und dann haben sie Steve Jobs als I-CEO
als Interim-CEO den Titel, den er.
Dann irgendwann getroppt.
Hat genau und dann hat er sich sozusagen für null Dollar einstellen lassen und
dann hat er halt irgendwie alles gekillt, was gerade war,
alles gesteaved, alle Computerprojekte wurden eingestellt,
meine Die Lieblingsprogrammiersprache Döllen wurde damals,
gekillt, die damals noch bei Apple entwickelt wurde.
Eigentlich wurde so ziemlich alles eingestellt und er hat dann alles auf eine
Karte gesetzt und hat gesagt, bei der Hardware machen wir es jetzt so,
wir bauen jetzt den iMac und machen eine einfache Produktmatrix.
Der iMac war aber, soweit ich weiß, auch schon ein Kind von Almelio gewesen.
Der war schon länger in der Entwicklung.
Den hat Steve dann ein bisschen angepasst und rausgehauen.
Wenn du dir den iMac anguckst, wie er rauskam mit seinem durchsichtigen Kram,
glaubst du, ein Steve Jobs hätte so was von sich aus rausgehauen?
Wie was?
Naja, dieses durchsichtige Plastik.
Ja, selbstverständlich hat er das rausgehauen. Also das hätte er ja nicht rausgehauen,
wenn er das nicht rausgehauen...
Die erste iMac-Hardware hatte übrigens noch auf der Platine einen Anschlussport
für ein Diskettenlaufwerk. Das wurde auch gesteaved.
Ja, klar. Also ich meine, es kann natürlich sein, dass es irgendeine Entwicklung schon gab.
Ja, die Entwicklung gab es ein bisschen länger.
Power-PCs waren ja jetzt in dem Sinne nichts Neues.
Nee, nicht mehr.
Genau. Naja, egal. Wir müssen ja nicht die ganze Apple-Next-Geschichte nacherzählen.
Auf jeden Fall ist es schön, mal so ein altes macOS im Browser ein bisschen auszuprobieren.
Man muss jetzt nicht alte Hardware dafür kaufen.
Könnt ihr ja mal machen. Vielleicht nehmt ihr ein bisschen Tuchfühlung auf und
habt Verständnis für die alten Säcke, für die das damals einfach bittere Realität war.
So und als allerletztes und das hoffe ich, das schaffen wir jetzt wirklich in
kurz, ist, wir hatten letztes Mal über Wasserkocher gesprochen.
Da gab es viel Feedback.
Ein bereits kommentiertes Thema.
Und das ist jetzt so ein Zufallsprodukt und zwar in Hamburg in dem Hotel, in dem ich war,
gab es keinen Wasserkocher, hatte das Frühstück nicht dazu gebucht und wenn
ich morgens meinen Tee nicht kriege, dann kann das sein, dass ich unleidlich
werde. Also habe ich dann am ersten Tag,
beim Elektronik-Großhändler irgendwie geguckt, was es da in der Wasserkocherabteilung
so gibt und da bin ich auf dieses Produkt gestoßen, der UNOLED Reiseblitzkocher
aus Edelstahl, Halber Liter,
30 Euro und habe den dann einfach mitgenommen und war auch sehr zufrieden damit.
Also da sind noch irgendwelche komischen Plastikbecher dabei,
das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig. Und komische Plastiklöffel und so ein Scheiß.
Wie viel Watt?
1000 Watt.
1000? 1000 Watt. Dadurch, dass der so klein ist und nur einen halben Liter Wasser
warm macht, ist es dann aber auch egal.
Es ist jetzt nur so, dass ich mir wahrscheinlich eine größere EcoFlow kaufen
muss, damit ich dann auch 1000 Watt habe, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Also klar, keine Ahnung, das Ding würde ich jetzt zu Hause nicht benutzen,
da habe ich einen richtigen Wasserkocher.
Aber so als Reisewasserkocher, den
gibt es auch mit so einer schönen Transport-Turnbeutel, wie nennt man das?
Reisetasche.
So ein Beutel mit so einem Zwei-Kordel-Verschluss, so ein Turnbeutel halt.
Gibt es auch in einer 1,5 Liter Version.
Ja, dann würde ich ihn aber nicht mehr als Reisekocher bezeichnen.
Nicht mehr so handlich.
Also der ist wirklich sehr handlich.
Ja, ich habe mir sowas auch schon mal gekauft. Das ist im Campingbereich ganz
praktisch, einen Reisewasserkocher zu haben, insbesondere wenn er nicht so viel Strom zieht.
Also man will ja eigentlich beim Wasserkocher, dass er viel Strom zieht,
weil viel Strom viel schnell.
Aber wenn du halt nicht die belastbare Elektrik dahinter hast,
dann sind halt niederwattigere Reisekocher besser.
Richtig, danach habe ich nämlich auch geguckt, weil ich der Stromverteilung
da im Hotel auch nicht so richtig getraut habe.
Und so 1000 Watt, das sollte aber auch die schlechteste Steckdose noch mitmachen.
Na gut, Wasserkocher, alles klar. So, was haben wir auf der Uhr?
Oh Gott, Politik, Ralf.
Ja, ich versuche mich kurz und nicht allzu empört zu halten.
Ja, das wird bestimmt gelingen.
Das wird bestimmt super. Wir haben ja bald einen neuen Präsidenten der USA.
Ja, wir ja Gott sei Dank nicht.
Wir nicht. Naja, wir als Welt insgesamt dann halt irgendwie doch schon.
Insbesondere aber diverse CEOs der USA und die machen jetzt also alle Reihe
um ihren Bückling und spenden erstmal Geld für die Einführungsfeier von Trump.
So beispielsweise auch Apple-Chef Steve Cook.
Der heißt also Tim Apple.
Tim Apple heißt der.
Gott, Gott, das ist die Freutschke-Fehleistung.
Ja, eine Million Dollar für Trump spenden. Das ist aber keine Korruption, oder?
Das ist vermutlich noch keine Korruption. Also es wird aber darauf hingewiesen,
dass er das quasi als Person macht und nicht die Firma Apple das spendet.
Welchen Unterschied das dann am Ende auch immer irgendwo machen soll.
Naja, das macht schon einen Unterschied.
Auf jeden Fall, wer sich dort...
Würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, also klar, es ist natürlich alles ein bisschen
traurig, wie sehr sie sich da unterwerfen müssen, aber in gewisser Hinsicht
hat er damit verhindert, dass Apple irgendwas tun muss.
Wenn er das aus eigener Tasche zahlt, der ist jetzt eh nicht mehr lange CEO.
Und ja, you take it for the team.
Ja.
Ach, Tim himself hat das gespendet.
Ja, ja.
Ja, dass ihm jetzt die Million nicht wehtut. Da mache ich mir jetzt die wenigsten Sorgen drum.
Das ist ja von vorne bis hinten. Das ist ja nur eine reine Symbolgeste.
Na, wer auf jeden Fall halt auch seine nächste Million reingeworfen hat in dieses
Säckel, ist dann eben Mark Zuckerberg, Chef von Meta, Facebook,
Instagram, Threads und Konsorten.
Und der hat aber nicht nur das Geld reingeworfen, sondern eben auch noch,
ist gerade erst zwei, drei Tage her,
verkündet, dass am selben Tag, wo Trump Präsident wird,
weite Teile des Meta-Universums von jeglicher Art von Fakten,
Checks und in Anführungszeichen Zensur befreit wird, weil jetzt ja schließlich
ein neuer Zeitgeist angebrochen sei und wir in einem neuen Zeitalter leben und,
jetzt wird endlich mal aufgeräumt,
und da weiß man gar nicht so richtig, wo man irgendwie anfangen soll.
Von daher würde ich mich da jetzt auch wirklich gar nicht groß so auslassen.
Hast du die Mem-Schlacht da drum gesehen?
Die Mem-Schlacht? Ne, die habe ich in der Tat nicht gesehen.
Also hier gibt es einmal den Mark Zuckerberg recipient of world's first red
penis transplant announces Meta will stop fact-shacking.
Achso, ja doch, die Sachen habe ich gesehen.
Facebook-Founder and Convicted-Pedophile Mark Zuckerberg, dead at 36,
says social media sites should not fuck check posts.
Etc..
Etc.
Das habe ich gesehen, das Instant quillt über von Falschmeldungen,
die er jetzt ja eigentlich alle nicht mehr löschen dürfte über sich.
Genau.
Naja, das Ganze hat natürlich dann eben doch leider auch einen sehr ernsten Hintergrund,
weil er sich auch in der Argumentation auch hinter X quasi dranhängt und sagt,
so wir machen jetzt alles so wie Musk und machen stattdessen jetzt eben so diese Community Notes.
Das heißt also, die Mehrheit der Lesenden muss sich einig sein,
so, das stimmt hier nicht und dann kann man eine entsprechende Notiz dann ranhängen
an einen Inhalt, wie fantastisch das funktioniert, das sehen wir jetzt ja bei X.
Sprich die ganzen Firmen, die jetzt gerade glücklich irgendwie nach Threads
migriert sind, können sich jetzt wieder als nächstes überlegen,
wo sie noch hin wollen, klar, die sind jetzt dann auch nach Blue Sky gezogen,
anstatt irgendwie nach Mastodon, wie es sich vielleicht mal gehören würde,
und das macht mich zornig und wütend und das könnt ihr euch anhören,
wie ich richtig zornig und wütend werde, wenn ihr das möchtet,
denke ich nicht hier und jetzt, sondern,
da war ich auf dem Kongress in einem Podcast eingeladen, dem Wisspod.
Nele Heise war da auch zu Gast. Und da hatte ich, glaube ich,
auch schon ein bisschen was getrunken.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr so ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall bin ich da für meine Verhältnisse
irgendwie, glaube ich, ungewöhnlich krawallig geworden.
Vorhin ja, Tim, du hörst dir deine Sachen noch an, um ein Gespür dafür zu bekommen.
So war das jetzt eigentlich gut und kannst du das weiterempfehlen?
Ich würde das jetzt unter Vorbehalt weiterempfehlen.
Ich glaube, so rhetorisch lässt das Ganze vielleicht ein bisschen zu wünschen
übrig. Ich entwickle da aber so ein paar Grundgedanken, wo ich glaube,
da kann man vielleicht doch was mit anstellen.
Und das würde ich jetzt vielleicht nur in 20 Sekunden mal zusammenpacken.
Ich glaube, wir müssen völlig aufhören, irgendwelche Feature-Debatten zu führen.
Also dieses ganze, wir können als Firma irgendwie oder als Journalisten nicht
auf Mastodon gehen, weil da fehlt uns Feature XY und das ist alles völliger Quatsch.
Sich in diese ganzen Debatten noch überhaupt reinzuklinken, das macht überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn. Und ich bin mittlerweile der festen Überzeugung,
dass Europa da einen ganz anderen Weg einschlagen sollte, nämlich erstens über
Geld gehen und zweitens über Juristen.
Das heißt also öffentliche Software, öffentlicher Code.
Und das transferieren wir jetzt einfach auf Social Media. Wenn irgendwo ein
Projekt oder eine öffentliche Einrichtung des öffentlichen Dienstes gefördert
wird mit öffentlichen Geldern, dann müssen die auch mindestens einen offenen Kanal bespielen.
Und eben nicht nur irgendwie X und Threads und TikTok, sondern können sich aussuchen,
was sie wollen. Aber es muss irgendetwas Öffentliches sein.
Und damit das Ganze auch vernünftig durchgesetzt wird. Also erstens kriegen
sie kein Geld, wenn sie es nicht machen.
Und das geht meiner Meinung nach aber immer noch nicht weit genug.
Daher würde ich als zweites vorschlagen, wir brauchen ja einfach mal eine Gesetzgebung dafür.
Und dass sowas funktioniert, das haben wir bei DSGVO gesehen,
das haben wir bei BETV2 gesehen. Alle stöhnen darüber.
Wo gesehen? BETV2?
BETV2.
Was ist das?
Das ist Barrierefreiheit.
Ah.
Dass du also alle Webseiten barrierefrei machen musstest.
Ach, die Accessibility-Sache?
Ja, ganz genau so. Alle stöhnen, aber es passiert.
Und genau so machen wir jetzt einfach mal eine Gesetzgebung,
wo drin steht, öffentlich finanzierte Einrichtungen müssen auch freie,
offene Kommunikations-Social-Media-Kanäle bespielen.
Was sie daneben noch alles machen, ist mir völlig egal.
Können die alles bespielen, wenn sie meinen, sie brauchen das.
Sie müssen einfach verdonnert werden. Und von selber werden weder die Politikerinnen
es lernen, noch die Journalistinnen es lernen, noch die Social-Media-Teams es lernen.
Also müssen wir da mit anderen Hebeln dran und den Gedanken führe ich da ein bisschen aus.
Und jetzt höre ich auch schon, weil ich fange schon wieder an,
mich aufzuregen und das will ich aber heute gar nicht.
Sehr gut.
Naja, also ich meine die Hoffnung, dass wir uns nicht mehr über Features unterhalten,
da kann ich dir gleich sagen, dass wir enttäuscht werden.
Wir, da meint er jetzt nicht die Anwesenden.
Sondern… Nein, ich auch nicht.
Nein, aber wenn du dir anguckst, Monate, Monate, Querstrich,
jahrelang mussten wir uns anhören, warum gerade Journalistinnen auf gar keinen
Fall irgendwie mit Mastodon klarkommen, weil ihnen da Feature Exhibition kommt.
Und so dieselben Leute, dieselben Teams sind innerhalb einer Woche alle mit
Pauken und Trompeten zu Blue Sky eingezogen, was vom Feature-Set her immer noch
ungefähr ein Viertel von dem hat, was Mastodon seit Jahren irgendwie Ja.
Aber die Sachen, die sie halt brauchen.
Als das da jetzt wäre.
Ja, Suche zum Beispiel. Ich meine, das ist schon mal so das erste Thema,
dass du halt mal in den ganzen Scheiß nach allem suchen kannst und das kannst du halt bei Masse nicht.
Du suchst halt irgendwo irgendwie.
Hashtags kommen auch nur von irgendwo irgendwie. Du hast halt immer so Ausschnittsblasen
und ja, ich weiß, warum das so ist und ich weiß auch, dass das eine bewusste
Design Entscheidung ist.
Das hat auch alles seine Gründe, aber es ändert halt nichts an der Tatsache,
dass das eben einfach mal sich nicht so twitterig anfühlt und das ist nun mal
das, was die Leute suchen.
Also ich will das jetzt nicht bewerben, ich sag nur, das ist der Grund, warum und du kannst halt,
noch so mit hehren Zielen und Weltrettung und Umweltschutz und Accessibility
und Freiheit und Demokratie, kannst du so werben, wie du willst.
Die Leute wollen am Ende das kriegen, was sie haben wollen und wenn das halt
nicht da gibt, dann wird das nicht benutzt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das die Gründe sind, aber das diskutieren wir echt nicht hier und heute.
Ich glaube, das liegt in der Art und Weise, wie die Social-Media-Teams aufgestellt
sind, wie deren mittleres Management aufgestellt ist und was dort die Entscheidungswege sind.
Das hat nichts mit Features zu tun.
Ja gut, ich meine, die rennen natürlich dahin, wo alle sind und denken nicht
über solche Metathemen nach, wie du das oder wir das tun.
Und dann ist das eben die Folge davon.
Dieses, wo alle sind, die waren ja eben alle nicht bei Blue Sky.
Das heißt also, wer tritt dann dort eben die Stampede eigentlich los,
mit was für der Agenda wird das Ganze eigentlich losgetreten.
Und warum schafft die EU es in so vielen anderen Bereichen mit Regularien dann
doch im Großen und Ganzen das Richtige zu tun und gerade hier schaffen sie es aber halt nicht.
Ja gut, ich meine es waren dann halt schon kritische Massen.
Bei Blue Sky. Nicht für alle Gruppen, aber eben für manche.
Und wie es eben so ist, wenn die Promis irgendwo hinmarschieren, dann sind alle da.
Heise hat jetzt zum Jahresende wieder schön ihre Statistiken mal publiziert,
wie sie auf den verschiedenen Social Media Kanälen eigentlich jetzt vertreten
sind und wie viel Traffic auf ihre eigentlichen Angebote sie aus welchen Kanälen bekommen. Ja.
So und da ist jetzt Mastodon mittlerweile führend, gleichauf mit Facebook interessanterweise,
aber weit vor Threads, weit vor Blue Sky, weit vor X.
Das heißt also, wenn ich das systematisch und vernünftig bespiele,
ist es eine Bubble, aber es ist innerhalb von Deutschland dann doch auch schon
eine relativ große Bubble, unsere Tech-Bubble immerhin.
Ja, aber ich würde die Zahlen für die Gala gerne mal sehen.
Naja, also wenn man das vernünftig bespielt, dann kannst du dort echt Reichweite
generieren, die auch nicht nur gekaufte Bots sind, sondern echte reale Menschen.
Aber daran haben die Social Media Teams vielleicht gar nicht so viel Interesse,
weil die halt andere KPIs bespielen müssen.
Aber lass uns das echt nicht hier und heute jetzt noch ausbehalten.
KPIs sind der Teufel.
Gut, vor 40 Jahren, oder sind wir wieder bei alten Scheiß, das hätten wir schon
mit dem macOS eben bringen können, vor 40 Jahren wurde der Atari ST vorgestellt.
Habt ihr mal Kontakt gehabt mit einem Atari ST?
Ja, die Tastatur war richtig scheiße.
Und der Bildschirm war spannend, weil zwar nur grau, aber ziemlich hochauflösend.
Nee, schwarz-weiß war der.
Der hatte grau Stufen, oder?
Nein.
Der war nicht schwarz-weiß.
Der war schwarz-weiß. Hatte nur ein bisschen mehr Auflösung.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, also es gab die Farboption, die hatte nicht die Auflösung.
Und dann gab es den schwarz-weiß Bildschirm.
Und der war wie der Mac, nur nicht so geil.
Der SM124, Monochroma-Monitor mit sagenhaften 640x400 Bildpunkten.
Ja, das war damals ein Traum.
Weil damals mein Best, also ich hatte einen Amiga und mein bester Freund hatte
einen Atari ST. Man kann sich vorstellen, was das für eine entspannte Situation war.
Aber ich habe das echt in Erinnerung, dass der graustufen konnte.
Gab es irgendwann eine Nachfolge gewesen?
Aber einen reinen Graustufen-Monitor gab es nicht von Atari.
Es gab ja nur den Farbmonitor.
Interessant.
Aber das war ja quasi so die Zeit, wo du eben eigentlich gerade gewechselt bist
von diesen rein analog-videogetriebenen Monitoren, die halt rumflackerten und
rumflummerten oder du eben in der Regel deinen Fernseher angeschlossen hast als Alternative dazu.
Und da war natürlich dieser Atari-Monitor wie eben auch der Macintosh-Monitor
vorher ja schon eine totale Segen.
Also im Prinzip haben sie ja nur den Mac kopiert. Überhaupt war der Atari ST
eine reine Copy Machine?
Also ich würde mal sagen, auf dem Atari ST war überhaupt nichts wirklich neu.
Nee, selbst das Dateisystem war irgendwie ein Fad von DOS.
Oh, ist noch schlimmer. Das ganze Betriebssystem, was unten drunter lag,
unter diesem Gem, was sie ja auch von DR Research eingekauft haben, hieß ja TOS-Modell.
Warum hieß das TOS?
Tremiel OS?
Ja, genau. Tremiel Operating System. Jack Tremiel war ja der Gründer von Atari
ST. Vorher war er bei Commodore.
Und lustiger Typ, habe ich auch noch eine kleine Anekdote zu erzählen.
Auf jeden Fall, dieses TOS war halt auf dem 68K im Prinzip das normale MS-DOS.
Also sie haben wirklich nicht sehr viel mehr gemacht als MS-DOS auf 68K sozusagen umzusetzen.
Neu kompiliert.
Ähnlichen Abstraktionen und Kommandozeilen und so weiter. Also da war nicht wirklich viel neu.
Ein paar Abweichungen mag es gegeben haben, aber das war alles so barebones und so dahin gerotzt.
Also Operating System technisch war das Ding überhaupt nicht geil.
Der einzige Wurf war, sie waren auf dem Markt.
Und sie hatten eine MIDI-Schnittstelle.
Amiga, genau. Und sie hatten eine MIDI-Schnittstelle. Und das war,
glaube ich, den meisten Anwendern in den USA irgendwie egal,
hat aber einen interessanten Effekt gehabt. Wisst ihr welchen?
Naja, sie waren halt die MIDI-Sequencing-Maschine schlechthin.
Genau, das war die Musikmaschine.
Aber was war der eigentliche, okay, ich frage mal ein bisschen anders.
Was ist, Also wir kennen ja alle die Bedeutung der USA für Software.
Da kommen die meisten Apps her, da kommen die meisten Betriebssysteme her und
überhaupt Software und so weiter.
Außer den USA gibt es sehr wenige Länder, die überhaupt für irgendwas bekannt sind.
Also sagen wir mal ein Land und für welche Art von Software dieses Land bekannt ist.
Naja, es gab zur 8-Bit-Zeit und auch später gab es einige Spielebuden in England.
Mhm, richtig.
Auch einige in Frankreich. Und ich würde sagen, Musiksoftware war eigentlich
Deutschland immer ein Hotspot.
Genau. Steinberg, wann hatten die das erste?
Wegen des Atari ST.
Und warum Deutschland?
Keine Ahnung, also ich glaube Steinberg waren die die Ersten also Imagic,
das was dann später Apple gekauft hat war ja eine Ausgründung von Steinberg.
Deswegen sind die auch beide in Hamburg.
Genau, deswegen sind die beide in Hamburg War Steinberg die erste Boote die in MIDI Tracker sind.
Notator Notator Logic,
War glaube ich, Cubase war das Erste.
Cubase war Steinberg.
Notator, Logic, daraus wurde dann später Logic.
Nein, Logic ist aber Imagic. Also es ist dann schon die Ausbildung.
Genau, genau. Also Cubase war das Erste. So, und das fing halt alles in Deutschland an.
In Deutschland haben die Leute ein Atari gekauft mit MIDI und Deutschland ist
halt Kraftwerk-Country.
Techno, elektronische Musik, das haben die Amerikaner ja auch jetzt nach Jahrzehnten
immer noch nicht verstanden.
Aber Deutschland war halt immer schon der Ort, wo elektronische Musik gemacht
wurde. Und deswegen gab es diesen Druck.
Mit Cubase hat es angefangen, dann kam halt Logic, dann kam Ableton, Native Instruments.
Also mit Ausnahme von Reaper kommen alle DAWs der Welt aus Deutschland.
Gott, und gerade die muss ich nutzen. Verdammt.
Naja.
Ableton ist eine Ausgründung von Native Instruments gewesen.
War es nicht andersrum?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Da ich bei Ableton gearbeitet habe, weiß ich das ziemlich sicher.
Ja, okay, gut. Ja, dann so rum, wie auch immer. Aber auf jeden Fall Berlin, Hamburg.
Berlin, Hamburg.
So, und ich meine Apple Music. Also nicht Apple Music as in Apple Music,
sondern Apple, die Softwareabteilung für Logic, für GarageBand und so weiter.
In Hamburg, ja.
Ist auch immer noch in Hamburg.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich habe da ja auch gearbeitet.
Da hast du gearbeitet?
Da habe ich gearbeitet, das ist ein halbes Jahr.
Ah ja, okay. Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist auch immer noch so.
Und es gibt ja überhaupt nur sehr wenige Orte, wo Apple außerhalb der USA Software
produziert. Und das ist halt eine der Ausnahmen.
Eine andere Ausnahme ist, glaube ich, in Israel gibt es noch etwas.
Und dann weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Zu Apple in Hamburg gibt es eine lustige Anekdote.
Und zwar war Apple, als Garageband gerade so rausgekommen ist,
wollten die dafür ein Audiointerface auf den Markt werfen.
Und dieses Audio-Interface wurde aber von den Hardware-Leuten von eMagic gebaut.
Und deswegen haben alle in Amerika gesagt, nee, das Ding hat es nie gegeben.
Das ist ein Rumor, das nicht stimmt.
Aber es gab das Teil, ich hatte es auf dem Schreibtisch und ich habe tatsächlich
den Software-Updater dafür geschrieben.
Es wurde leider nie veröffentlicht.
Okay, verstehe. Also auf jeden
Fall, das war der Grund, warum der Atari ST überhaupt eine Bedeutung hat.
Weil ich glaube, ansonsten war eigentlich alles relativ zweitklassig.
Der Amiga war deutlich besser bei Spielen, war deutlich besser bei Video und bei 3D.
Der Amiga hatte ein Ding, das hat vor und nach dem Amiga nie ein anderes System getan.
Also vielleicht spezielle Karten, aber das sogenannte Gen-Log-Fähigkeit.
Und zwar konnte der Amiga seine Grafik nicht nur...
Extern synchronisieren. Also der Grafikchip konnte das Zeilensignal extern eingespeist
bekommen, sondern konnte über einen ganz speziellen Pin auch sagen,
hier darf das eine Signal durch und hier möchte ich was anzeigen.
Und deswegen konnte man da relativ leicht Geräte bauen, wo du quasi Videoeingang,
Amiga, Videoausgang und dann das Amiga-Bild mit Alpha-Kanal,
also digitalen Alpha-Kanal, davor blenden konntest.
Und das war so der Standard, keine Ahnung, für ein paar Jahre war es der Standard,
der auch im Fernsehen viel verwendet wurde.
Weil du auf einmal synchronisiertes Video hattest sozusagen.
Genau, weil du dich extern synchronisieren konntest und keine Hardware brauchtest,
die zwei Bilder irgendwie zusammen mischst, sondern die liefen sowieso synchron.
War ja alles analog, wie du so schön sagst.
Also noch zwei Sachen zum ST. Also ich habe jetzt gerade in den Chat nochmal
ein Screenshot reingeworfen.
Ja, das Screen ist wirklich monochrom, aber der Hintergrund vom Desktop,
der sieht grau aus, weil er gedithered ist. Also so jedes Pixel.
Ja, das war bei Mac auch so.
Und da die Qualität halt dann natürlich nicht so toll ist, sieht es dann eben
von ein bisschen weiter weg aus, als ob das quasi ein dritter Farbwert dann
im Graubereich doch dabei wäre.
Aber nicht, weil der Bildschirm nicht gut ist, sondern weil er gut war.
Und da keine Interferenzen und sowas irgendwie reinkommen. Moiré-Effekte, wie es alles heißt.
Und der zweite Punkt, den ich erinnere, war, dass man gut drucken konnte mit
dem ST im Gegensatz zum Amiga.
Dass es dort schon durchaus sowas wie Desktop-Publishing-ähnliche Software drauf hat.
Drucken war kein Amiga-Spezialgebiet, das stimmt.
Es gab, jetzt wo du das sagst, es gab eine Desktop, eine spezielle,
eine, wie hieß das, es gab auf dem Atari-Spezialgebiet,
So eine Desktop-Publishing-Software.
Und da konnte man mit Schriften auswechseln, die nicht in einem Drucker eingebaut
waren. Das ging auf Mami überhaupt nicht.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
Ja, nicht gar nicht unsere Schülerzeitung drauf gedruckt.
Desktop-Publishing auf dem Atari ST. Da gab es eine, das weiß bestimmt der Chat
schneller, als ich antworten kann.
Aber da gab es ein ColorMoss. Genau, ColorMoss.
Ein rahmenorientiertes Layout-Programm und das hatte in der Tat ja, das hatte Bedeutung.
Weil ja auch desktop Publishing in Deutschland relativ stark war,
weil wir viel Publikationen, Verlage und so weiter hatten, da hat sich das dann
tatsächlich auch teilweise etabliert. Das stimmt.
Das ist neben der ganzen Musikgeschichte so eine Sache.
So und ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Story schon mal erzählt habe,
aber ich dachte, ich packe sie jetzt einfach mal rein, weil ich habe diesen
Jack Tremiel ja mal kennengelernt.
Der ist ja mittlerweile auch gestorben. Und der Hintergrund ist der,
dass ich ja früher in Hannover gelebt habe, so als Computer-Kit.
Und dann gab es halt so eine Phase, wo ich einen Atari ST hatte.
Nicht lang, aber hatte ich. ich hab's dann, ich hab so eine ulkige Karriere gehabt.
Ich hatte irgendwie C64, dann gab's den Amiga nicht, dann hab ich mir einen
Atari ST gekauft, hab mich mit dem eine Weile beschäftigt.
Dann war das uninteressant, dann hab ich mir einen Commodore PC 10 gekauft,
also einen der allerersten oder den allerersten PC-Klonen und hab ein bisschen
mit DOS rumgemacht, da gab's noch kein Windows,
war also, ja, okay, vielleicht, meinetwegen, aber komme nicht so spät nach Hause.
Und dann habe ich mir einen 286er gekauft,
Und den habe ich dann nicht mehr mit DOS gefahren, sondern mit Xenix.
Und dann ging das mit Unix los und später kam der Mac.
Auf jeden Fall war das die Atari-Zeit. Und wir waren ja in Hannover.
Und was ist in Hannover immer gewesen?
Cebit.
Cebit, genau. Und wer kannte sich richtig gut aus auf der Cebit?
Na du.
Wir, alle. Naja, das ganze CCC hat ja immer die Cebit geohnt.
Und wir waren immer überall. Also wir waren immer auf allen Presseempfängen
und also alles, wenn es irgendeine Party gab, wir waren da.
Egal ob Nokia gerade finnische Bands einlädt und da irgendwie ein großes Festschmeiß
hier, wie hieß es, Leningrad Cowboys, habe ich da irgendwie live gesehen auf
einer Nokia Party und so eine Geschichte.
Und auch jegliche Völlerei von irgendwelchen Firmen und damals ging es noch
opulent zu auf diesen Pressekonferenzen.
Unter anderem auch bei Atari, wo ich dann halt auch immer war. Also wir waren immer da.
Und ja, dann haben wir aber, dann war Jack Tremiel da und dann haben wir nach
dieser Presseveranstaltung gefragt, ob er nicht Bock hat, bei unserem Hackertreff vorbeizukommen.
So auf den Dienstag.
Und er so, ja.
Und wir wussten nicht, ob das wirklich stattfinden wird. Also Hackertreffen
im Sinne von, wir waren so sechs, sieben, acht Leute.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, wir machen hier mit Atari rum und wir kennen
uns irgendwie aus und ob er nicht Bock hat, irgendwie vorbeizukommen.
Und dann hat er zugesagt. Und dann kam er auch tatsächlich mit dem Taxi,
hat sich irgendwie noch so einen Technikmenschen aus seinem Unternehmen genommen.
Und hat, ja, ist dann da aufgeschlagen.
Wir waren also in so einer kleinen Kneipe, irgendwie saß in so einem kleinen,
verrauchten Raum, Jack Tramiel auf dem Sofa.
Der Typ war wirklich unglaublich. Hat die ganze Zeit eigentlich nur gelacht
und fand es einfach alles so irre unterhaltsam und crazy mit uns.
Und wir haben uns da unterhalten und wir konnten halt so technische Fragen fragen,
die dann halt sein Technikmensch soweit ich mich erinnern kann,
weitgehend beantworten konnte. War auf jeden Fall ein lustiger Abend.
Er meinte, er hätte nur irgendwie ganz kurz Zeit, saß dann aber irgendwie über
eine Stunde, glaube ich, oder zwei sogar mit uns rum.
Naja, auf jeden Fall hat dann einer von uns darüber auch diesen Kontakt behalten.
Und ist dann später tatsächlich bei Atari eingestellt worden und war dann,
nachdem Atari irgendwann keinen Erfolg mehr hatte und abgewickelt wurde,
war er dann einer der letzten Mitarbeiter von Atari überhaupt.
Die Tür zugemacht. Also der ist wirklich sozusagen mit Jack Tremiel irgendwie
so als letzter aus dem Raum rausgegangen und das alles nur, weil wir auf einer
Pressekonferenz irgendwie mal
gefragt haben, ob man nicht Bock hat vorbeizukommen. Das war sehr lustig.
Naja, die Geschichte. 40 Jahre ist das jetzt her, früher, als nicht alles besser
war, Leute. Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, es war schlimm.
Nichts hatten wir.
Was ich so lustig fand an Atari, aber das war auch Mac und,
der Amiga, die haben ja alle drei den gleichen Prozessor gehabt.
Und dann gab es natürlich Emulatoren für die jeweils anderen Systeme.
Und ich weiß noch, dass ich auf dem Amiga damals sowohl einen Mac-Emulator hatte,
als auch einen Atari-Emulator.
Oh, der war langsam. Ich glaube, ich habe den einmal ausprobiert.
Der war so schnell, wie der Atari so war. Das Lustige war.
Das war ja nicht ein Emulator in dem Sinne, sondern nur so ein VM,
also der lief ja der Code Native.
Ja, der Code lief Native. Das Lustige war, das Diskettenlaufwerk.
Man hat ja bei dem Zugriff von dem Diskettenlaufwerk gehört,
ah, das ist ein Amiga, das schnarzelt immer so ein bisschen.
Und dann hast du dieses, beim Mac hattest du dieses so ein bisschen so ein,
Ein tiefes Brummen, der hatte nicht so viele Obertöne, sondern der brummte eher so tiefer.
Und dann hatte man noch den Atari, der war irgendwie so irgendwo dazwischen, klang immer nach DOS.
Und immer wenn man einen der Emulatoren laufen ließ, klang tatsächlich auch
das Diskettenlaufwerk wie das von den anderen Systemen, obwohl es die gleiche
Hardware war. das war so dermaßen witzig.
Ich fand das immer super und der Amiga-Emulator von Atari konnte tatsächlich
Original-Atari-Disketten lesen.
Allerdings die Mac-Disketten nicht, weil die Mac-Laufwerke irgendwie komisch waren.
Das weiß ich aber nicht mehr genau, was das Problem an den Mac-Laufwerken war.
Irgendwas war da komisch.
Deswegen waren die nicht kompatibel.
So, und jetzt?
Jetzt bist du, glaube ich, dran, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ich wollte nur kurz noch was ankündigen.
Ich bin nämlich weg. Bald.
Ich hatte ja auch schon vor einiger Zeit hier mal so Reisepläne angekündigt
und die werde ich jetzt auch wahr machen, allerdings anders als ursprünglich gedacht.
Ich werde jetzt nicht nach Neuseeland fahren.
Weil Gründe? Keine Orbits. Naja.
Aufgeschoben ist nie aufgehoben. Ist eine längere Gedankenkette,
die jetzt auch nicht weiter eine Rolle spielt. Aber trotzdem,
ich werde längere Zeit weg sein.
Wir werden aber weiter die Freakshow machen. Ich werde daran remote teilnehmen.
Hier werden alle Klimmzüge gemacht, um das irgendwie sicherzustellen. Unter anderem.
Rude Casa Duo und so weiter, als Reisepodcast-Gerät und so weiter, also für alles gesorgt.
Ja und das wird dann schon mit der nächsten Sendung soweit sein und ich werde
mich dann trotzdem in den weiten Universen, tendenziell Richtung Südostasien
rumtreiben und dort ein paar,
wie ich hoffe, interessante Begegnungen und Erfahrungen machen.
Meine erste Haltestelle ist Singapur, falls es Hörer in Singapur gibt.
Ich weiß, dass es mal Hörer in Singapur gab, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob es noch Hörer in Singapur gibt.
Hörer und Hörerinnen natürlich gleichermaßen, wenn ihr in irgendeiner Form von
dort der Freakshow lauscht,
dann lasst doch mal eine Mail fallen oder so oder schreibt mich auf irgendeinem
Social Media Kanal an, ihr werdet schon einen Weg finden.
Das würde mich auf jeden Fall interessieren, das wird dann übernächste Woche
der Fall sein, also so 17.
18. Januar, dann ziehe ich aber auch schon wieder weiter und ja,
falls ihr da überhaupt irgendwo in der Region seid, ich weiß noch nicht so hundertprozentig,
wo ich überall entlang kommen werde.
Malaysia wird dabei sein, Taiwan wird dabei sein und die Region will vielleicht
auch noch auf andere Art und Weise erkundet werden.
Das kann ich dann auch noch bekannt geben. Also wenn ihr in irgendeiner Form
da seid, dann lasst das doch mich mal wissen und dann gucken wir mal.
Na genau, wir machen dann hier aber trotzdem Kram.
Ja und Singapur hat kein deutsches Internet, sondern ordentliches.
Wie? Schnell oder zensiert?
Schnell, robust, zuverlässig.
Hast du das schon getestet?
Nein, ich frage.
Achso. Ich denke mal, das mit dem Internet, das ist ja so ein Business Hub.
Ja, besser als in Deutschland ist einfach, glaube ich.
Ja, also ich glaube, ich mache mir ehrlich gesagt jetzt keine Sorgen.
Also Zug fahren und Internet, das geht definitiv woanders besser.
Da kann ich kurz einschieben und zwar hat die deutsche Glasfaser ja groß angekündigt,
bei mir in der Ecke Glasfaser legen zu wollen und hat eine Bedarfsermittlung gemacht.
Diese Bedarfsermittlung ging irgendwann zu Ende und seitdem hat sich die Webseite
dort nicht mehr angepasst.
Ich fürchte schon, das wird nichts, die werden wohl doch keine Glasfaser legen.
Und jetzt?
Weiß ich nicht. Gutes, gutes, altes Telekom-Schnürsenkel-DSL, nehme ich mal an.
Ja.
Also, weiß nicht. Also, und jetzt?
Also, der Status quo hat sich nicht geändert. Also, das ist weit.
Ja,
auf jeden Fall, Roddy und ich
werden dann hier die Meta-Ebene live und in Farbe bespielen, so der Plan.
Das heißt, für Technik-Abenteuer ist gesorgt.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also ja, gucken wir mal, wie das so wird. Okay,
haben wir noch irgendwas Kleines, was wir noch dazwischen schieben können? Nicht so richtig, ne?
Ich glaube, nein. Also wir hatten das Thema Kongress ja eigentlich schon durch.
Da gibt es einen Talk, den ich gesehen habe und zwar den über das Volkswagen Datenleck.
Und das war, wenn man so ein betroffenes Auto fährt, schon gar nicht so richtig lustig.
Interessanterweise kam gestern Abend die Ankündigung eines Updates,
aber in den Release Notes stand nichts zu dem Thema drin.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das länger geplant haben oder ob das ein ganz schnelles
Hoppla, da müssen wir jetzt kurz mal, dass die Autos vielleicht nicht mehr so
viele Daten senden. Keine Ahnung.
Also ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass die Firma in Wolfsburg so
schnell ist, dass sie von Kongress bis jetzt schon ein Update zusammengeklöppelt haben.
Vielleicht solltest du mal kurz erklären, worum es geht, wenn du das Thema schon ansprichst.
Ähm, also, ähm, VW ist erwischt worden, Daten relativ offen im Internet rumliegen
zu lassen und diese Daten waren, äh,
Daten, die sie über die Besitzer, ähm,
von Autos eingesammelt haben, die größtenteils zu der MEB, zu der mobilen Elektrobastelkasten,
wie es im Vortrag hieß, Elektrobaukasten gehören.
Also die ganze ID-Reihe, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 und Basis wahrscheinlich,
sowie die dazu kompatiblen Audi-Modelle.
Aber auch von Skoda und Seat, also der Enyaq, wie auch immer der heißt,
gefällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein und irgendwelche Skoda-Autos.
Allerdings auch Autos, die tatsächlich nicht zu dem MEB gehören.
Da haben sie wahrscheinlich auch entsprechend Elektronik verbaut.
Weiß ich nicht so genau, ist im Vortrag kurz angerissen.
Also auf jeden Fall sammeln diese Autos Standortdaten und zwar ein bisschen
viel und ein bisschen genau bei den Autos, die tatsächlich von Volkswagen selber ist.
Die Skoda und Enyaq Leute, die haben da ihre Hausaufgaben gemacht und haben
die Daten entsprechend eingekürzt. Wie war das? Auf 10 Kilometer, glaube ich?
Ja.
Während VW tatsächlich die Standortdaten auf der vollen 10 Zentimeter Auflösung...
Auch wenn sie was anderes versprochen haben.
Auch wenn sie was anderes in ihren AGBs versprochen haben...
Ja, das ist im Prinzip der Vortrag, also der ist sehenswert,
der ist sehr sehenswert.
Also die Daten muss man dazu sagen, also das sind die realen Daten,
sie lagen auch in nennenswerten Mengen vor, wir reden hier von hunderten von
Terabytes, also richtig, richtig, richtig viel und sehr ausführlich über sehr
viele Autos in allen möglichen Aspekten.
Der Vortrag zeigt dann auch, gekoppelt mit User-Konten und selbst wenn es das nicht wäre,
könntest du also aus diesen Bewegungsprofilen problemlos herausarbeiten und
das wurde ja dann in so einer beispielhaften Auswertung auch gezeigt, also so, was weiß ich,
Person, Auto steht über Nacht immer an dieser Adresse und ist dann tagsüber
von 9 to 5 an der Adresse und dann zwischendurch mal am Supermarkt und so weiter.
Und am Kindergarten.
Im Kindergarten. An der Schule. Genau, also der Vortrag heißt,
wir wissen, wo dein Auto steht.
Das ist natürlich sehr schön gewählt, ist sehr humoristisch,
hat nicht zu viele Details, aber zeigt auf jeden Fall wieder so einen typischen
Fall von, also man muss dazu sagen, das ist nicht aus dem Live-System,
sondern das sind quasi Backups, die da gefunden wurden.
Also es ist nicht ein Live-System gehackt worden, sondern es sind Daten im Netz
irgendwo abgelegt und schlecht gesichert gewesen.
Und dort konnten sie dann sozusagen geborgt werden, wurden dann Tests ausgewertet
und seien laut Vortragenden wieder gelöscht worden. Ganz ordentlich, genau.
Und ja, das war im Wesentlichen der Vortrag. Und das ist auch ehrlich gesagt
ein Problem, was ich sehe.
Man muss dazu sagen, die Daten, die sie gefunden haben, waren jetzt nur die Elektroautos.
Aber diese Datensammlung an sich ist nicht auf Elektroautos beschränkt,
sondern das ist generell Teil des Flottenmanagements und das findet genauso
mit Benzinern und Dieselfahrzeugen moderner Generation statt.
Wir sehen aber ja generell so eine zunehmende Elektronifizierung.
Wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe, habt aber die Elektrobaukastenautos tatsächlich
auch mehr Daten gesammelt als die anderen.
Ja, weil da kommen ja noch diese ganzen Ladezustände und so weiter mit rein.
Das fällt natürlich jetzt bei den anderen weg.
Und ich kann ja auch verstehen, dass man sowas auswerten will.
Das Problem ist nur, man sammelt diese Daten eben komplett de-anonymisiert.
Und nur um mal zuvor.
Vielleicht einen Vergleich zu machen, wie man es ja auch machen könnte.
Man könnte sie anonymisieren.
Apple liest ja auch diese Daten mit und bildet da Statistiken drüber und alles mögliche.
Aber sie haben ja auch dann ein entsprechendes Modell der, wie hieß denn das
nochmal, Differential Privacy, was quasi so ein System ist, was in der Gesamtheit
die Daten sicherstellt, dass die quasi die richtige Aussage haben.
Sie aber so kryptifiziert verschaffelt werden, dass du im Einzelnen niemals
beweisen könntest, dass es zu irgendetwas genau dazu gehört und das ist quasi ihr Ansatz.
Da kann man jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob das ausreichend ist oder ob sowas
auch nicht statthaft ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal so,
wenn du die Daten dann so im Netz findest, dann hast du zwar auch eine statistische
Auswertung, aber eben keine Zuordnung.
Bei den GPS-Daten, insbesondere die, die halt mit 10 cm Auflösung sind,
das geht ja mal gar nicht bei einem Bewegungsprofil, das wäre jetzt auch beim
iPhone genau dasselbe und von daher hohe Fahrlässigkeit zeigt einfach nur mal wieder,
wie gering ausgeprägt das gesamte Gefährdungsbewusstsein ist oder wie schlecht
die Systemadministration ausgelegt ist.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganze Kaskade von Vorwürfen, die man hier machen kann.
Insofern leider auch nicht überraschend. Nur so ein Moment wieder.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn man mit der Software von VW schon mal etwas intensiver interagiert hat,
dann wundert einen überhaupt gar nichts.
Also allein die Menge an Firmen, die beteiligt sind, um die App,
also die Mobile App auf die Räder zu kriegen und bei wie vielen einzelnen Teilen
dieser Firma VW du akzeptieren drücken musst, um diese App zu benutzen,
sagt dir, da weiß der Finger von der rechten Hand nicht, was der Daumen von der rechten Hand tut.
Also es ist ein komplettes Chaos.
Dieses Auto ist auch ständig in Zuständen, wo man nicht so genau weiß,
ist es jetzt an, ist es jetzt aus, ist es jetzt keine Ahnung,
warum schließt es sich in dem Fall wieder ab, aber im allgemeinen Fall nicht und solche Sachen,
warum geht jetzt die Heckklappe auf beim ersten Mal, wo ich den Knopf drücke,
warum geht die Heckklappe jetzt nur auf beim zweiten Mal, wo ich drücke und
so weiter. Also es ist alles extrem,
sketchy.
Es ist nichts Neues. Ich habe ja einen Turan noch, so mit gut Benzin und all dem und,
Das ist mein zweiter Touran. Bei dem ersten Touran war es chronisch,
dass man ab und zu mal so auf die Straße kommt, wo das Auto steht und feststellt,
dass alle Fensterscheiben runtergefahren sind.
Das hat das Auto von alleine getan.
Ja, das ist, wenn man den Schließen-Button länger drückt, dann macht er auch die Fenster auf.
Nein, dann macht er die zu.
Macht er sie zu?
Ja, ja, damit kann man alles auf einmal schließen aus der Ferne und dass das
Fahrzeug so beschließt, oh, frische Luft, ich brauche frische Luft und dann
einfach alle Fenster aufmacht, das war so ein Bug.
Naja, auf jeden Fall hatte ich gestern Abend dann ein Over-the-Air-Update.
Dachte mir so, oh spannend.
Habe dann das versucht zu installieren und das ist, was ich sehr witzig fand,
das kann man nur installieren, wenn man das Standlicht ausschaltet.
Das ist so, das ist sowas, wo du denkst, bitte was?
Warte mal, ich habe da ein paar Screenshots. Also das erste sieht so aus.
Da sagt er dann so, hey, du hast ein Update. Update verfügbar. Sehr gut.
Schon mal nicht verkehrt. Dann sagst du, okay, wie sieht es denn da aus mit dem Update?
Und wenn man jetzt in dem Screenshot guckt, da ist dieses kleine Informationsding
Standlicht ausschalten.
Rate mal, was nicht passiert, wenn man auf dieses I drückt.
Das Standlicht wird nicht ausgeschaltet?
Richtig. Okay.
Das hört sich ja auch wieder in Sicherheitsrisiko.
Und zwar ist links vom Lenkrad ist dieses Touchpanel mit den ganzen Licht und
sonstigen Bedienelementen und da gibt es in der Mitte einen Button,
der heißt Auto und wenn man da drauf drückt,
dann kann man Standlicht zwischen Auto,
On und Off schalten und wenn man dann Off schaltet,
dann kann man tatsächlich installieren.
Lustigerweise, das war so die Ankündigung dessen, was da in der Aktualisierung drin ist.
Mit diesem Update nehmen wir kleinere Aktualisierungen und Fehlerbehebungen,
ist wahrscheinlich eine kleinere Aktualisierung und Fehlerbehebung,
wenn sie tatsächlich das Datenleck gefixt haben, in Zusammenhang mit dem Antrieb vor.
Ah ja, dessen Funktion wird dadurch nicht beeinträchtigt, ihr und Antrieb,
na genau. Ähm, hm, hm, hm, hm.
Bei Fahrzeugen, die mit einer Diebstahlwarenanlage ausgestattet sind,
ist dies während der Installation nicht aktiv. Okay, meinetwegen.
Dieses Update führt nicht zu einer Erhöhung der angezeigten Version der ID-Software.
Darüber konnte ich mich auch tatsächlich… Es gibt nichts zu sehen, gehen Sie weiter.
Zu viele Details sind nur unruhig.
Das ist Version 7.5.3, revision 2.1.
Das war vorher 3.7 und es ist jetzt immer noch 3.7.
Du weißt nicht, hat er es tatsächlich installiert oder hat er nur so getan,
als würde er es tun, während du schläfst? Weißt du nicht.
Revision 2.1.
Also diese Firma ist, was Transparenz anbelangt, sind Umbauten vorgenommen worden,
die die Steuersignale des Fahrzeugs eingreifen.
Zum Beispiel Taxi führen sie keinen Over-the-Air-Update.
Also ich meine, immerhin haben sie nicht geschrieben, dass sie irgendwie einen
Frühjahrsputz gemacht haben, irgendwie alle Ketten geputzt, den Müll rausgebracht
haben und generell für eine bessere Experience gesorgt haben.
Magst du diese lustigen Hinweise nicht?
Überhaupt nicht. Ich finde, es gibt nur eine einzige App auf dem ganzen Planeten,
die es schafft, korrekte und gleichzeitig unterhaltsame und informationsreiche
Update-Texte zu liefern.
Das war diese Wetter-App.
Oder?
Slack.
Slack, oh Gott.
Schau dir mal Slack-Update-Knots an.
Die haben eine Weile lang auch versucht, sehr witzig zu sein.
Ich fand die immer witzig.
Okay.
Also ich fand die durchgehend witzig und informativ.
Aber dieses Update führt nicht zu einer Erhöhung der angezeigten Version der
ID-Software. Entschuldigung, wer hat denn das bitte beschlossen?
Tja, das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob wir hier eine Sendung rausbringen,
die nicht zur Erhöhung der angezeigten Sendungsnummer beiträgt.
Also das geht ja gar nicht.
Also die Handzock werden wir noch nicht im Griff, die Wolfsburger.
Ja, aber mal so ganz und gar nicht.
Die sind doch durch so einen Tal der Tränen gegangen, da denkt man so, Leute, na egal. Egal.
Gut. Let's go. Feedback zur letzten Sendung von mir.
Da habe ich nämlich über Cursor geschwärmt. Ihr erinnert euch?
Die Älteren erinnern sich, oder? Erinnert ihr euch?
Unbedingt.
Ja.
Ja, so alt sind wir durch dieses Schwärmen nicht geworden.
Ja, war es ja schon.
Kleiner Witz. Ich wollte nur ein paar Nachträge liefern.
Ich habe auch schon eine Menge Feedback bekommen von Leuten,
die es dann auch mal probiert haben und ein paar andere Experimente gemacht.
Ich habe seitdem einfach weitergemacht, also das hat mich total gepackt, das Fieber.
Zumal ich dann auch noch ein paar Sachen rausgefunden habe, die mir zum Zeitpunkt
der Sendung noch gar nicht klar waren und die dazu geführt haben,
dass ich meine Produktivität noch weiter steigern konnte.
Und ja, dazu gehört, dass Cursor, also vielleicht ein kleiner Recap für Leute,
die die letzte Sendung nicht gehört haben, also Cursor ist so ein Editor,
ein Klon vom Visual Studio Code von Microsoft,
populärer Open Source Editor und die haben den halt genommen und haben den so
ein bisschen angepasst und haben halt eine LLM oder beziehungsweise mehrere
LLMs dort eingebaut oder man kann sich auswählen, mit welcher LLM man arbeiten will.
Man zahlt da irgendwie 20 Dollar im Monat und da führt man dann irgendwie 500
Requests, sogenannte Fast Requests frei.
Man kann es auch mit Slow Requests machen. So ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall funktioniert das alles ganz super und da ist dann schon so ein
Next Level erreicht und ich habe das halt mit dem Cloud 3.5 Modell probiert
und das tue ich auch nach wie vor, weil es meiner Meinung nach immer noch das Beste ist.
Ich habe jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen mit Chat-GPT, aber Chat-GPT ist mir zu phaselig.
Also der ist mir nicht konkret genug. Der erzählt mir immer schön,
was man alles so machen müsste und dann so, ja mach mal.
Und dann muss man ihn irgendwie immer ein bisschen zum Jagen tragen,
das ist ein bisschen ungeil.
Wobei, man muss dazu sagen, du hast ja immer die 4O-Version,
sagst du nicht die O1, die besser sein soll für Coding?
Ja, das Ding ist, also, was ich eigentlich entdeckt habe, was mich bis dahin
immer ein bisschen verwirrt hat, ist, es gibt halt so einen...
Sidebar, den du aufmachen kannst und da gibt es dann diesen Chat-Dialog.
Aber der Chat-Dialog ist nicht das Einzige, was du diesem Sidebar machen kannst.
Es gibt auch einen anderen Dialog, der nennt sich Composer.
Und ich habe immer nicht so richtig gecheckt, was eigentlich der Unterschied ist.
Und um ehrlich zu sein, ich weiß auch immer noch nicht, warum es eigentlich
den Chat noch gibt, weil eigentlich will man Composer haben.
Und dann habe ich also auf Composer umgestellt und da wurde mir dann erst so richtig.
Flau im Magen, weil ich bisher sozusagen die ganze Zeit mit angezogene Handbremse
gefahren bin und das hat mich ja schon irgendwie ziemlich umgehauen.
Composer ist einfach der Ort, wo du wirklich mal richtig loslegen kannst und
dein ganzes Projekt ausformulieren kannst und dann legt das Tool einfach los.
Und man kann diesen Composer in einem normalen und in einem Agent-Modus betreiben.
Mir ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz klar, was dieser normale Modus überhaupt
sein soll, weil du willst definitiv in dem Agent-Modus arbeiten,
denn dieser Agent-Modus, der,
redet nicht nur mit dir und macht auch nicht nur Code-Vorschläge,
was man mal so machen könnte, sondern der kann die Dateien dann auch gleich
automatisch editieren, zeigt dir dann an, was er schön alles geändert hat.
Das heißt, du kriegst sozusagen, also musst gar nicht irgendwie Apply machen,
sondern der legt einfach los.
Der bearbeitet irgendwie alles und du kannst dir dann sofort anzeigen lassen,
was jetzt irgendwie alles geändert wurde und das macht er nicht nur in einer
Datei, sondern das macht er in allen, vielen Dateien.
Du kannst einfach sagen, leg mal los hier auf die Codebase und vor allem du
kannst halt auch loslegen auf einen komplett leeren Ordner und sagen erstmal,
was du willst und dann wird der ganze Bowlerplate ausgerollt und irgendwie das
ganze Gerüst gemacht und das macht er nicht einfach, indem er so oder nicht einfach nur,
indem er Files anlegt, das auch und Ordner,
sondern der kann dann auch gleich.
Terminal-Kommandos aufrufen und startet irgendwie dann dein Project-Building-Tool
oder GIT oder was auch immer gerade ist und es ist einfach,
Irre. Und in dem Dialog, da bin ich dann so richtig heiß geworden,
weil wenn du so ein bisschen dann mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommen hast,
wie man eben mit diesem Ding hantieren muss,
geht einfach die Produktivität nochmal komplett durch die Decke.
Also ich habe wirklich komplexeste Sachen damit gemacht, Riefreiz.
Alles mögliche, so was weiß ich.
Ich hatte dann so Code und dann hat mir dann das Naming nicht gepasst.
Ich habe dann irgendwie so einen Begriff benutzt, den ich irgendwie gerne für
was anderes frei hätte und der irgendwie besser passt. Und dann muss man dann
aber irgendwie ganz, in ganz vielen Orten irgendwas ändern und so.
Aber das war dann irgendwie kein Problem. Das gehst du einfach los und sagst
so, hier, ich verwende diesen Namen.
Ich würde aber gerne einen anderen Namen verwenden. Ich möchte jetzt gerne,
dass überall alles geändert wird, was irgendwie in irgendeiner Form diesen Namen
oder Ableitung von diesem Namen benutzt und dann marschiert er da irgendwie los.
Und dann trifft er vielleicht nicht alle Stellen auf einmal,
dann musst du noch zwei, dreimal nacharbeiten, aber im Wesentlichen kommst du schon irgendwie dahin.
Und wenn du in diesem ganzen Step-by-Step-Talk irgendwo das Gefühl hast,
jetzt hast du dich komplett verrannt, weil, hatte ich ja auch letztes Mal schon
gesagt, das kann dann schnell mal passieren,
dass man, was weiß ich, zu unscharf formuliert hat oder das Ding einfach auch
in so einen Overzealous-Mode kommt und einfach zu viel auf einmal ändert oder
anfängt irgendwelche anderen Kommentare noch mit wegzulöschen oder Code umzuschreiben,
den du gar nicht umschreiben wolltest.
Also das kann schon mal passieren, aber du kannst dann in diesem Composer jederzeit
also er macht quasi mit jedem Prompt so ein Checkpoint und du kannst einfach
sagen, ich möchte dahin wieder zurückkehren und dann macht er automatisch so
einen lokalen Rollback, unabhängig von Git,
nur in dem Editor in deiner Local Copy und dann bist du wieder genau da,
wo du vorher warst, also das ist wirklich irre und.
Seitdem ist auch noch ein neues Feature, ein drittes Sidebar Feature,
das habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht ausführlich getestet, dazugekommen, das ist der Bugfinder.
Und das ist dann wirklich so, du nennst dein Projekt, gehst in den Bugfinder und sagst, finde Bugs.
Und dann marschiert das Ding durch und durchsucht irgendwie alles.
Und zwar auch deine Git-Historie und kann dann irgendwie rausfinden,
wer für irgendwelche Änderungen verantwortlich war und es ist alles total crazy.
Ja, ich habe auch noch ein paar Stunden darin versenkt.
Ich habe aber in der Tat von vornherein immer in dem Composer View gearbeitet.
Also es tut mir leid, dass ich dir das nicht in der letzten Sendung irgendwie
schon gezeigt habe. Es war mir nicht klar, dass du da noch in dem Chat bist.
Ja, ja.
Gut, Dinge passieren. Ich habe ja erzählt, in der letzten Sendung,
dass ich hier mir diese Software-Idee geschnappt hatte, dass man aus Draw Things,
was halt KI-generierte Bilder generiert,
nochmal so ein Browser- und Analyse-Tool draufsetzt, um zu gucken,
welche Einstellungen, welche Loras haben eigentlich welche Effekte und was für Qualität kommt daraus.
Und das habe ich dann ja mal, es gab eine Software, die das hatte und dann habe
ich gesagt, okay, jetzt from scratch lasse ich das einfach mal komplett selber und neu schreiben.
Und hatte dann, das war so der Status der letzten Sendung,
irgendwo war ich da so bei 700 Codezeilen und dann wurde die Sache ein bisschen
anstrengend, weil das irgendwie so die,
Größe ist, ab wo dann die LLMs dann doch wieder auseinanderfallen und hatte
aber dann doch noch so ein paar relevante Feature Requests wie irgendwie,
ich will jetzt halt mehrere selektieren und Drag & Drop ins lokale Fallsystem
machen können und ähnliches.
Das war ja eine reine HTML-Java-Script-Anwendung zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Dann gab es da so 30 Minuten Diskussion von mir und dem System,
wo also dann, ich habe also auch immer Cloud 3.5 Sonnet genommen,
was meiner Meinung nach auch das Beste ist in der Tat derzeit für Coding.
Und das war dann so eine ganz klassische LLM-Drehschleife, die dann da gestartet wurde.
Ja, ist doch gar kein Problem, das machen wir jetzt hier mit dem generischen
HTML4, Dreck und Drop, guck mal hier, alles geil, so ausprobiert,
funktioniert nicht. Ja, okay, dann machen wir es jetzt mit Mac OS generisch
und so. Gar kein Problem, kriegt man hin.
So, funktioniert sie wieder nicht. Ah, ist auch kein Wunder,
wir müssen das generische HTML4. Nein, nein, hallo, da waren wir gerade eben.
Guck mal oben nach. Ja, das heißt also, wenn das eigentlich nicht funktionierte,
ist er immer sofort wieder auf die andere Technologie, aber beide liefen nicht.
Und irgendwann habe ich dann gesagt, so, jetzt guck nochmal ein bisschen,
nimm mal einen Schritt zurück und schau nochmal drauf, wo die eigentlich sind.
Und dann kam mir in der Tat an, naja, ich habe schon von Anfang an gesagt,
du brauchst eigentlich eine Elektronen-App für das, was du hier machst.
Das ist eigentlich sowieso nicht richtig.
Das hat er gesagt.
Wenn ich so, ach gut, ich fühle mich eh schon schmutzig hier,
dass ich hier alles gogen lasse, dann schreibe ich halt jetzt mal die erste
Elektronen-App meines Lebens oder das in mir schreiben.
Warum denn nicht? Und was soll ich sagen? Das ging dann plötzlich sehr schnell sehr gut.
Das heißt also, da war er dann wieder in einem sehr ausgetretenen Pfad,
den er gut in Anführungszeichen verstanden hatte und der gut im Internet durchdokumentiert ist.
So Elektronen-Apps gibt es dann nochmal irgendwie wie Sand am Meer.
Das heißt also, all das, wo man vorher technologisch dann wirklich immer sehr
von der Seite gegengetreten hat, damit es irgendwo ging, ging dann mit dem Elektronen-Framework
sehr einfach und sehr schnell.
Bis, und das ist jetzt der aktuelle Stand, man so bei 1500 Kurzzeilen ist.
Und dann geht er jetzt dann doch auch wieder in die Knie. Und auch solche Geschichten
wie, jetzt mach mal ein Refactoring und jetzt teile das doch mal auf in unterschiedliche
Module, damit wir irgendwie eine etwas saubere Architektur bekommen und das
wieder wartbarer wird, kriegt er nicht mehr hin.
In was ist das dann gekohlt? JavaScript?
Das ist immer noch JavaScript, ja. Das ist jetzt JavaScript mit einem Elektron
drüber, aber es ist rattenschnell.
Es hat ein paar lustige Ideen, glaube ich, verbaut.
Aber im Moment ist es in einem State, wo es gar nicht funktioniert.
Ansonsten könnte ich hier schon mal rein zeigen.
Aber zur nächsten Sendung, glaube ich, kriege ich das noch repariert und dann
würde ich das in der Tat auch mal releasen, weil das, glaube ich, eine Lücke füllt.
Was ist das, was du da brauchst?
Können wir uns das vielleicht nochmal angucken. Das ist ein Browser- und Analyse-Tool
für von KI-Image-Generatoren erzeugte Bilder.
Um etwas systematischer vergleichen zu können, so wenn ich welche Parameter
ändere bei meiner KI-Bildgenerierung, was für Auswirkungen hat das auf die Bildqualität
oder auf Motivauswahl oder was auch immer.
Ja, so und ich glaube, da werde ich die Stable Diffusion Querschnitt-Draw-Things-Community
ganz glücklich machen, wenn ich denen das dann mal vorwerfe.
Aber da muss ich noch ein paar Umdrehungen machen, aber Elektron funktioniert,
kann man einfach nur sagen, das hat also echt dann den Knoten zum...
Auseinandergegeben, Dreck und Drop und so weiter, alles ja kein Problem.
Aber es ist auch das Sonnet-Modell, ab einer gewissen Komplexität der Software
wird es dann echt anstrengend.
Und da stehst du als jemand, der nicht irgendwie selber auch programmiert,
stehst du dann da total im Kalten.
Ja, das war ja meine Aussage auch schon beim letzten Mal.
Also es ist gut zum Lernen, aber wenn man Serious Projects machen will,
dann muss man auch wissen, was man tut.
Also das ist schon hilfreich, wenn man in diesem Prozess sehr darauf achtet,
dass man sich aus dem Code, der erzeugt wird, lernt und diesen Code zu interpretieren lernt.
Also dass man die Sprachen, die man verwendet, so gut kann, dass man sie auch,
also komplexe Algorithmen, okay, vielleicht auch irgendwo eine Grenze,
aber zumindest, dass man erstmal die Syntax drauf hat.
Dass man auch ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, okay, was will der mir jetzt andrehen?
Und diese Verzweiflungsschleife, die Schleife der Verzweiflung,
die er da eintritt, die kommt vor allem dann,
wenn man zu sehr Vorgaben macht, die dann für das eigentliche Ziel gar nicht angemessen sind.
Also ich hatte auch so einen Fall, wo ich gesagt habe so, ja,
ich möchte jetzt gerne hier so bei meiner Web-Anwendung, bei Phoenix Live View,
da möchte ich gerne irgendwie das und das machen und das wäre doch sicherlich
eine gute Anwendung für so ein Live-Component.
So heißt so ein bestimmtes Element.
Und das hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht so richtig verstanden,
was das ist. Ich hatte nur eine Meinung davon, was es ist.
Und habe dann irgendwie versucht, in dieser Live-Component irgendein dynamisches
Zeug zu machen. Und dann ging es halt wieder los.
So, ja, alles kein Problem. Hier, guck mal.
Zack, zack, zack. Ich habe da mal was vorbereitet. Hier, guck mal,
weißes Häschen unter dem Hut.
Und ausprobiert ging nicht. So. Und dann wieder so, ja, hier geht nicht.
Ja, nee, kann ja auch gar nicht gehen. Wir müssen das irgendwie mit dem Ansatz
probieren. Und dann ging das immer so hin und her.
Und dann ist es halt so ein bisschen, wie dieses kleine Kind steht vor dir und
du hast es um etwas gebeten, was es nicht erfüllen kann, weil die Rahmenbedingungen nicht stimmen.
Und du hast eine schöne Formulierung gerade verwendet mit denk doch nochmal
richtig drüber nach. Den Tipp hatte ich irgendwie ganz zu Beginn bei LLMs schon
von Frank, von Frank Rieger. Vielen Dank für den Tipp bekommen.
Er meinte, er hätte bessere Ergebnisse, wenn er am Anfang schreibt, take a deep breath.
Weil irgendwie, wenn du ihn sozusagen, also wenn du sozusagen...
Worte und Formulierungen verwendest, die so typischerweise so bei Denkern zum Ausdruck kommen.
So dieses, wir entspannen uns, wir treten einen Schritt zurück.
Genau, wir treten einen Schritt zurück und schauen uns das Ganze nochmal von
oben an und betrachten die Metaebene.
Out of Spocks, Dengel.
Die Hände.
Genau, also solche Ansätze, damit assoziierst du einfach andere Gedankenstrukturen
und wirst nicht von vornherein so konkret und dann kommt er aus diesem Konkreten
nicht mehr raus, weil er sich da sozusagen in diesem Promptkontext komplett verbeißt.
Und dann sagst du halt auch erstmal, ich möchte gerne diese, das ist mein Ziel.
Mein Wirkungsziel.
Schlage mir vor, mit welcher Technologie, mit welchem Ansatz kann ich das machen.
Oder drei verschiedene Ansätze.
Mache ich auch gerne. Gib mir mehrere zur Auswahl.
Nimm nicht das, sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das und das und das
funktionieren könnte, aber ich bin mir unsicher.
Evaluiere diese drei und liefere mir Argumente für und dann machst du nochmal
so eine Zwischenstufe und dann wird es auf einmal ganz anders so.
Und das sind so Techniken, wo man eben gucken muss, wie kriege ich aus diesem
Assoziationsgewitter, wie bekomme ich da quasi so ein Preset hin.
Du musst erstmal quasi die Landschaft definieren, in der du dich bewegst.
Und wenn du da einfach so eine Blumenwiese reinzauberst, wo,
verschiedenste Insekten und verschiedenste Blümchen da sind und viele Optionen
sind, wo man irgendwie seinen Nektar herbekommen kann, dann hast du viel bessere,
Ergebnisse, als wenn du sagst so you are in a room, here is your computer,
here is your keyboard, go.
Weil dann kannst du einfach auch nur noch in diesen Dimensionen denken.
Ja, also ich glaube wohl schon noch,
Potenzial nicht gehoben ist, ist schon, dass die Promthistorie,
glaube ich, zu wenig gewichtet wird derzeit, also in dem Kontextfenster.
Also er ist dann eben doch sehr auf irgendwie so das jeweils letzte Kommando
plus sein aktueller State im Code konzentriert und schaut zu wenig darauf,
was eigentlich die letzten fünf Schritte davor schon beinhaltet haben.
Ansonsten dürfte er eigentlich nicht immer in diese AB-Schleifen reinfallen.
Es müsste ihm eigentlich selber einfallen, in Anführungszeichen, so da war ich schon mal.
Das führt uns hier nicht weiter. Ich kann jetzt nicht nochmal dasselbe vorschlagen,
was ich genauso vor einer Minute schon vorgeschlagen habe.
Das ist richtig und tatsächlich kann man sich aber am besten dadurch befreien,
indem man den Kontext komplett verlässt und nochmal neu ansetzt.
Ja, völlig d'accord. Das ist gar kein Widerspruch dazu. Also ich sage nur,
da könnten Sie einfach mit der vorhandenen Technologie wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen was tunen. Das zweite, wo er, finde ich, eine systemische Schwäche
hat, ist hinter sich aufräumen.
Das heißt, wenn irgendein Ansatz nicht funktioniert und man dann sagt,
okay, das war jetzt nicht so richtig Knall, räum das mal ab und stattdessen
probieren wir mal Variante Y,
lässt er häufig dann doch ziemlich viele Fragmente von seinem ersten Ansatz noch im Code drin.
Ja, also und das, da gleite ich auch jetzt so ein bisschen über zum Problembewusstsein
bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Das, was dahinter als Code rauskommt, ist nicht so richtig schön,
wenn man also komplex und längere Zeit damit arbeitet.
In Java-Skript.
Ja, okay, das mag sein, dass es von Sprache zu Sprache dann nochmal ein paar Unterschiede gibt,
aber das muss man auf jeden Fall einpreisen, dass man dann also in regelmäßigen
Abständen dann nochmal eine echte Codehygiene drüber gehen laufen lässt,
weil das macht er eben auch nicht von selber an der Stelle.
Ja, so bewusst ist es dann doch nicht.
Und wir haben ja ein bisschen Prügel bezogen in den Kommentaren von der letzten
Sendung dazu, wie wir sowas ja so abfeiern können und all die Gefahren, die dahinter stecken.
Und das ist, würde ich sagen, richtig, das haben wir in der letzten Sendung
wirklich wenig zugesagt zu den Gefahren.
Und ich sehe die im Wesentlichen eigentlich noch auf zwei Ebenen.
Das erste ist, dass ganz im engsten Sinne halt jetzt Software entsteht,
die einfach unsicher sein kann.
Ich kann Sicherheit da rein prompten.
Im Gegensatz zu der bestehenden Software, die ja total sicher ist.
Ja, aber wenn ich halt jetzt der LLM nicht sage, Achtung, lege insbesondere viel Augenmerk darauf,
dass das Ganze hier vernünftig gehärtet ist, dann wird sie das von sich aus
nur in sehr geringem Umfang tun. Also das muss man schon aktiv mitdenken.
Und die zweite Ebene ist natürlich das, was wir letzte Sendung und auch heute
natürlich eigentlich feiern, nämlich dass es ein Werkzeug ist,
um plötzlich viel mehr Software entstehen zu lassen und viel einfacher Software
entstehen zu lassen, die dann noch irgendwo publiziert wird.
Und auch irgendwo zum Einsatz kommt, wo dann aber im Zweifelsfall wirklich kein
Mensch mehr drüber geguckt hat.
Und für einen Zeitraum X, bis die LLMs dann in ein, zwei Jahren dann wirklich
in Anführungszeichen perfekt sind, was sowas angeht.
Und ich glaube, das werden wir noch erleben und zwar relativ bald.
Bis dahin haben wir wahrscheinlich wirklich nochmal so ein Tal zu durchschreiten,
wo wir eventuell mit großen Massen an durchaus problematischer Software uns
irgendwie auseinandersetzen.
Müssen. Weil also dieses Werkzeug ist so verführerisch und so niedrigschwellig
und löst einem auf so vielen Ebenen so viele Probleme.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es da draußen viele Buden gibt,
die dem widerstehen können einfach.
Oh, mit Sicherheit nicht, aber
das sind auch Buden, die bisher noch nie besonders gut abgeliefert haben.
Also klar, es gibt hier eine Menge Probleme. Es gibt ja auch sehr viel Klagen von Software,
Entwicklern, die jetzt mittlerweile, also sagen wir mal, hier so größere Projekte,
die so Bug-Bounties haben, werden beballert jetzt mit irgendwie AI-generierten Security-Bestand,
hinweisen.
Nahlegendes Geschäftsmodell.
Das ist zum Beispiel so ein Problem. Aber ich will noch mal kurz bei der Entwicklung
bleiben und warum ich das nicht ganz so negativ sehe.
Also klar, du wirst solche Budenwürste haben und so weiter und das sind aber
auch Leute, die heute schon, also vielleicht machen sie noch gar keine Software.
Das kann auch sein, aber schlechte Software gibt es genug.
Und Software, die keine Security einhält, ohne Ende.
Haben wir ja gerade ausführlich wieder gehabt den Fall und die Beispiele sind ja mannigfaltig.
Es ist hier auf jeden Fall möglich, auch sagen wir mal so seine eigenen Designprinzipien und,
Grundbedingungen einfach auch mit rein zu diskutieren oder rein zu diktieren.
Ob die dann immer eingehalten werden, ist eine andere Sache,
aber das geht auf jeden Fall. Du kannst auch sehr gut Security-Checks damit machen.
Du kannst halt einfach sagen, nimmst den Code, sagen wir mal,
ob da irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken sind. Mache ich hier irgendwelche klassischen Fehler?
Ist mein URL-Encoding, mein String-Handling und so weiter ist das safe und so weiter?
Kann man alles irgendwie darüber ganz gut abbilden und ist auf jeden Fall ein
interessantes Lerninstrument.
Also man muss, das ist halt wieder der Hammer. Du kannst damit was einschlagen,
aber du kriegst damit auch ordentlich Nägel in die Wand getrieben und wenn man
es halt so ein bisschen lernt.
Abgesehen von Security, erstmal ist es ja so, LLMs sind eigentlich im Wesentlichen so eine Art.
Zwölferpackung Best Practice. Weil sie lernen ja quasi so aus dem entstehenden
Code und du kannst halt sehr gut die typische Weise, wie man ein Problem angeht, erstmal erfahren.
Und das ist ja schon mal etwas, was viele Leute ausschließt.
Was ich auch noch gemerkt habe, dadurch, dass du auch so schnell vorankommst,
ist es auf einmal ökonomisch verschiedene Varianten durchzutesten.
Ja, du sagst jetzt hier irgendwie Code ist irgendwie eingecheckt,
jetzt mache ich mal einen Branch auf, jetzt gucken wir mal läuft das besser,
wenn ich das jetzt was weiß ich, auf 20.000 Prozesse verteile,
diesen Ansatz wähle, wenn ich hier mein Interface ändere, was kommt dabei raus?
Und dann kann ich eine zweite Variante vergleichen und obwohl das unheimlich
viel Code ist, der dann da vielleicht erzeugt wird oder umgeschrieben wird,
kann ich danach sehen so, ah okay, das geht in die Richtung,
das geht In die Richtung,
ich habe jetzt auch mehrere Fälle gehabt, wo ich in so Dead-Ends reingerannt
bin, aus Gründen, die ich vorher nicht habe sehen können.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel, wollte ich hin, oder was halt wollte ich,
ich war schon nahezu fertig,
ich wollte für meinen HDMI-Matrix-Switch, habe ich das letzte Mal schon erzählt,
ich glaube nicht, wollte ich eine Kontrollsoftware machen, um das mit Stream Deck zu machen.
Du hast das, glaube ich, angeteasert.
Habe ich das schon erzählt, dass es das vorhatte? Dass es das vorhattest. Genau.
Dann habe ich das irgendwie auch so weit getrieben, nur um dann am Ende,
als das eigentlich schon alles lief, festzustellen, dass Stream Deck die Eigenschaft
hat, seine Plugins einfach mit einem SIG-Therm-Signal abzuschießen nach 30 Sekunden Inaktivität.
Also gefühlter Inaktivität.
Weil, ja, keine Ahnung warum, weil sie die Erfahrung gemacht haben,
dass die Plugins Speicher belegen oder sich sonst irgendwie die Karten legen.
Und sie haben einfach mal beschlossen, die killen wir einfach mal nach 30 Sekunden,
wenn dann kein Button gedrückt wurde, weil die rufen wir dann auf,
wenn wir sie wieder brauchen.
Ist natürlich super, wenn dein Programm ein permanentes Monitoring betreibt
und die ganze Zeit laufen muss.
Und dann habe ich noch eine kleine Schwäche von Elixir und Erlang entdeckt,
dass ich nämlich so ein SIG-Therm-Signal nicht ignorieren kann mit der VM.
Was nochmal ein Problem für sich ist.
Kann man beheben, indem man dann nochmal so einen Rapper-Prozess irgendwie in
was anderem macht, aber ich wollte ja irgendwie pure bleiben.
Was ich sagen will eigentlich ist, da war sehr viel Weg erforderlich, um überhaupt erstmal.
Diesen Case durchzutesten, um festzustellen, geht das überhaupt,
kann ich das überhaupt so machen und ganz am Ende kam dann irgendwie so die
böse Nachricht mit so äh äh,
weil irgendeine grundlegende Bedingung vorherrscht, kannst du diesen ganzen
Pfad vergessen oder hätte ich jetzt irgendwie wochenlang dran rum,
entwickelt, um am Ende festzustellen, dass keiner den Schlüssel für die Tür hat.
Naja, also wie man es dreht und wendet, ihr müsst das ja auch nicht machen.
Aber da ist eine ganze Menge Value drin. Und den Doomsayern,
die jetzt sagen, wir dürfen das nicht anfassen, weil Weltuntergang und Energieverbrauch und so weiter.
Ja, es gibt ja kein richtiges Leben im Falschen.
Und das Problem ist, also die Technologie ist da.
Man muss sich damit beschäftigen. Das geht auch nicht mehr weg.
Das ist das Ding. Aber das ist auch so eine Club-Hacker-Sache,
wo man halt sagt, okay, die Technologie ist da, jetzt müssen wir gucken,
wie wir damit klarkommen.
Also was ich halt sehe, ist, dass glaube ich,
also es ist jetzt schon für Manager von Softwareentwicklern schwer einzuschätzen,
was ist wie viel Aufwand und wie gut ist das Ergebnis, was da rausgekommen ist.
Weil du brauchst, um tatsächlich die Qualität eines Software-Systems zu erkennen,
brauchst du jemanden, der wirklich viel Erfahrung hat.
Und wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal, das ist jetzt böse gesprochen,
fünf Affen mit einer Software-AI anstellst und die hacken daran rum, bis es funktioniert.
Dann sieht das halt erstmal so aus, als hättest du, also als Manager,
dass du viel Geld gespart hättest, hast aber letzten Endes kein Feedback darüber,
wie geil oder scheiße ist denn die Lösung, die gebaut wurde.
Und sollte man das so tatsächlich machen?
Und das ist, glaube ich, was, wo die Industrie als Ganzes sehr stark drauf gucken
muss, machen wir uns da nicht auch irgendwie ein Problem,
indem wir alle Hurra schreien.
Wir benutzen jetzt alle AI und in ein paar Jahren merken wir,
wir haben Systeme gebaut, die kein Mensch mehr versteht, nur noch die AI.
Und das ist so das Bedenken, was ich da dran habe.
Und dann ist irgendwann so ein Wettrüsten angesagt, naja, das lösen wir halt
damit, dass wir noch mehr AI draufschmeißen.
Darüber stapeln.
Genau, genau. Und irgendwann hast du dann halt so ein Myzel von Software,
was einfach irgendwie, ja, nur noch so wuchert, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht geht das auch einfach ganz natürlich dahin und wir können nichts
tun, aber die Gefahr sehe ich halt.
Ja, also ich meine, am Ende ist es wie mit allen Hypes.
Troph of Dissolutionment kommt schon noch.
Genau, also wir sind jetzt erstmal so in der Phase der überzogenen Erwartungen
und es wird jetzt auf alles angewendet werden und alle probieren das irgendwie
aus und das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Und dann werden wir feststellen, dass wir da an diverse Grenzen stoßen und natürlich
haben wir ein Problem mit Energieverbrauch. Aber das ist natürlich etwas,
was sich, also das ist ein Problem, das muss sich irgendwie lösen.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ob wir das lösen werden und wie wir das lösen werden,
aber dieser nochmal gestiegene Energiebedarf ist natürlich enorm.
Aber man könnte zum Beispiel Bitcoin abschalten, dann hätten wir auf jeden Fall schon genug frei.
Ja, also das würde definitiv schon mal die ein oder andere Staatendimension
von Stromverbrauch eliminieren, aber das will ja auch keiner machen.
Also ich denke, das mit dem Stromverbrauch ist, ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen
eine Schattendiskussion, weil wo kommt der Strom her?
Entweder aus erneuerbaren Energien oder ich verbrenne irgendeine Scheiße.
Und die Sachen, die wir verbrennen, da haben wir sowieso ein grundsätzliches Problem mit.
Also ob wir es jetzt so verbrennen oder anders, das müssen wir in den Griff kriegen.
Und erneuerbare sind, wenn wir weiterhin wie die bekloppten Solar zubauen und
die Netze so sind, dass sie den Strom verteilen und ich vielleicht auch,
ein System baue, wo ich sage, ich sende meine Requests immer an das Data Center,
wo gerade die Sonne scheint, dann sehe ich den Stromverbrauch nicht als prinzipiell das große Problem.
Also wenn es ein großes Problem wäre, dann würde man den Scheiß ja nicht für
umsonst kriegen oder für wenig Geld.
Also am Ende des Tages, ja klar, wird da wahrscheinlich auch jede Menge Venture
Capital verbrannt erstmal,
damit du einen Markt bekommst, aber irgendwann ist der Punkt erreicht,
wo du für den Service mindestens so viel bezahlst, wie er tatsächlich kostet, auch an Energiekosten.
Und damit regelt sich das meiner Meinung nach auch halbwegs selber.
Wobei man sagen muss, jetzt hier im Bereich Coding, alle Modelle,
die wirklich was können, kosten was.
Ich kenne kein kostenloses LLM-Modell, was im Coding irgendwie ansatzweise brauchbar
wirklich Ergebnisse ist. Das mag sich ändern.
Ich möchte nicht ausschließen, dass wir hier in drei Jahren auch auf einem lokalen
Modell irgendwie coden können.
Ich halte das für möglich, wenn man sich anguckt, wie in anderen Bereichen dadurch optimiert wird.
Aber derzeit ist es so, darum bin ich auch immer vorsichtig,
wenn die Leute sagen, ja, ich habe XY ausprobiert, also auch irgendwie bei ChatGPT,
ja, hast du auch die richtigen Modelle ausprobiert oder halt nur das,
was da so umsonst drinsteht und dass da die Antworten peinlich sind,
das wissen wir halt alle, das ist jetzt no shocking news, also das sagt mir
jetzt nichts über den Status von LLM aus.
Nee, darum ging es mir nicht, es ging mir einfach darum, dass ich sage,
der Stromverbrauch ist etwas, der geht ja nicht weg, also der wird sicherlich
optimiert werden, Aber auf der anderen Seite ist, wenn Nvidia die nächste AI-Generation
lostritt, die zehnmal schneller ist bei gleichem Stromverbrauch,
dann wird halt das zehnmal größere Modell gerechnet und wir brauchen immer noch den gleichen Strom.
Also da wird sich nicht viel dran ändern.
Wobei das Rechnen der Modelle, das Training ist das Problem.
Nein, nein, schon das Expressieren der Modelle oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Nein, ich sage nur, wenn die Hardware mehr hergibt, dann werden wir auch mehr davon benutzen.
Dann werden die Modelle entsprechend größer und dann sind wir, das ist eine Nullsumme.
Also du wirst immer so viel Strom verbrauchen, wie der Kunde bereit ist zu bezahlen.
Insofern, wir müssen uns einfach wirklich darüber unterhalten,
was für einen Strom verbrauchen wir denn? Wo kommt der denn her?
Also, dass ein Teil davon, wie groß er auch immer sei, aus fossilen Energie
kommt, das darf halt nicht sein.
Weil da haben wir ein prinzipielles Problem. Also in Kalifornien brennen gerade
die Willen der Gutverdienenden ab. Vielleicht ändert sich jetzt mal was.
Nein, glaube ich natürlich auch nicht. Nur weil die Drittwelle abgebrannt ist, bleiben ja noch zwei.
Nee, also wie gesagt.
Ja, na klar.
Das ist wie bei Bitcoin. Ich meine, ja natürlich wäre es sinnvoll, Bitcoin abzuschalten.
Aber solange Leute denken, sie könnten damit Geld machen und vielleicht auch
welches machen, läuft es halt weiter.
Genau, jetzt ist der Scam und jetzt haben wir Trump, also Bitcoin werden wir
jetzt erstmal eine Weile nicht los, weil jetzt die ganzen Hodler jetzt irgendwie
an der Macht sind. Aber ich wollte nicht mit Politik anfangen.
Ein weiteres Argument, was auch noch so kritisch mit reinkam, war ja auch so, oh,
ihr benutzt ja jetzt auch noch AI-generierte Bilder für euren
Podcast Und damit promotet ihr ja den Diebstahl von geistesschaffenden Menschen
und ihr reißt sozusagen das Einkommensgebäude von Künstlern.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht an dir ein Argument zu rechtfertigen,
das du nicht gebracht hast, aber ich verstehe es nicht so ganz.
Ehrlich gesagt. Versuche nur zusammenzufassen, was mir so gegeneinander gesagt wurde.
Also das ist halt eine Frage, da kann man sehr stark über Urheberrecht und Verwertungsrechte streiten.
Also ein Modell, was an den Artworks von Leuten trainiert wurde und sie dafür
nicht entsprechend beteiligt?
Gibt es dafür ein Lizensierungsmodell? Gibt es dafür ein Entlohnungsmodell?
Also das ist ja irgendwie, also das Thema geht ja nicht weg.
Man muss sich eher darüber unterhalten, wie kriegt man das Problem in den Griff,
wenn ich heute ein Bild male.
Keine Angst, ich werde es nicht tun. und eine AI lernt das dann.
Dann weiß ich nicht. Und ich mache den großen neuen Stil,
den irgendwie jede Galerie haben will und plötzlich kann man den Stil einfach kopieren,
weil das Bild ist da draußen oder die Bilder sind da draußen mit dem Stil und
jeder kann mit der AI die gleichen Bilder machen und dann ist das Alleinstellungsmerkmal
wieder weg. Also klar, die,
Die Diskussion ist wichtig und das Problem ist da, nur zu sagen,
wir würden jetzt das Problem befeuern, finde ich jetzt ein bisschen schwierig,
weil Bildgenerierung per AI ist,
so weit ich das mitbekommen habe,
relativ stark in der Mitte der Gesellschaft, auch so eine schöne Floskel, angekommen.
Auch das ist so ein Zug, der ist aus der Halle, den kriegen wir nicht wieder zurück.
Also wo ich ja noch mitgehe, ist der Vorwurf, das wäre ja alles so etwas mit mediocre Ästhetik.
Und da muss ich auch zugeben, da sind dann sozusagen meine Prompting-Skills
im Image-Generation-Bereich, die sind jetzt nicht Top-Level.
Also mir gelingt es ab und zu mal wirklich was Schneidiges hinzubekommen,
auch in den letzten Folgen waren öfter mal ein paar Treffer dabei,
aber es gibt auch immer so Momente,
wo ich irgendwie komplett verzichte, mir das Endergebnis anschaue und mir denke
so, ja das ist sowieso, das ist jetzt so der typische AI-Slob,
der jetzt irgendwie gerade rausgelaufen ist.
Da bin ich jetzt gar nicht so richtig stolz drauf und da gehe ich auch irgendwie
mit und ich würde es auch gerne besser machen, aber kriege es dann halt auch
einfach nicht hin und auch nicht übers Herz dann gar nichts zu liefern.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite, ich finde es ja okay, man sieht, dass es AI generiert ist.
Also jeder, der weiß, wie das aussieht, sieht, dass es AI generiert ist.
Und am Ende des Tages, ich meine, du wirst ja wahrscheinlich nicht mit einem
Prompt, sondern mit 20 oder 30 Prompt so lange rumprobieren,
bis halbwegs was rauskommt und dann auch nicht das erste Bild nehmen,
sondern dann eine runde Scrollen, bis du was gefunden hast, was wirklich gut aussieht.
Das ist ja auch ein kreativer Prozess am Ende des Tages.
Oh ja, das auf jeden Fall. Das ist halt nur eine andere Art und Weise.
Was man natürlich auch sagen kann, ist, dass sich bei der Bildgenerierung halt
die Kritik vor allen Dingen daran aufhängt, wenn Stile kopiert werden.
Und das machen wir jetzt mit den Titelbildern ja explizit gar nicht.
Also da geht es ja quasi um das inhaltliche thematische Prompten,
also was ist zu sehen, aber nicht wie ist es zu sehen. Das heißt,
da gibt es ja eigentlich, nehme ich das so wahr, niemals Stilkommandos ein.
Und das Ganze jetzt im Stile von Rembrandt oder von Van Gogh oder irgendein
hipper Artist um die Ecke.
Sondern das ist ja eine totale Middle-of-the-Road-KI-Ästhetik vom Stil her.
Hätte ich jetzt auch kein Problem damit, Van Gogh zu zitieren.
Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie ausreichend abgeschüttet.
Aber auch das ist doch etwas, wenn ich jetzt, ich meine, wir sind hier im Prenzlauer
Berg, wahrscheinlich gibt es schräg gegenüber irgendwo einen Künstler,
den könnte man engagieren.
Mach uns ein Titelbild für die Episode.
Viel zu teuer Prenzlauer Berg für Prenzlauer mittlerweile.
Aber du findest jemand und der macht ja seine Bilder auch, der geht ja auch
in Galerien, guckt sich Dinge an, kennt die Standardwerke und so weiter und
verarbeitet alle diese Einflüsse in das Bild, was er getan hat.
Am Ende ist das auch nur ein neuronales Netz, was trainiert wurde.
Also insofern ist dieser Unterschied zwischen ein Mensch hat den Stil gelernt
und eine Maschine hat den Stil gelernt,
keine Ahnung, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das ist das Gleiche,
aber irgendwo verschwimmen die Grenzen dann doch irgendwann.
Also insofern, ich weiß nicht, also eine simple Kopie wird man immer als simple
Kopie erkennen, wenn ein Mensch sie tut, aber auch wenn eine Maschine sie tut.
Und bisher waren die Episodenbilder, fand ich jetzt nicht so,
dass man sagen würde, du hast jetzt Künstler XY kopiert.
Gut, ich kenne mich auch nicht aus.
Aber weißt du, was ich meine?
Das ist halt so der übliche Wahnsinn, der aus so Bildgenerierungen rauskommt,
aber dafür macht man es ja.
Außerdem ist das ja alles total ironisch.
Wenn wir diesen Clip von diesen zwei Mädels nochmal sehen.
Genau, es ist Meta-Mann-Chicket.
Genau, auf Ernst jetzt. Okay, dann machen wir doch jetzt mal richtig auf Ernst
und machen hier nochmal Gadget Thursday.
Oh ja. Wir haben ja eine Spende erhalten von unserem lieben Freund Dominik, der Monkey Dom.
Oh.
Er hatte nämlich noch ein Apparat im Regal, von dem er meinte,
brauche er nicht mehr, also zumindest vorerst nicht.
Ist aber nur eine Dauerleihgabe, ist nicht eine wirkliche Spende.
Ja, ja, ist eine Dauerleihgabenspende-Gedöns. Und wovon reden wir?
Es kann sich nur um ein Gerät handeln, der gehört ja zu den Leuten,
die gleich zugegriffen haben, als die Apple Vision Pro zu haben war.
Sodass das Ding jetzt hier nochmal bei uns umherzog.
Und zuerst, also ich habe es kurz nochmal getestet für das eine oder andere,
aber du hast es jetzt vor allem erstmal in der Mangel, Ralf und Roddy dann auch.
Und jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was kommt.
Ja, ich war ja gespannt wie ein Flitzebogen, kann man sich vorstellen,
weil ich habe ja schon das Thema 3D hier immer hochgehalten,
als ich noch gar nicht Teil des Teams war.
VR. Ja, genau.
Und mit meiner Quest 3 war ich ja doch auch immer hinlänglich glücklich eigentlich.
Und jetzt endlich habe ich also dann mal etliche Stunden jetzt mit der Vision
Pro verbracht und ich habe, glaube ich, viele Erkenntnisse und viele,
viele starke Meinungen dazu und die möchte ich natürlich jetzt nicht hinterm Berg halten.
Das Erste ist, dass ich...
Echt ein bisschen schockiert bin und zwar jetzt nicht über das,
was die Vision Pro macht so, die macht halt das, was jetzt technisch gerade
irgendwie state of the art ist.
Ich werde auch viel Lobendes gleich noch sagen, aber ich bin etwas schockiert
darüber, wie das in den Tech-Medien eigentlich besprochen wurde oder verkauft wurde.
Weil ich habe das glaube ich schon einigermaßen eng alles mitgelesen und mitgeschnitten,
als die rausgekommen ist, was dort wo wie darüber geschrieben worden ist.
Und wenn man das jetzt selber ausprobiert, dann habe ich da echt Störgefühle.
Also diese Grundaussage von,
wenn du die aufhast, merkst du gar nicht, dass du die aufhast,
weil alles so hochauflösend ist und so gut aussieht und das Pass-Through der
echten Welt so perfekt ist,
dass du denkst, du hättest gar keine Brille auf.
Also wer das denkt, sollte dringend zum Augenarzt gehen. Eindeutig.
Das ist nicht nur gelogen, sondern das ist also einfach, das ist Hannebüchener Unfug.
Und aus mehreren Gründen ist das Unfug.
Das erste, das mag aber damit zusammenhängen, dass die jetzt nicht perfekt auf
mich eingepasst ist, ist dieses einfach mal schwer und unbequem.
Das heißt also, es ist mir jetzt egal, mit welchem der...
Wir haben jetzt also hier zwei verschiedene Straps.
900 Gramm, sagte der Mann im Apple Store.
Also es ist schwerer halt als die Quest, obwohl der Akku nicht drin ist,
im Gegensatz zur Quest 3.
Egal mit welchem der beiden Haltebänder halt hier, es hat also wirklich viel
Druck bei mir vorne aufs Gesicht produziert, sodass ich also vom Tragegefühl
her so nach 30 Minuten eigentlich keine Lust hatte mehr, die weiter zu tragen.
Das mag aber jetzt ein Physiognomie-Problem sein, komischer Kopf, viel zu große Nase,
nicht die richtige Einpassform im Store ausprobiert, sondern jetzt einfach so
das übergeholfen bekommen, was wir halt jetzt hier ausgeliehen bekommen haben.
Von daher würde ich den Punkt jetzt gar nicht zu stark machen.
Aber alleine, dass du da einfach mal so einen Klotz davor hast.
Da muss ich aber einhaken, weil ich war vorhin noch mal im Apple Store.
Ich hatte mir so eine Demo-Halbe-Stunde da geklickt und da haben sie mir mit
Einmessen und die richtigen Einsätze und die Linsen,
die ich brauche und so weiter und alles und die saß eigentlich so gut, wie sie sitzen kann,
und ich war trotzdem froh, als
die halbe Stunde rum war und ich das Ding absetzen konnte. Also ist so.
Also Tragekomfort, würde ich schon mal sagen, ist die Quest 3,
da habe ich keine Probleme, zwei bis drei Stunden die aufzuhaben.
Bei der Vision Pro habe ich dieses Problem.
Die ist auch leichter, oder?
Die ist schon deutlich leichter, die Quest 3. So, das viel größere Problem aber ist für mich der,
super eingeschränkte Sichtfeld. Und das ist etwas, das kapiere ich nicht,
dass das so weggeschrieben wird da draußen.
Also, dass gesagt wurde, das sei
alles so irgendwie weit und man hätte da überhaupt keinen Rand und sowas.
Lasst euch da keinen Quatsch erzählen. Ihr zieht euch eine Taucherbrille auf.
Ja, man guckt da in so ein Rohr rein.
Du guckst in ein Rohr rein. Es ist eben nicht, dass deine Augen die Ränder nicht
erfassen können, sondern du hast, und zwar ist es nicht eine Taucherbrille,
die aus so zwei Einzelkapseln besteht, sondern so eine, die man so zum Schnorcheln irgendwie anhat.
Mit Abstand zum Auge und dann hast du halt vor dir ein Feld und dann guckst du durch.
Es mag sein, dass das für Brillenträgerinnen weniger dramatisch ist,
weil die ohnehin irgendwie eine stärkere Fokussierung nach vorne haben.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Du hast zwar als Brillenträger hast du zwar den Bereich, der scharf ist,
den hast du ja also der ist im Prinzip etwas eingeengt, aber die Brille ist ja nicht wie die,
Vision Pro, so eine Tülle, wo der, der hat da ewig, der hat da ewig im Apple
Store rum gemacht, ja und kommt jetzt da noch Licht rein und kommt jetzt da
noch Licht rein und kommt jetzt da noch Licht rein als wäre das das Wichtigste,
dass ich da in einer virtuellen Dunkelkammer stehe und,
aber als Brillenträger hast du ja eine periphere,
Vision ganz normal, 180 oder 170 Grad oder so, nur halt unschärfer als eh schon.
Aber ich meine, als Normalsichtiger hast du da auch Unschärfe.
Ja, also vielleicht versuchen wir mal ein bisschen technisch zu beschreiben,
was diesen Tunneleffekt eigentlich bewirkt.
So, wenn man sich also jetzt diese Vision Pro anguckt, dann besteht die halt
aus drei Teilen, die man auch alle auseinander nehmen kann.
Das erste Teil ist das eigentliche Modul, wo das Display drin ist und wo Linsen verbaut sind. Das was?
Der Gerät.
Der Gerät. So, dann haben wir dazwischen einen Adapter, dank des Adapters,
das sogenannte Light Seal.
Ja, die Muffe.
Die Gesichtsmuffe. Die Gesichtsmuffe. Das ist also ein Plastikgerät mit irgendwie
ein bisschen Stoff noch drumherum.
Das im Wesentlichen dafür sorgt, dass zum einen die Augen einen Abstand bekommen
zu den Linsen und zum anderen rundum halt jegliche Art von Licht wegblendet.
Also wirklich halt wie in einer Taucherbrille.
So, der Vergleich finde ich ist schon relativ gut.
Und dann obendrauf hat man...
Gut, der Rand der Taucherbrille ist ja nicht dafür da, dass er Licht wegblendet,
sondern das ist einfach ein Konstruktionsmerkmal.
Ja, aber um halt abzudichten. Und dieses Abdichten ist halt hier optisch offensichtlich
einen Wert, den Apple da sehr hoch hält.
Ich komme gleich dazu, warum das anders viel besser ist.
So, und das dritte Element, was man noch hat, ist, alles drei hängt magnetisch aneinander.
Das dritte Modell ist dann nochmal eine Polsterung, damit das Ganze also etwas
weicher auf dem Gesicht aufliegt.
Und diese Polsterung gibt es auch nochmal in verschiedenen Dicken,
um also noch mehr Abstand quasi Auge zu Linse auch herstellen zu können oder
mehr Polsterung herstellen zu können.
So, und diese drei Komponenten kann man also alle zusammen klicken.
So und das muss man zusammen klicken und es gibt insgesamt, ich glaube,
22 verschiedene Bauformen wirklich von diesem Mittelteil, das heißt von dem Leitziel.
Je nachdem also, wie das Gesicht geformt ist, wird das also in unterschiedlichem
Abstand und unterschiedliche Breite angeboten und das ist dieser Einpassungsprozess,
den du jetzt auch im Apple Store entsprechend hattest.
Das Ergebnis ist aber egal, wo man da landet bei welchen, so dass halt deine
Augen grundsätzlich, wie viel wird das hier sein, zwei Zentimeter von den Linsen
entfernt sind und das führt dann eben zwangsläufig zu diesem Tunneleffekt.
So und als jetzt Roddy aber bei mir war.
Und ich ihm die Division Pro übergeben hatte. Roddy hat ja jetzt bekanntlich eine Brille.
Ja, die passt auch nicht ins Leitziel rein.
Und die passt nicht, genau, das wussten wir auch vorher, dass sie also,
es gibt keinen Weg, wie du eine Brille in dieses Leitziel irgendwie reinquetschen
kannst, sondern man muss also dann die Brille abnehmen und halt diese Korrekturlinsen machen.
Genau, das habe ich ja am Anfang dann auch erst mal ohne Brille versucht.
Da war das mit, das ist so scharf, als hätte man nichts auf.
Schon irgendwie genau so, weil andere Seite.
Ich gucke jetzt gerade hier, wie bauen sich das denn irgendwie.
War das so? Keine Ahnung. Deswegen habe ich dann angefangen,
da rumzuexperimentieren.
Ich mache gerade hier einen, achso, den orangenen Schnupse hier muss ich ziehen.
Genau, die Lippe.
Ich baue jetzt gerade hier nochmal einen der Gurte dran, damit man das Ganze
jetzt ein bisschen vor sich sieht.
So und was wir dann ausprobiert haben, mehr oder weniger aus purer Verzweiflung, ist,
dass wir eben einfach diesen Leitziel ganz rausgenommen haben und Roddy seine
Brille anbehielt und das drüber gezogen hat über die Brille und mit der Hand
hast du dann die ganze Konstruktion festgehalten,
um überhaupt erstmalig sowas wie ein scharfes Bild zu kriegen dadurch.
So und parallel habe ich dann an meinem Rechner angefangen rum zu googeln,
okay, wie ist denn hier das mit Brille und Leitziel und Vision Pro ohne Leitziel
zu betreiben und da bin ich drauf getroffen,
dass es eine kleine, aber feine Community gibt, die propagiert,
dieses Leitziel sollte man generell weglassen.
Das heißt also Brille hin oder her, völlig egal.
Nutzt einfach die Vision Pro so, dass ihr das Leitziel weglässt und du,
das ist jetzt etwas schwierig über dem Headset hier, du die direkt drauf setzt.
Das habe ich doch mal ausprobiert. Was soll ich sagen? Ich habe das Licht gesehen.
Ja, vor allem, dass es von der Seite reinfällt.
Aber ohne Leitziel.
Aber eben nicht nur von der Seite.
Ich habe halt wirklich einen AB-Test gemacht mit einer Quest 3 und es ist so,
würde ich sagen, dass der Field of View mit diesem Leitziel,
würde ich sagen, ein Viertel enger ist als das, was die Quest 3 macht.
Wenn du das Leitziel weglässt und die Brille direkt vor den Augen hast,
ist der Field of View plötzlich, würde ich sagen, mindestens 30 Prozent breiter
als das, was die Quest 3 hat. Es ist irre groß, der Field of View.
Plus, du hast oben, unten, unten halt auch noch die echte Welt daneben.
Das heißt, du hast überhaupt nicht mehr den Eindruck, du hast eine Tauchermaske
auf, sondern du hast den Eindruck, du hast eine Brille mit etwas dickeren Rändern
auf. Aber auch nur etwas dicker.
Du denkst wirklich, du hast plötzlich eine normale Brille.
Der Unterschied ist also phänomenal und total frappierend. Und es ist trotzdem
alles scharf und es funktioniert.
Und du kannst trotzdem das Eye-Tracking machen und alles.
Und es gibt halt im Internet relativ viele auch YouTube-Videos,
die also genau das propagieren.
Und mir ist völlig unklar, warum Apple diesen Weg nicht einschreitet.
Weil es ist jetzt erstmal so, so richtig problemlos ist es nicht,
weil es sitzen halt erstmal sehr schwer auf der Nase, weil halt so die ganze,
Dämpfung nicht mehr funktioniert, die ganze Lastenverteilung nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dafür gibt es dann aber auch Alternativen und da hatte nämlich dann Dom in der
Tat auch schon sogar ja eins mit beigepackt und das ist nämlich dieses ominöse
Teil, was wir hier hatten.
Achso, das ist da nicht drin.
Aber Genau, das ist ein nochmal zusätzlicher. Versteht man es nicht.
Wir haben fast eine Stunde rumgetüftelt,
wie man das jetzt eigentlich dran kriegt und wofür das gut ist.
Ich kann aber ein paar Links dazu in die Shownotes reinwerfen.
Das ist ein zusätzlicher Bügel nochmal, der über den Kopf drüber gezogen wird,
um die Last von der Nase wegzubekommen.
Sodass also wirklich die Brille frei vor deinen Augen schwebt und quasi überhaupt
keine... Kontakt mehr hat auf der Nase oder sonstiges Gesicht.
Das heißt also schon mit der jetzigen Technik kannst du die in einem Modus betreiben,
der dann wirklich beeindruckend ist, weil du den so noch von keinem anderen Device gesehen hast.
Und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum Apple das nicht macht.
Also wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt, das mal auszuprobieren.
Das solltet ihr unbedingt mal tun.
Also die Gelegenheit habt ihr übrigens alle, wenn ihr in Reichweite eines Apple-Stores seid.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die einem das erlauben.
Was?
Einfach das Leitziel rauszunehmen und zu sagen, jetzt lass mich mal eine halbe Stunde alleine.
Ich möchte das jetzt mal ohne probieren.
Ich dachte, du meinst generell mal ausprobieren.
Nee, das glaube ich auch nicht.
Aber viele schreiben auch schon im Chat, das ist ein bisschen schwierig,
wenn man das Ding nie aufgehabt hat, unsere Aussagen überhaupt irgendwie zu
kontextualisieren, das kann ich auch ganz gut nachvollziehen.
Ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mit dem Leitziel. Also wie gesagt,
der Typ in dem Apple Store heute vorhin,
dem war das so unglaublich wichtig, dass seitlich kein Licht reinfällt und dann
benutzt du die Brille aber im Wesentlichen sowieso als AR-Gerät.
Also sprich, du hast immer deinen Raum um dich rum und siehst durch die Kameras den Raum um dich rum.
Es hilft total der Immersion, dass du plötzlich auch am Rand noch den echten
Raum einfach siehst, weil der ist ja eh nicht scharf, so weit draußen außerhalb deines Sichtfeldes.
Das ist also völlig unschädlich, ob da noch eine Brille drüber ist oder nicht.
Alleine, dass er dann da ist und nicht mehr einfach nur so ein schwarzer Rahmen,
führt dazu, dass man viel mehr in diesem so, das ist jetzt halt eine AR-Anwendung,
in der ich mich hier gerade bewege.
Ja, ich finde auch dieses AR, also man fügt Dinge im Raum hinzu,
aber hat den Raum noch, finde ich erstens viel angenehmer und auch viel spannender als dieses reine VR.
Ich bewege mich in einer komplett abgeschlossenen, dunklen Welt und weiß eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so genau, wo ich bin. Gut, das...
Ist wahrscheinlich mit dem richtigen Spiel, mit der richtigen VR-Erfahrung ein anderes Thema.
Aber so für das, für was die Brille beworben wird, also die Vision beworben
wird, dieses pack deine Fenster hier und da und hin und da und mach das und
unterhalte dich mit Kollegen, während du die Brille auf hast und so weiter.
Dafür brauchst du das Leitziel nicht.
Und selbst ich habe dann mal halt diese immersiven Umgebungen ausprobiert,
wo du dann da auf dem Mond stehst und wo du irgendwie da über den Bergen bist und so weiter,
um zu gucken, ob es mich bei denen denn dann total nervt, wenn ich das Leitziel
weg habe und drumherum quasi meinen echten Raum habe. Und selbst das stört überhaupt nicht.
Also auch diese Rundum-Panoramen wirken viel realistischer, wenn man nicht diesen
schwarzen Rahmen überall drumherum hat.
Also ich bin da ein bisschen wirklich völlig verwundert und verwirrt,
Warum das A nicht thematisiert wird,
weil die Informationen sind da draußen und B, warum Apple dort so eine Entscheidung
trifft oder sie können zumindest die Option anbieten.
Wenn sie schon irgendwie 22 verschiedene Varianten von dem Leitziel anbieten,
warum dann nicht auch eine Variante für Leute, die es einfach mal ohne haben wollen.
Also mal gucken, ob sich da noch irgendwo was tut.
So, das nächste, was mich irritiert hat, ist die Sache mit der Schärfe.
Tim, da hattest du ja schon in den letzten Sendungen immer gesagt,
du kriegst es eigentlich nicht so richtig scharf und bist dir immer nicht so
ganz sicher, liegt das jetzt eigentlich wirklich an der Technik oder an den
Linsen oder es ist doch irgendwie deine Augen.
Und ich muss sagen, für mich ist die wirklich knackscharf, also richtig extrem scharf.
Also die User Interface Elemente.
Die User Interface Elemente, die sind wirklich knackscharf und die sind aber
auch nur in der Mitte knackscharf.
Und jetzt kommen eben zwei Dinge rein, wo es dann eben überhaupt nicht scharf ist.
Und das erste ist halt alles, was durch Pass-Through durchkommt.
Das heißt also, diese ganze Propaganda da draußen, dass die Auflösung des normalen
Zimmers, in dem man sitzt, so fantastisch wäre. Das ist ein grober Unfug.
Du guckst dort wirklich auf eine abgefilmte, niedrigpixelige Variante deiner Umgebung.
Ja, wenn du versuchst, auf die Uhr zu gucken oder aufs Handy oder auf einen
Bildschirm, dann siehst du, dass.
Da wirklich wenig Pixel am Start sind.
Und teilweise auch Doppelbilder so in der Mitte, das ist so die Pixel so.
Es ist klar besser als das, was die Quest 3 hat, das ist überhaupt keine Frage,
aber es ist noch nichtmals doppelt so gut und es ist wirklich weit,
weit, weit davon entfernt, irgendwie wirklich realistisch zu sein.
Das heißt also, es reicht, um sich im Raum zu orientieren, es reicht,
um irgendwie zu gucken, so wo ist jetzt mein Glas Bier und wer sitzt da noch irgendwie.
Also ganz so kritisch würde ich es jetzt nicht sehen.
Aber du kannst dein Handy damit praktisch nur sehr schwer bedienen.
Ja, also siehst alles, es ist halt alles unscharf, aber du kannst halt nichts
lesen im Großen und Ganzen.
Und das ist halt nicht das, was versprochen wurde, muss man einfach mal sagen.
Das heißt, die Displays selber sind aber grundsätzlich scharf genug.
Das heißt also, das Problem ist ja die Kamera.
Was wurde da versprochen?
In Bezug auf die Betrachtung des Raums?
Dass man gar nicht den Unterschied feststellen würde.
Achso, du meinst von den Journalisten versprochen?
Ja, genau.
Okay, aber nicht von Apple.
Naja, also müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, wie genau da die Statements sind.
Die sind dazu raus.
Also Apple ist geschickt genug, das so zu formulieren, dass sie keinen Unsinn erzählen.
Die Aussage gibt es nicht.
So, der nächste Punkt bezüglich Schärfe ist, und das hat mich dann wiederum
überrascht, Es gibt ja diese Methodik, dieses etwas schwierige Wort,
so Foveated Rendering. Habe ich das richtig ausgesprochen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Foveated Rendering.
Foveated Rendering. So, dahinter ist halt der Gedanke, was die wirklich super
macht, ist Eye-Tracking.
So, das heißt also, die Präzision.
Fand ich jetzt nicht so, aber ja.
Ja, your mileage may vary. Also das war bei mir echt gar kein Problem.
Das heißt also dieses, wo guckt das Auge hin und wo wird der Klick ausgelöst,
das hat bei mir, würde ich sagen, wirklich perfekt funktioniert.
Zumindest der Augenpart, zum Klick komme ich gleich noch.
So und der Gedanke ist ja, dass um insgesamt Rechenpower zu sparen und es auch
ähnlich zu machen wie das echte Auge, nur der Bereich von der Vision Pro wirklich
hochauflösend scharf gerendert wird,
wo das Auge gerade hinguckt und drumherum wird es einfach unschärfer.
So das Konzept ist auch jetzt gar nicht komplett neu, das gibt es auch schon
länger und das ist mir also bewusst, dass es das gibt und im Prinzip könnte
das auch gut funktionieren.
Es hat aber bei der Vision Pro einen großen Haken, nämlich dass die Qualität
der Linsen dann eben doch nicht so exorbitant gut ist, dass wenn ich jetzt,
den Kopf geradeaus richte und ich gucke nur mit den Augen nach links,
so 20 Grad, und lasse den Kopf aber nach vorne.
Das heißt also, ich sitze vor einem Monitor und lasse nur die Augen von links
nach rechts über die Zeilen drüber gleiten, ohne den ganzen Kopf mitzubewegen. Dann.
Sehe ich natürlich, dass da etwas scharf geschaltet wird oder scharf sein möchte,
links und rechts der Mitte, aber es ist, würde ich sagen, ein Schärfeabfall
von vielleicht 30 bis 40 Prozent im Gegensatz zu dem, wenn ich die Augen gerade nach vorne habe.
Das Eye-Tracking funktioniert, er versucht die Schärfe nachzuziehen,
aber die Linse selber bringt es einfach nicht an der Stelle.
Und das führt dazu, dass wenn ich beispielsweise jetzt irgendwie Code schreiben
will damit über einen virtuellen Bildschirm, ist das prinzipiell gut möglich,
ich muss aber die ganze Zeit meinen Kopf hin und her bewegen.
Und das ist etwas, was schlecht ist.
Und das ist erstaunlicherweise bei der Quest 3 nicht der Fall.
Die ist insgesamt nicht so scharf, aber viel konstanter über das ganze Blickfeld.
Das heißt also, da lebe ich zwar damit, dass ich da ein paar Pixel sehe und
dass ich ein bisschen Fliegengitter sehe.
Dafür habe ich aber überall über das ganze Gesichtsfeld eine ziemlich gleichmäßige Schärfeverteilung.
Also ich muss sagen, das Problem hatte ich weniger mit der Schärfe am Rand.
Ich hatte nur das Gefühl, dass am Rand so diese chromatische Aberration immer
stärker wird und dass so harte Kanten plötzlich so Farbsaum ausbrechen.
Das habe ich generell öfter, nicht nur am Rand.
Wenn man die Brille drunter hat, wird das richtig krass, was irgendwie klar
ist, aber auch so fand ich das, also das mit dem,
also für mich ist es nicht so ein
großes Problem gewesen, weil ich als Brillenträger sowieso gewohnt bin,
wenn ich irgendwo hingucke, auch den Kopf dahin zu drehen.
Insofern hatte ich da nicht so ein Problem mit, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn man die Brille drunter hat dann funktioniert das Eye-Tracking sowieso so
gut wie gar nicht mehr da muss man eigentlich immer direkt den Kopf auf das
Element drehen was man angucken will und selbst dann trifft man es nicht immer aber.
Jetzt heute im Store hattest du ja Ausgleichlinsen drin.
Da hatte ich Ausgleichlinsen da war es besser, das Problem Was ich zusätzlich fand, war, dass die,
Die Auswahlanimation, also die Art und Weise, wie dir das Vision OS anzeigt,
dass du etwas anguckst und dass es ausgewählt ist und du interagieren könntest,
dass die mir ein Ticken zu subtil ist und ich mir immer nicht so ganz sicher bin.
Habe ich da jetzt richtig gezielt gerade?
Habe ich jetzt, ich gucke das jetzt an, aber ist es jetzt selektiert oder nicht?
Da wäre eigentlich so ein Accessibility Mode nochmal ganz hilfreich,
der das stärker hervorhebt. Das wäre technisch trivial. Ja,
also generell, das Eye-Tracking hatte ich ja gerade eben schon gesagt,
das finde ich, das ist super, das ist wirklich super.
Was fast super ist, ist dann dieses mit der Hand schnipsen, um dann wirklich was auszulösen.
Das funktioniert, hat bei mir so in neun von zehn Fällen funktioniert, würde ich sagen.
Was gut ist, aber auf der anderen Seite eben auch in so einem Bereich von,
du kannst dich halt nicht drauf verlassen.
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl von totaler Stabilität und Sicherheit jetzt,
um nur mit den Händen in dieser GUI irgendwie mich zu bewegen.
Also in den meisten Fällen funktioniert es, aber manchmal funktioniert es nicht.
Und dann ist genau dieser Effekt, den du auch gerade beschrieben hast,
liegt es daran, dass er jetzt meinen Schnips nicht erkannt hat?
Liegt es daran, dass ich jetzt gerade doch ein bisschen daneben geguckt habe?
Muss ich es jetzt nochmal irgendwie anders mich ausrichten und so.
Und das bringt so eine gewisse Unschärfe in die ganze Bedienung rein, die dann doch stört.
Auch wieder im Vergleich zur Quest 3, da hast du halt diese Awkward-Controller geschenkt.
Also mit der Fingersteuerung fange ich gar nicht alles an mit der Quest 3,
die kann man vergessen. Aber wenn du diese Controller hast, das hat alles ultra
präzise und ultra stabil.
Da denkst du halt nicht drüber nach, ob das jetzt gerade klappt oder nicht,
sondern da weißt du einfach, es funktioniert, solange die Batterien laufen.
Ja, also ich hatte Probleme mit dem Scrollen.
Weil, wenn du normal die Finger zusammentappst, dann macht man die auch relativ
schnell wieder auseinander, das erkennt er dann.
Aber wenn du scrollst, dann musst du dir angewöhnen, nach dem Scrollen,
wenn du den Scrollvorgang beendest, die Finger wirklich wieder weit auseinander
zu machen. Sonst erkennt er nicht, dass du die Finger nicht mehr zusammen hast.
Und dann folgt er deiner Hand und die Liste, die du gerade scrollst,
scrollt weiter hoch und runter. Es ist irgendwie so.
Ja, scrollen ging bei mir wiederum gut. Das hatten wir auch schon bei mir im
Wohnzimmer. Das war dann wirklich gar kein Problem. Also das war eine der Sachen,
die, finde ich, konstant gut funktioniert haben.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat er auch meine Hände nicht richtig eingemessen.
Also ich hatte massiv Probleme mit diesem Fingerbedienung. ich hätte da ja gerne
lieber irgendeinen Controller und wenn es nur ein kleiner Button ist,
den man irgendwo drückt.
Naja, man kann halt natürlich jetzt eine Tastatur und Trackpad halt anschließen.
Das ist dann ganz cool auch. Also selbst wenn du den Bildschirm nicht spiegelst,
kannst du das ja trotzdem als Eingabeinstrumente darüber verwenden.
Das geht natürlich, aber dann hast du halt wieder Kram, der irgendwo halt auf
dem Schoß oder sonst wo liegt.
Aber dann kommt natürlich sofort diese Stabilität in der Bedienung rein.
Und ansonsten von den Anwendungen her, dieses Spiegeln des MacBook-Screens,
das ist schon cool, wenn du dann also plötzlich da so ein 50 Zoll Monitor vor dir schweben hast.
Das hat bei mir auch ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Die Geschwindigkeit ist top. Null Latenz, wirklich extrem geschmeidig.
Also da hatte ich keinerlei Gefühl so, da zieht jetzt was nach und wenn ich
die Sachen durch die Gegend scrolle oder durch die Gegend ziehe oder sowas.
Was wir da über ein normales WLAN hinbekommen ohne Kabel, das fand ich schon
bemerkenswert. Also das war richtig gut.
Ist allerdings auf der Quest 3 mittlerweile auch ziemlich gut.
Da gibt es eine Software, wer die Quest hat, die habe ich dann danach auch mal mir rausgesucht.
Die heißt Immersed, mit der ist es fast so gut. Nicht ganz so gut,
aber fast so gut. Aber wer das also quasi eine Quest 3 hat und mal ausprobieren will.
Aber du hast doch auf der Quest 3 nicht ansatzweise diese Auflösung.
Du guck dir mal die Specs an, so viel weniger.
Ich hab da durchgeguckt.
Das ist ein Drittel weniger, das ist nicht so. Und dadurch, dass du aber dafür
überall im Sichtfeld die gleiche Schärfe hast, fand ich es für Computerbedienung
im Ergebnis angenehmer.
Also ich fand,
dieses Mac Display Mirroring oder wie auch immer das dann heißt,
fand ich mitunter das absurd best funktionierende Feature.
Weiß ich nicht. Für 4000 Euro kriegt man aber auch andere gute Monitore. Also insofern.
Naja, du kannst es natürlich halt überall einfach schnell aus der Tasche auszaubern.
Also mich hat der Typ im Apple Store auch gefragt, ob ich denn damit dann mal
arbeiten würde. Und dann meine ich so, ja gut, da gibt es ja keine Software dafür.
Was ich denn benutzen würde? Ja, X-Code. Ja, hier Mirroring von App und so weiter.
Und dann sage ich, ja gut, vielleicht im Zug oder im Flugzeug.
Aber ansonsten zu Hause setze ich mich nicht mit dem Ding hin, um zu arbeiten.
Also ich habe eine Stunde Coden ausprobiert. Eben genau, einfach nur im Mirroring.
Und grundsätzlich von der Größe her, was du plötzlich am Platz hast.
Ich habe jetzt hier nur ein 14 Zoll MacBook Pro, was du also plötzlich alles
an Fenstern nebeneinander arrangieren kannst.
Top. gar keine Frage, aber dieses ich muss den Kopf nachziehen,
um es wirklich scharf zu haben, das funktioniert bei mir einfach nicht.
An der Stelle kurz mal reingegrätscht, noch eine Erfahrung, die ein Freund von
mir erzählt hat, der halt auch für Mac programmiert und.
Der arbeitet mit der Brille sehr gerne, vor allem per Programming Remote.
Das heißt, er arbeitet mit dem FaceTime-Sharing sozusagen, kannst du dann eben
auch deinen Bildschirm sharen.
Und dann hast du noch eine andere Person im Raum, die dann auf deinem Sofa sitzt
sozusagen, diesem Avatar.
Und beide haben denselben Bildschirm.
Und er meinte, das wäre der totale Gamechanger für so eine kooperative Arbeit über große Distanzen.
Und er hat dann auch mit der Brillenanpassung keine Probleme sozusagen gesehen.
Also es ist alles scharf. Ich bin da noch nicht ganz so angekommen,
aber schön, wenn es so ist.
Ja, dann kann ich mir das auch super vorstellen. Das ist definitiv eine Anwendung,
die natürlich jetzt sehr singulär ist und das hat natürlich jetzt nicht jeder,
aber das ist natürlich auch etwas, was du mit gar nichts repliziert bekommst.
Es gibt schon so Szenarien, wo immer mal wieder eine interessante Konstellation,
aufpoppt und ich glaube, so muss man dieses Gerät auch sehen.
Ich meine, du kritisierst es jetzt so ein bisschen aus so einer.
Hallo neues Consumer-Produkt Perspektive.
Ich glaube ja nach wie vor, die Vision Pro ist eigentlich eine totale,
Beta-Prototyp wir testen mal was geht Variante.
Das ist eine Public Beta.
Aber sowas von. Genau, also aber eine sehr gute. Also sie haben sich eine Menge
Mühe gegeben und hatte ich auch schon mal erzählt, ein paar Sachen funktionieren ja wirklich Bombe.
Also diese Stabilität im Raum, also das eigentliche Tracking.
Das ist auch hammerhart. Also so rocksolide, wie das ist.
Da zittert nichts.
Da zittert nichts. Also ich hab das in keiner anderen Brille gesehen.
Also nach ein paar Updates hat das die Quest 3 nahezu genauso gut.
Also da stehen nahezu genauso.
Also nicht genauso.
Dichter dran als die Klickrate, Failrate bei der Vision Pro oder den Unschärfeabfall.
Also die kleinen Fehler, die du da alle paar Minuten mal drin hast,
die nehme ich da gerne im Kauf dem gegenüber.
Mag ja alles sein. Ist ja auch schön, wenn Apple da auch noch was aufzuholen
hat oder noch nicht ausreichend viel besser ist etc.
Ich denke, allen ist irgendwie auch relativ klar, was jetzt geschehen muss.
Und es ist auch klar, dass das nochmal den nächsten,
technologischen Hardware-Schritt braucht, der nicht von heute auf morgen kommt.
Naja, Software-Schritt auch.
Ja, na sicher, klar, die Zeit ist ja jetzt auch da. Sie gewinnen ja jetzt eine Menge Erfahrung.
Erstmal, was schlägt bei den Leuten überhaupt ein, was nicht?
Wir erinnern uns, bei der Apple Watch war das am Anfang auch,
da haben sie irgendwie drei, vier, fünf verschiedene Sachen postuliert,
wofür die Uhr irgendwie gut wäre.
Was hat sich am Ende durchgesetzt?
Fitness.
Fitness, Notification und Gesundheit. Das sind die drei Killer-Apps und dieses
Ganze, wir kommunizieren hier und mein Puls wird übertragen und so weiter.
Das sind keine Anwendungen für die Uhr. Und überhaupt Apps haben sich auch auf
der Apple Watch nur sehr begrenzt überhaupt durchgesetzt.
Also es gibt ja fast gar keine Diskussion darüber.
Also was ich an Software gerne sehen würde, das war erstens ein Multi-User-Modus.
Also der fehlt ja auf dem iPad schon.
Gut, iPads sind jetzt nicht so teuer. Was heißt es mit Multi-User?
Also, dass man jederzeit wechseln kann und auch eine andere.
Also, du musst dich ja in deinem Apple-Account anmelden, um irgendwas Sinnvolles tun zu können.
Ja, jetzt wie beim iPad.
Genau, und dann bist du eigentlich komplett mit deinem Account drin und fertig.
Aber es gibt doch einen Gästemodus angeblich, ne?
Keine Ahnung.
Den haben wir ja nicht ausprobiert.
Den haben wir nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist doch auch nicht wie.
Also, er misst halt den Augenabstand neu ab, wenn wer anders die Brille auf hat.
Also, er versucht zumindest erstmal, da ein bisschen entgegenzukommen.
Aber die ganze App-Struktur ist natürlich die von dem, wo der Account mitgekoppelt ist.
Das wäre auch vom Marketing eigentlich sinnvoll, dass du mal eben die Brille
mal jemand anders geben kannst.
Die kostet 4000 Euro, aber du kannst sie zumindest gleichwertig mit deiner Frau teilen.
Ja, ja, genau. Oder irgendeinem Freund mal ordentlich zeigen.
Und dann, wie war das, 28 verschiedene Muffen?
Warum? Also warum sind die nicht in der Lage, eine Brille zu bauen,
die mehr oder weniger für alle Köppe passt?
Das ist sehr schwierig und unmöglich. Außerdem kostet jede 219 Euro.
Was, jede Muffe?
Ja.
Naja, wie auch immer.
Die Billen sind billiger.
Entschuldigung, wenn das gerade so ein bisschen Mantra wird,
aber die Quest 3 hat es hinbekommen. Die haben keine wechselbaren Muffen.
Das beschwert sich niemand drüber.
Das ist Quatsch. Was ich auch sehen würde gerne ist, bei dem Mac-Modus ist,
dass man auch da einen Immersion-Modus hat, wo sämtliche Fenster des Macs einzeln positionierbar sind.
Also, dass der Desktop quasi weg ist.
Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein. Ich meine,
der Window-Manager vom Mac ist sowieso so ein 3D-Ding, wo Texturen einzeln auf
Fenster gelegt werden und rumgeschoben werden und so weiter.
Da kann auch jedes Fenster einzeln dargestellt werden, weil dieses verdeckte
Dinge neu rendern, das macht das Betriebssystem schon lange nicht mehr.
So ein Modus, wo du einfach so peng, dann hast du dein Dock irgendwo und dann
sind alle Fenster irgendwo und dann kannst du sie rumschieben, wie du sie brauchst.
Was du eigentlich willst, ist, dass die Vision Pro selber ein Mac ist und dass
du da nicht nochmal einen brauchst, auf den du drauf schaust.
So reden wir ja derzeit von einem Remote Access System auf Screen Basis.
Und was du eigentlich möchtest, ist, dass die Software in deiner Brille läuft
und dann hast du natürlich auch die volle Freiheit, die Fenster irgendwo zu
platzieren, weil der gesamte Raum da ist.
Aber das Vision OS ist ja mehr oder weniger nur ein abgespecktes iOS.
Da läuft ja kein komplettes Betriebssystem.
Naja, aber wir wissen, dass iOS auch nur ein abgespecktes macOS ist.
Also es wäre überhaupt nicht das Problem, auch macOS darauf noch laufen zu lassen,
aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie das...
Tun werden, aber ich denke, dass in dem Moment...
Ich will die Möglichkeit haben, mich mit einem Rechner zu verbinden,
wo ich Peripherie dran habe, die ich nicht an die Brille kriege,
wo ich ein Terminal habe, wo ich Kommandozeilentools starten kann,
die mir sinnvolle Dinge tun, wo ich ein ordentliches Dateisystem habe und, und, und.
Ein professionelles Gerät. Nur weil Apple Pro dran schreibt,
ist die Vision Pro überhaupt nicht Pro.
Ja, aber weißt du, was du machen musst, damit du diese Features bekommst?
Was denn?
Na, du musst über einen populären Podcast berichten und dann wird dir zugehört
und dann werden diese Features irgendwann kommen.
Gut, das habe ich jetzt getan.
Also das, was ich gelesen habe, da drin ist ja ein M2. Ist da ja verbaut.
Ist das nicht ein M1?
Nee, ist ein M2.
Und dass viel von dessen Kapazität halt drauf geht für dieses Ganze,
ich werte die Kamerasignale aus, das sind ja zig Kameras, die da drin verbaut
sind und muss noch mal ein Eye-Tracking machen und so weiter und so fort.
Und dass dann nicht mehr so rasend viel für hartes Computing übrig bleibt und
dass sie darum quasi dort derzeit Kompromisse machen.
Aber gut, in die nächste Fassung können sie halt ein M5 reinbauen,
dann sieht die Welt schon wieder anders aus.
Ja, aber natürlich wirst du kein Final Cut Pro auf der Brille laufen lassen und Videos schneiden.
Oder ein Logic da drauf laufen lassen. Ja, wie kriege ich denn mein externes
Keyboard angeschraubt?
Achso, du meinst jetzt native?
Ja, native auf der Brille.
Aber im Prinzip müsste es doch sogar schon geben. Es gibt doch Final Cut Pro
für iPad, das müsste ja hier einfach laufen.
Das habe ich nicht versucht.
Das müsste laufen, aber Final Cut Pro für iPad ist ja nun auch eine extrem runtergedampfte Variante.
Das müsste eigentlich schon laufen und ich weiß jetzt nicht,
ja klar, dann Kapazität, Speicherplatz, bla bla bla.
Genau, für die 4000 Euro kriegst du nämlich nur auch 256 Gigabyte Filesystem.
Was denkst du denn? Weißt du, was das kostet, so viel Gigabyte?
Unbezahlbar okay gut.
Okay also noch mit der Hardware, man ahnt es hadere ich gerade,
also ich sehe das so wie du das ist jetzt für den ersten Aufschlag ist das erstaunlich
und es ist besser als alles was ich bisher gesehen habe aber es ist,
du hast halt umso deutlicher finde ich jetzt so die Karotte vor der Nase hängen
so wie man es eigentlich haben will,
und ein paar Sachen finde ich, das stellen sich halt selber ein Bein wie mit
diesen Lightseals und bei anderen Geschichten müssen wir halt einfach noch irgendwie
einige Generationen abwarten.
Aber ich finde zum Beispiel, es würde wenig bis gar nichts bringen,
die Displayauflösung weiter hochzuziehen.
Weil sie sind da meiner Meinung nach oder meiner Augen sagen wir schon im Retina-Bereich.
Das heißt also, wenn sie da jetzt noch, also was ist, du siehst keine Pixel,
du hast super glatte Kanten an den gerenderten Elegern.
Also wo sie investieren müssen.
Ist die Kameratechnik. Wenn du so einen großen 40, 50 Zoll Bildschirm da simulierst,
der ja native über 10.000 Pixel hätte.
Aber auch einen Abstand zu dir hat.
Der steht ja nicht direkt vor dir drauf. Du kannst ja nicht eins zu eins die
Pixeldichte des anzuzeigenden Monitors machen, sondern du musst mit reingerechnen
die Distanz, die du quasi im virtuellen Raum dazu hast.
Ja, aber ich glaube, also die Auflösung muss sich mindestens nochmal vervierfachen pro,
also du brauchst mindestens so 8K pro Auge und dann wird das,
ich meine, du hast ja eben auch selber gesagt, du guckst in den Raum,
da kommt natürlich jetzt auch noch die Auflösung der Kameras dazu und auch da
wird es sicherlich noch besser werden können,
aber grundsätzlich glaube ich schon, dass noch ein bisschen mehr Auflösung,
also am Ende wissen wir es nicht, es ist halt eine Vielzahl von Dingen.
Die eigentliche Frage, die sich ja mir stellt, ist nicht so sehr,
ist jetzt diese konkrete Hardware heute schon so oder so,
sondern ist eigentlich diese Idee des Spatial Computing, also dass du wirklich
durch so einen Teil durchschaust und damit irgendwie längere Zeit deinen digitalen Erlebnis,
Entspannungskonsum,
Programmierer, was auch immer, Kreativspace erlebst versus du benutzt.
Irgendeinen der anderen klassischen Systeme. Hat das Zukunft?
Ist das sozusagen der richtige Weg? Oder ist das ein Weg, der für manche richtig
sein kann oder besser sein kann?
Das reicht ja auch aus, weil nichts wird für alle sein und nicht für jeden Moment sowieso nicht.
Sondern ist es sozusagen ein Gerät, was dann auch eine Rolle spielt?
Das ist ja auch von Anfang an meine Grundskepsis gewesen.
Ich hadere ja schon mit dem iPad. Ich finde zwar ein iPad irgendwie toll,
ich habe auch meine Anwendung für ein iPad, Aber mein iPad ist halt nur für
sehr wenige Anwendungen mein Go-To-Device.
Also für die wenigsten Anwendungen von allen, die ich jetzt habe mit meinem ganzen Gerätepark.
Im Prinzip konsumieren.
Genau, Filme gucken, aber das auch nur in bestimmten Situationen.
So im Bett irgendwie. Kalender gucke ich auch gerne. Wenn man unterwegs ist.
Ja, Kalender, ja, nee, das würde mir schon, nee.
Nein, besser als auf dem Phone.
Ja, aber schlechter als auf dem Mac.
Richtig, aber den habe ich meistens nicht dabei.
Ja, aber ich, ja, aber dann, klar, wenn es schnell gehen soll und ausnahmsweise,
und man kann das auch mal machen.
Mein Go-To-Device ist ja, die Definition von Go-To-Device ist,
was ist das Gerät, wenn ich alle zur Verfügung habe, welches nehme ich?
So. Und da würde ich derzeit in meiner Anwendungsrealität sagen 90% Mac,
80% Mac, sagen wir es mal so.
Weil das iPhone oft, das stimmt eigentlich auch nicht.
Es ist schwierig, ja das iPhone, es gibt eine bestimmte Kategorie von Sachen,
da ist halt einfach das iPhone die Nummer 1.
Das hat aber auch mit der Verfügbarkeit von Apps zu tun, weil es die halt auf dem Mac nicht gibt.
Apps, die ich auch auf dem Mac starten kann, also iPhone-Apps,
die ich auch auf dem Mac starten kann, da gehe ich auch lieber an den Mac.
Es kommt drauf an, also im Prinzip alle Kommunikations-Apps haben bei mir einen iPhone-Fokus.
Herzhaft. Also wenn ich Messages auf dem Mac machen kann, dann ziehe ich das immer Touch vor.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, Das iPhone ist immer dabei, ist immer am schnellsten aus der Tasche.
Rappelt, wenn eine Notification reinkommt und du kannst halt schnell eine Antwort
tippen oder reinlabern, wenn du was machen möchtest.
Also deswegen ist so dieses echte Text-Message, Sprach-Message,
dieser ganze Krempel ist für mich, also das iPhone sehr ein Kommunikations-Device.
Während für mich das iPad mehr ein Konsumier-Device ist, also so,
keine Ahnung, YouTube oder irgendwelche kleinen Spiele oder irgendein Kram.
Zum Beispiel gehst du zum Arzt, was machst du im Warteraum? Ja,
einen Rechner rausziehen kann man schon machen.
Aber wenn du dann nochmal einen Termin ausmachst, dann hole ich halt das iPad
raus und gucke, weil da habe ich irgendwie, das passt noch an übliche Plexiglas-Dinger,
die bei Ärzten irgendwie inzwischen überall rumstehen und so weiter.
Dann nimmst du halt das iPad und fertig.
Also weil auf dem iPhone im Kalender habe ich eigentlich nie so richtig genug Überblick.
Und das ist auf dem iPad gut genug.
Auf dem Mac wäre der Kalender jetzt noch einen Ticken größer.
Aber wenn man es sich anguckt, das ist keine Revolution mehr.
Klar, man kann besser tippen, aber das war es dann auch schon.
Und ansonsten richtig arbeiten natürlich nur auf dem Mac. Womit sonst?
Also bei dem Punkt, bei der Frage, die du stellst, ist das jetzt ein guter Proof
of Concept dafür, wie wir in Zukunft etliche Dinge irgendwie machen wollen?
Ich finde das ganz schwer zu beantworten, weil das hat man gerade eben auch
schon gesagt, die Softwareseite halt noch so unausgegoren ist.
Ich habe mich halt jetzt doch ein bisschen länger auch durch diese ganzen Demos,
muss man wirklich sagen, es sind ja alles eigentlich nur Demos durchgearbeitet,
also sprich irgendwie das Alicia Keys Konzert mit den verschiedenen Standpunkten
und dieses Slackline Video,
wo da die Frau über die Slackline irgendwie in Finnland rüber geht.
Und da siehst du diese klassischen Probleme von 3D-Filmen und 3D-Präsentationen,
dass die eben in so einer ganz ungesunden Welt sind von wir wollen fast alles
scharf zeigen, aber unsere Aufnahmelinsen sind wieder nicht scharf genug,
dass das richtig gut klappt.
Und dann bist du es halt eigentlich als Mensch gewohnt, ich möchte jetzt da
hinten, der Musiker interessiert mich, den gucke ich jetzt an und der wird nicht
scharf, sondern der ist so leicht unscharf.
Aber er ist auch nicht so unscharf, dass du es als künstlerisches Mittel interpretierst
und du ärgerst dich, dass du eben den jetzt nicht scharf bekommst.
Anders oder wirklich völlig anders ist die Wirkung in diesem Film Submerged
der ist ja jetzt gerade auch erst vor ein paar Wochen, Querstrich Tagen rausgekommen,
und das ist quasi der erste wirklich professionell,
konzipierte geskriptete und gedrehte Mini-Kurz-Kinofilm für die Vision Pro den.
Habe ich leider nicht mehr geschafft bevor ich das Ding dann nicht abgetreten.
Habe ja den Ding guckt ihr mal an weil das ist sehr, sehr geil.
Das ist im Prinzip das Boot nachgedreht mit einem zu großen U-Boot.
Ich habe nur den Anfang gesehen und das wurde direkt lächerlich, weil das ist eine Halle.
Dieses U-Boot ist eine Halle. Da kannst du dich quer reinlegen und ausstrecken.
Das mag aber ein Problem auch der Perspektive sein, weil auch die Figuren wirken
in dem 3D nicht so ganz stimmig in der Größe. Also da mag auch noch der eine
oder andere Haken drin sein.
Aber was dieser Film hervorragend macht, ist grundsätzliche Schärfe.
Also das ist wirklich so IMAX-Schärfe, die du da plötzlich hast.
Und dann eben ein sehr künstlerisch bewusster, vernünftiger Umgang mit Tiefenschärfe
für einen 3D-Film. Dass du eben zum einen Einstellungen hast,
wo einfach mal alles super scharf ist, weil du halt einfach die Blende entsprechend eingestellt hast.
Also super kleine Blende, was weiß ich, also nicht nur F8, sondern F20,
was die auch immer da genommen haben.
Das heißt, du kannst selber entscheiden, wo möchte ich gerade hingucken und alles ist scharf.
Und der andere Modus ist eine künstlerisch sehr klar eingesetzte Blende.
Tiefen und Schärfe, dass du also gesagt hast, so dieses Porträt im Vordergrund
ist jetzt scharf und alles andere ist so blurry, dass mein Auge gar nicht erst
auf den Gedanken kommt, da zu versuchen scharf zu stellen, weil es einfach kapiert,
das ist jetzt so gemeint.
Und dann merkst du plötzlich zum einen, was dieses Display eigentlich kann in
dieser Brille, was diese Kameras, die da drin verbaut sind, alles überhaupt
nicht ansatzweise umgesetzt bekommen, dass du also plötzlich,
oh, so hatte ich es mir jetzt eigentlich vorgestellt, wenn ich diese Brille
aufsetze, dass alles so aussieht.
Plus, dass es eben einfach mal offensichtlich mal ein Künstler war,
der sich jetzt mal ein bisschen austoben konnte.
Das ist ja auch der, der hier diesen einen bekannten Film gemacht hat.
Die Story ist jetzt nichts berauschendes und sowas, aber guckt euch das mal
an, wenn ihr da irgendwie die Gelegenheit zukommt.
So kann das schon ganz gut funktionieren.
So eine andere Anwendung, die haben wir auch zusammen ausprobiert,
die mich völlig umgehauen hat, ist Sky Guide.
Das heißt hier, das haben wir schon mal besprochen, als ich erzählt habe,
wo ich da in der Rhön war, in diesem Sternenpark und weil nur Nebel war.
So und so eine App, mit der man ja die Sterne findet und wo steht eigentlich
gerade hier, wo stehen die Planeten und wo finde ich meinen Saturn,
ist eben Skyguide. Gibt es fürs iPhone.
Gibt es auch verschiedene Apps in der Richtung, aber für Skyguide gibt es eben
jetzt auch eine Vision Pro App.
Und die habe ich mal ausprobiert und,
So hätte ich es ja gerne in der Rhön gehabt. Das heißt also,
da kommt dieses Display eben auch zu sich selbst.
Weil da kommt eben, ist das eigentlich ein OLED?
Ich fand die App aber ein OLED-Dreffverbot.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein super tiefes Schwarz. Da macht plötzlich dann
auch das Leitziel Sinn, dass du also auch überall Schwarz hast.
Siehst du mal, siehst du mal?
Das ist aber auch die einzige Anwendung, die ich hatte.
Aber darauf kommt es an.
Aber in dem Moment war es gut. So und dann hast du wirklich diesen Sternenhimmel.
Und das ist alles knackscharf, zumindest halt in der Mitte, wo du hinguckst,
aber alles andere, da verwischte sich, war es nicht so dramatisch,
wenn ich halt irgendwie auf Text gucke einfach.
Plus du hast noch diesen Modus, dass du dann noch so ein virtuelles Fernglas
aufsetzen kannst, um dann also die Andromeda-Galaxie etwas stärker als bisher
noch mal hier ranziehen zu können.
Sondern auch da funktioniert dann plötzlich halt dieses, ich habe eine Taucherbrille
auf, Moment viel besser, weil du dann eben denkst, so jetzt gucke ich wirklich
hier durch ein Fernglas durch.
Also das war, ich würde nicht sagen ein spiritueller Moment,
aber da kommt diese Technologie dann wirklich zu sich selber.
So möchte man eigentlich immer gerne Sterne gucken können.
Das war also wirklich wie in einem guten Planetarium vom Insekt her.
Probier das dann auf jeden Fall auch nochmal aus.
Im Prinzip ja, ich fand die App nicht so geil. Also ich bin ja Stellarium gewöhnt,
weil ich das immer benutze und Stellarium ist halt einfach auch besser in dem, was es zeigt.
Das habe ich dann gleich auf der Quest 3 ausprobiert, weil das geht nämlich
für die Quest 3 Stellarium.
Aber da fällt dann das Display echt zurück, weil es halt kein OLED ist.
Und du dann halt auf so ein dunkles Grau guckst, dann sind die Sterne dann eben
an doch auch nicht wirkliche Punkte, sondern dann schon eher so als Flächen gerendert.
Also das ist einer der Punkte, wo ich sagen würde, da ist dann die Quest 3 wirklich
nicht hinterhergekommen an der Stelle.
So, wieder auf die andere Seite rum. Ich habe mir dann mal etwas intensiver
diese immersiven, selbstgemachten Videos und Bilder angeguckt.
Ja, wo du dann also plötzlich deine Kinder filmst und dann die in 3D hast und
ich mach 3D Bilder und sowas.
Ey, was ein Scheiß. Also das ist auch wieder etwas, wo der Diff zwischen dem,
wie es beschrieben wurde, dass du plötzlich wieder genau in der Szene drin bist und sowas.
Du guckst da in einen relativ kleinen Schuhkarton.
Und den kannst du dann zwar ein bisschen größer ziehen, dass er immersiv wird,
aber das ist von dem, was aufgenommen wird von der Kamera, ist es echt.
Du redest jetzt von 3D-Video.
Was du mit dem Telefon aufgenommen hast. Nee, die ich mit der Brille aufnehme.
Ach so, okay, das geht ja auch.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, selbst das Werbematerial, was sie in der Apple-Demo im
Apple-Store zeigen, sind die Filme von so niedriger Qualität,
dass du denkst, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst.
Die Auflösung ist nicht toll.
Also die Kameras sind dermaßen schlimm.
Ein Foto, was bei Mittags Sonne aufgenommen ist und trotzdem Farbrauschen hatte,
weil die Kamera irgendwie nicht genug Leck gekriegt hat oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht Also Technikjournalistinnen die sagen, dass das jetzt irgendwie,
irgendwas beeindruckendes wäre da kann ich nur sagen, ihr seid aber sehr leicht
zu beeindrucken. So, wieder andere Seite.
Wenn die schreiben alles scheiße dann klickt doch keiner auf den Artikel Ja.
Mag sein Doch auch.
Wenn sie schreiben alles scheiße dann vielleicht schon.
Das stimmt Was ich ausprobiert habe Simple Piano.
Ich habe ja bei mir ein Stage Piano rumzustehen im Wohnzimmer.
Simply Piano.
Und da gibt es halt diese App, die dir dann virtuell vor dir deine Noten langfliegen
lässt und erkennt, dass du vor einem echten Klavier sitzt und das,
justierst du einmal entlang der Tasten, dass du also sagst, guck mal hier,
da ist das C und da ist das hohe C und dazwischen sind die schwarzen Tasten
und dann kriegst du also eingeblendet in der Vision Pro,
wo du wann welche Taste zu drücken hast. Das ist cool.
Funktioniert das gut?
Ja, ist super.
Aber gibt es auch auf der Quest 3. Habe ich seit anderthalb Jahren.
Aber das ist cool. Also das ist eine Sache, die kann man auch echt mal ausprobieren.
So als Musiklerninstrument.
Ich habe es ohne Klavier ausprobiert. Es gibt ja auch den ohne Klaviermodus.
Dass man so die Tastatur quasi einfach nur so virtuell auf dem Tisch drauf bietet.
Richtig, er hat nicht mal den Tisch erkannt.
Dann habe ich den in die App geschlossen. Das war mir dann zu doof.
Also mit einem echten Klavier hat das echt florist funktioniert.
Also das ist auch so eine Geschichte, wo man sofort merkt, okay,
hier wird so eine Ebene aufgemacht, oft gemacht, die du mit anderer Technologie
überhaupt nicht hinkriegst.
Also genau das Beispiel, was du eben so diese Kategorie, die du einforderst,
völlig zu Recht. Also das kriegst du ansonsten nicht hin.
So und ein sehr versöhnliches Ende, dann habe ich sie wieder abgetreten,
die Brille war Brettspiele.
Ich habe einfach mal Schach gespielt damit und eine Runde Schiffe versenken.
Und das macht irgendwie sonderbar viel Spaß,
weil du halt wirklich dann so ein wirklich sehr,
sehr schönes Holz-Schachbrett einfach sauber vor dir auf den Tisch gerendert
bekommst und du kannst dann wirklich mit deiner Hand die Figuren nehmen und
die auf dem Schachbrett vernünftig durch die Gegend ziehen.
Beim Schiffe versenken kannst du kleine, lustige Mini-Bötchen irgendwo reinsetzen
und dann explodieren die und saufen ab und du kannst wirklich rangehen und das
ist alles richtig sauber, gut gerendert.
Dann macht es Puff und alle Kühl fallen um?
Genau. So ich Genau, voriges Java-Merla-Matter Ich habe da ein paar Screenshots
dabei Warte mal, das ist wirklich, wirklich schön Das hier ist jetzt das Schachspiel, was ich jetzt hier.
Reinwerfe Also was mich ja total wundert dass bis jetzt offensichtlich gibt
es noch also korrigiert mich, aber ich habe weder was gehört noch geschweige
denn irgendwas entdeckt Ähm,
Es gibt doch nun diese 3D-Render-Realtime-Engines.
Kommen wir noch zu.
Genau, das bringt Roddy gleich rein. Ich bin jetzt auch gleich durch.
So, ich habe jetzt hier noch zweimal ein paar Screenshots vom wirklich Schiffe
versenken. Das bleibt halt ein stumpfes, doofes Spiel.
Aber so der Grat an...
Das ist ja weird, da ist noch so ein Hafen außenrum.
An Bells and Whistles, der da aufgefahren wird, ist schon süß.
Meine Herren, meine Herren.
So und auch sowas gibt es alles auf der Quest 3, aber da fehlt dann halt so
der letzte Tucken Render-Qualität und Schärfe, der dann hier bei der Vision
dann doch ganz gut funktioniert.
Und wenn du halt irgendwas Spannendes vor dir hast, ist es in dem Moment dann
auch nicht so tragisch, dass dein Zimmer halt nicht so toll gerendert wird.
Also das blendet das Auge dann, finde ich, stärker aus, als wenn du so einen
flachen Monitor vor dir hast.
Irgendwie fehlt dann da halt so diese Dreidimensionalität, die dann das Gehirn
nochmal anders überlistet.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das mit dem, dein Zimmer wird jetzt nicht so besonders
scharf gerendert, hat mich jetzt so sehr auch nicht gestört.
Es sei denn, du versuchst irgendwo in deiner Umgebung irgendwas anzugucken und
du hast dann so diesen Instinkt, ja gut, dann nehme ich die Brille halt schnell ab.
Was halt irgendwie auch nicht geht, weil du hast es ja gerade so fest gebamselt, dass sie richtig sitzt.
Und dann kriegst du das Teil auch nicht von der Fresse.
Gut, zum Thema Software und Spiele, da muss ich noch das, wie auch immer man
es ausspricht, Luna, glaube ich, mit Doppel-O-N-A geschrieben, Cozy Puzzle Games.
Das war auch so ein Minispiel. Ich habe da jetzt leider kein Screenshot von,
aber ich kann den Namen mal eben einfügen, wenn er das denn macht hier.
Wir brauchen nur links.
Da hast du halt so komische 3D-Szenen, wo du dann einzelne Teile immer dran
klebst, damit die dann bunt werden und so weiter.
Das war so als Zeitvertreib ganz niedlich irgendwie. Also es ist jetzt kein aufwändiges Spiel.
Aber ich dachte, ich versuch's dann tatsächlich mal. Genau, und dann sitzt immer
dieses Blau-Vieh im Menü.
Warum, was auch immer dieses Blau-Vieh ist. Egal.
Dann dachte ich, ich versuche mal eine richtige 3D-Anwendung.
Jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ich kenne im Wesentlichen drei.
Das ist Fusion 360, dann gibt es OnShape und dann gibt es Shaper 3D.
Fusion und OnShape.
3D-Modeling-Software.
Genau. Also CAD-Programme im weitesten Sinne. Genau.
Fusion und Onshape gibt es soweit ich weiß nicht auf der als Vision OS App.
Aber Shaper 3D gab es und das habe ich dann mal ausprobiert.
Gibt es auch immer noch.
Gibt es auch immer noch, ja. Ich denke nicht, dass sie es heute rausgenommen
haben. Gestern war es noch drin.
Und es ist nur leider kein richtiges 3D-Programm, sondern was sie machen ist, dass sie das,
was sie quasi auf dem Back haben als Fenster, da trennen sie so ein paar Paletten ab,
die kannst du dann einzeln irgendwo aufstellen und hast in der Mitte aber dann dein flaches Fenster,
wo sie dann eine 3D-Figur flach reinrendern.
Aber da glaube ich nach wie vor, da haben wir wahrscheinlich nur den richtigen
Schalter nicht gefunden. Also das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Doch, ich denke, das kann schon sein.
Da haben sie den Aufwand nur noch nicht reingesteckt, das dann tatsächlich 3D
zu machen. Und dem Programm traue ich es zu, dass sie es irgendwann hinkriegen.
Weil das ist also auch so ein bisschen mein Tipp, wenn man anfängt mit 3D-Modeling-Software
und weiß noch nicht so richtig, was man da so tut. Shaper 3D ist...
In der freien Variante kann man nicht so fürchterlich viel mitmachen,
aber es verhält sich wie eine normale Mac-App und man kriegt damit Dinge geregelt
und man versteht auch die Konzepte dahinter.
Aber zum Beispiel, ich bin jetzt gerade auf der Seite von denen und die haben
doch jetzt hier so Szenen, wo man sieht,
da kannst du dann deine Kaffeemaschine, die du gerade zusammengebaut hast in
3D, kannst du dann in einer echten Welt positionieren und um sie rumlaufen und
von allen Seiten betrachten und so weiter.
Also da wird es echt was geben, was wir einfach noch nicht gefunden haben.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin die Menüs soweit durchgegangen, das Programm ist eh nicht
so fürchterlich aufwendig, es ist eher ein etwas kleineres Programm,
aber wie gesagt, zum Anfang ist Shaper 3D, ich bin da ganz angetan von.
Benutze es aber nicht. irgendwas, was mal Realtime den ganzen Kram gemacht hat
mit Unity oder mit so Unreal Engine.
Also ich meine, wir haben doch diese ganze Gamer-Kram und das sollte ja das
Gerät auch schnell genug sein, um einfach in Echtzeit auf meine Bewegungen zu
reagieren und eben auch wirklich anders als diese ganzen Demo-Apps und Videos,
wo sozusagen deine Position immer eingebrannt ist,
wo du dich ja reinbewegen kannst und dann kann das ja auch alles in Echtzeit
neu gerendert werden und du kannst 360 Grad um dich herum gucken und im Prinzip
wäre das ja eine komplett immersive Geschichte, sowas muss es doch geben.
Also diese immersiven Szenarien sind so.
Es gibt ja diese Saurier-Demo.
Auf dem Mond kannst du da rumlaufen. Wirklich.
Das verschiebt sich alles richtig. Das war ja meine Frage auch in der früheren Sendung von mir.
Ist das dann eine feste Kamera oder ist es wirklich 3D gerendert und diese immersiven
Umgebungen sind wirklich sauber 3D gerendert. Da kannst du drin rumlaufen.
Wie weit kannst du da laufen? Ein paar Meter. Ja, aber die ganzen Objekte sind
doch alle fünf Kilometer entfernt.
Ja, geht so.
Da ist ja kein nahes Objekt, da ist ja nichts.
Die Mondoberfläche unter dir, da sind schon einiges an Steinen und sowas,
um die du rumläufst. Also da ist das eine oder andere.
Hast du diesen Dinosaurier-Dingsi ausprobiert?
Ja, klar.
Da kommt ja am Anfang der Schmetterling angeflogen, den kannst du dir ja auf
dem Finger, der sitzt ja dann auf deinem Finger, wenn du die Hand ausstreckst irgendwie.
Ich hab mich nur gefragt.
Und die benutzen garantiert Unity oder Unreal Engine.
Was auch immer. Ich hab mich nur gefragt, warum gibt es keine Apps,
die das benutzen und da mit Vision Pro was machen, weil das wäre ja sozusagen
out of the box, komplett 360 Grad.
Die Spiele, die Ralf jetzt vorgestellt hat und dieses komische Luna-Puzzle-Game,
die benutzen garantiert auch eine dieser Engines.
Aber sie funktionieren halt immer so, du hast etwas Gerendertes und das setzt
du irgendwo auf den Tisch in den realen Raum. Ja, klar.
Du bist nicht in so einem kompletten Environment.
Keine Ahnung. Achso, eine Sache habe ich noch versucht. Und zwar habe ich versucht,
die Vision mit meinem Steam-Account zu verbinden oder zumindest mit dem Rechner,
auf dem Steam-Games laufen,
um die dann quasi als Anzeige-Device für 3D-Games zu verwenden.
Aber da habe ich nichts gefunden, was auch nur im Anhieb irgendwie funktionieren würde.
Da sind wir dann noch nicht so weit. Das hat mit der Quest 2,
habe ich es mal ausprobiert, das war zwar auch eine sehr wonky Experience,
aber immerhin hat es funktioniert.
Also da zieht vielleicht wirklich halt so Apples Grundstrategie so,
wir wollen da jetzt erstmal keine Games drauf sehen und entforcen das in keiner.
Verboten ist es ja nicht.
Aber es gibt da auch echt keinen Support. Und du hast auch irgendwo halt so das Eingabeproblem.
So mit deinen Händen kannst du dann halt auch nicht so rasend viel machen versus
einem Controller, wo du dann halt doch diverses Freiheitsrader hast.
Das ist richtig. Also dass es keinen Controller gibt, das könnte man natürlich
auch als Nachteil werten.
Ich meine, ich bin mir relativ sicher, die schauen jetzt erstmal zu.
Die haben es nicht eilig. Die haben dieses Produkt rausgebracht,
damit es erstmal einen Proof of Concept ihrer Vision gibt.
Und ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn die nächste Generation,
die wahrscheinlich auch erst in zwei Jahren ansteht, auch wenn sie natürlich
mit Vision OS Updates auch schon nochmal was drehen können, aber dass erst mit
der nächsten Generation Hardware der nächste große Schritt kommt und dabei eine
ganze Menge über Bord geworfen wird.
Hoffentlich auch der hohe Preis.
Ja, sicher, aber ich meine der hohe Preis ist wahrscheinlich mit den Komponenten,
die du da drin hast, auch irgendwo zu vertreten.
Wobei ich jetzt echt sagen muss, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
durchgekommen. Mein Respekt vor dem, was Meta hier mit der Quest 3 zu einem
Zehntel des Preises abgeliefert hat, der ist echt gestiegen jetzt seitdem.
Weil der Unterschied ist mal definitiv
nicht Faktor 10, der ist nicht mal Faktor 2 von der Qualität her.
Und das ist dann eben schon Komponenten hin oder her. Aber das ist doch die.
Die du mir hier aufgesetzt hast. Das war doch total Pixel-Gitter-Welt. Das war doch alles...
Ja, deine Augen, Tim.
Nee, aber ich meine, das ist nicht Faktor 10, das ist einfach eine andere Kategorie.
Also ich meine, da siehst du sofort, dass du auf den Bildschirm guckst und das
ist bei der Vision Pro überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Also, sorry, aber den Vergleich lasse ich überhaupt nicht gelten,
weil da, finde ich, spielt diese Meta-Geschichte überhaupt nicht in derselben Liga.
Sehe ich komplett anders. Also ich nutze die täglich jetzt.
Ja, das kann ja sein, dass man die täglich benutzt, aber es ist halt,
optisch ist das nicht in derselben Liga, also das ist nicht ein bisschen schlechter oder so.
Genau, die ist scharf, die Vision Pro ist unscharf, außer ich gehe direkt in
den Kopf, weil wir haben da jetzt unterschiedliche Prioritäten.
Wir reden jetzt gerade über die Auflösung des Bildschirms und wenn ich in diese
Meta reinschaue, dann ist es halt...
Gitter, Muster. Ich sehe jeden Pixel als solchen und das sehe ich halt in der
Vision Pro nicht. Also, ist doch ganz offensichtlich.
Ja, aber wenn es dann unscharf ist, nutzt es mir nicht, dass da viele Pixel sind.
Du hast auch gesagt, es ist alles scharf.
In der Mitte, in einem sehr kleinen Bereich, direkt in der Mitte.
Sobald ich mit meinen Augen nach links oder rechts gehe.
Ist es sofort unscharf. Ja, das ist diese Motion Blur, dass es erst nachschärft
und du hast es immer wo du hinkommst.
Auch dann ist es nicht mehr scharf, sondern du hast diese Doppelstrukturen,
du hast diese, wie heißt es, chromatische Abiteration kommt immer stärker rein.
In der Mitte, also wenn du wirklich geradeaus guckst, ist es scharf,
aber wenn du nach links guckst, ist es nicht mehr scharf, oder was?
Genau. So, und so gucke ich nun mal auf einen Monitor. Wenn ich vor einem Monitor
bin, dann bewege ich mich die ganze Zeit meinen Kopf, sondern ich bewege nur meine Augen.
So, und das funktioniert mit der Quest 3 besser. Und von daher,
ja, da ist dann ein Fliegengitter, das stört mich aber weniger,
als dass ständig alles unscharf ist, wo ich mit meinen Augen hingucken will.
Das ist ja quasi alles, ja, egal. Ich weiß nicht, ich fand dieses Gitter,
habe mich einfach total abgeturnt, gleich von vorne rein. Das war für mich irgendwie
überhaupt keine Option.
Naja, mal schauen. Also ich werde das Ding jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal etwas intensiver testen.
Ich habe da so ein paar Szenarien, die ich ganz gerne mal überprüfen möchte,
ob das sozusagen als Arbeitsmodus funktioniert.
Und dann werde ich berichten.
So, jetzt haben wir aber auch, glaube ich, alles dazu erzählt, oder?
Vermutlich.
Vermutlich? Vermutlich.
Ich hoffe auch, dass euch das alle jetzt was gebracht hat.
Also ganz ehrlich, man kann natürlich jetzt über die Vision Pro der einen oder
der anderen Meinung sein. Das wird auf jeden Fall heiß diskutiert.
Wer die Möglichkeit hat, sich das mal anzuschauen und nicht selber gesehen hat,
kann ich nur raten, mal diese komische Demo da im Apple Store zu machen,
wenn man einen in der Reichweite hat. Das ist auch nicht jeder Apple Store.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Apple Stores in Berlin gibt,
aber zwei hatten das Angebot.
Ja, ich rede ja nicht von Berlin nur, sondern generell Deutschland und bin mir
nicht ganz sicher, ob alle Apple Stores in Deutschland, Österreich,
Schweiz auch immer eine haben. Das kann sein, das weiß ich bloß nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall waren da massiv Termine frei.
Jaja, das ist jetzt nicht überrannt. Also das meinten die auch.
Also wer einen Apple Store in der Nähe hat, einfach Termin klicken,
hingehen, freundlich sein zu den...
Dinosaurier angucken.
...die den Leuten, die einem das Ding vorführen. Und ansonsten, ich meine,
Kaufreflex hat es bei mir jetzt nicht ausgelöst, obwohl sie mir noch eine nette
E-Mail geschickt haben, so nach der Art, das ist die Konfiguration,
die du dir angeguckt hast und darunter ist ein blauer kaufenbutton.
Gut dann sind wir eigentlich durch oder?
Ich denke mal.
Du denkst das mal. Wenn du das denkst, dann ist es so.
Ich habe keine Einwände, euer Ehren.
Wir haben gerade jetzt doch noch mal kurz geguckt, die Auflösung pro Auge.
Der Quest 3 ist 2000 mal 2200 und die von der Vision 3600 mal 3200.
Also es ist ungefähr ein Drittel mehr, aber dann eben auch nur.
Es ist nicht das Doppelte, nicht das Vierfache.
Ja gut, vielleicht sagst du nochmal die Zahl.
Bitte.
Also wir können ja mal einfach runden. 2000 versus...
Du sagst mir jetzt die Zahl.
2064 mal 2208.
2208 sind 4,5 Millionen Pixel.
Genau, 4 Millionen Pixel und die Vision hat 3660 mal 3200.
Das sind 11,7 Millionen.
Ja, das ist ungefähr die Pixelanzahl von 4K. Also 4K sind um die 10 Millionen.
Also Faktor 2,6.
Mehr Pixel, ja. Es kann natürlich sein, dass die Displays tatsächlich besser
sind, dass sie weniger Zwischenräume zwischen den Pixeln haben.
Also du siehst natürlich bei gleicher Pixelgröße mehr Gitter,
wenn die Pixel kleiner sind.
Und mehr Zwischenräume zwischen den Gittern sind. Keine Ahnung,
wie die Displays so gebaut werden.
Der Schwarzwert ist viel besser, dank OLED.
Es kann natürlich durchaus sein, dass sie tatsächlich ein bisschen unschärfer
ist und dadurch du sie nicht so viel Gitter siehst.
Aber ja, also ich fand sie jetzt nicht unscharf, aber ja.
Your mileage may vary.
Ansonsten halt eher Crickets und Tumbleweed Weed im App Store.
Das ist halt das, wo ich sage so, hey, was will ich denn damit,
wenn ich damit nichts tun kann?
So, Leute, jetzt machen wir hier mal zu den Laden und spielen das beliebteste
Outro, Podcast-Outro Deutschlands ab.
Oder? Das ist schon das Beste. Mindestens, ich finde es am besten.
Gibt nichts Besseres. So, sagen wir noch schön Tschüss. Nächstes Mal bin ich
aus der Ferne mit dabei, aber Freakshow geht es natürlich weiterhin.
Wir sind schon ganz aufgeregt.
Und ihr seid schon ganz aufgeregt. Ich auch. Und dann gucken wir mal,
was dabei rauskommt. Also wir sagen Tschüss. Bis bald.
Tschüss.